Either present the actual instances of
the behavior or shut the [__] up.
It's so annoying. Pisco, have you
considered that that [music] you're not
comparing two identical things right
now? So why are you saying it on the not
identical? Pisco
going for the [__] thorough.
Literally the biggest betrayal I've ever
seen. [music]
He's being such a slippery, worthless
piece of [__] man. Truly, this is the
most embarrassing showing I have seen in
a debate, months, years. I truly [music]
like it it it's been a long time, guys.
Hutch and Pisco have been talking for
[__] ages. It's already 3 hours long.
I don't if people haven't known about
Pisco for a long time. Back when Sunday
was going after Erodite originally,
Pisco and Sunday had like I believe a
like 16hour debate,
they like literally it was like they
woke up, they started fighting on
Twitter, they got on a call on a stream
and they just argued basically until
they couldn't go any longer. They lit
they literally
just went. It was like it was like 12 to
16 hours. It was like ridiculous. It was
insane.
So
yeah, if if peace go, [laughter]
it is like unstoppable force immovable
object. Yeah, if he's going find someone
that just won't budge, he will just keep
keep going forever. So good. So good.
Respect it so much. So yeah, we're going
to take a look. I think this is going to
be awesome. H versus Pisco on the Ethan
Klein lawsuits. Indiana with like a lack
of federal funds and they and more
Republicans in the state legisle voted
against this measure than voted for it
already dead whatever it becomes down
the line when it's no longer just a cult
of personality around Trump I'm not
suggest
>> or all sorts of things including but not
limited to legal action taken by
individuals and I think that there's a
lot of people who care about that and I
think that you care about
>> part of of the conversation because
>> fundamentally I think it's about power
it's about who controls not on what
principles
power is um ought to be divided. It's
like who are the identities of the
personalities? Um and it almost feels
like the policy disagreements are either
afterthoughts or the cont
>> they don't even really have like a lot
of policy disagreements. Like most of
the policy disagreements is about like
immigration like should we be like Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Like should we be
should we be should we end the H1BV?
Ethan Klein, you had some thoughts. We
we dabbled a little bit on the pod. Why
don't we unpack a little bit more? So
basically I have this view that um
[clears throat]
I think that we need to be clear
regarding what we're talking about in
this controversy.
Are we talking about the legal
justification for a lawsuit? Are we
talking about the ethical justification
for bringing the lawsuit by which we
mean ought the lawsuit be brought? Or
are we talking about like other
misconduct? Does that affect the ethical
outlook? and I kind of have different
views on this lawsuit. Um, and I can
talk about my incentives or even
commenting on it. Um, but in general, I
think that a lot of my views have been
misconstrued
or misinterpreted to be something that
they're not. And I think that what I'm
proposing is not actually of like a a
very controversial view at all. And that
most of the disagreement with my view um
has to do with like perceptions about my
motivations or about relevance or
emphasis. And so that's basically like
kind of my starting set of assumptions.
It's like let's be clear about what
we're talking about and let's see if we
agree and then let's talk about why it
matters.
>> I don't know if I have a strong interest
in having a conversation about the
lawsuits have been brought. That's not
>> why
>> that's not really the thing that
interests me too much because
>> um
>> Oh, let me give you a point of contact.
Right. [laughter]
>> He can't defend them. Cuz he can't
defend it.
Dude,
how does it start so bad? How does it
start this bad? I don't understand.
How does it start this bad and go for so
long?
I'm going to have a [__] aneurysm
listening to this. I think
I think I'm going to die listening to
this.
>> Oh, go for it. I mean I so like that to
me is like the least part of the
interesting part of of the conversation
because like that seems totally
subjective like and it's difficult to
unpack that you know like I don't know
what I would do if if I was in his
>> you mean dude it's like [laughter]
it's totally subjective so we can't
possibly argue about it. If two people
could have differing opinions about
something, then we can't possibly argue
it and try to determine whether one
whether one opinion is more justified
than the other. There's no way cuz it's
subjective. So, how could you possibly
have an argument about it?
I can't. I can't, dude. I just
[laughter] can't.
[snorts] I'm already so mad. I'm already
enraged. He's just the dumbest person
online. He's just so dumb.
He's dumber than Hassan by far if I was
in his spot. And like you you for
example I think you said that he has a
strong case, right? So like if these
laws if these copyright regulations or
statutes or whatever they are um if they
exist and somebody abused them and he's
you know using the legal mechanism to
get a remedy for that then you you know
are we saying that he that that means
that it was justified or like what kind
of angle are you going do you want to
have a conversation about? Should he
have brought the lawsuits?
>> Well I think that's a conversation that
a lot of people do want to have. Whether
you want to have it, I'm not sure. But
I'll just to give you a point of
contact, I stopped by your stream a
little bit recently and I said hello,
but I heard
>> all all forms of litigation are okay,
actually. Wow. So, you're just like okay
with what Trump suing ABC and Trump
suing the BBC and Trump like
he [__] Obviously, sometimes
someone might be able to technically
extract a win
under the legal system that's separate
from the morality. You [__] idiot.
This is like literally you figure this
out when you're 13 usually. HCH
>> talking about like the propriety of like
Denim's statement and analyzing whether
she should have said this, whether she
was throwing Casey Tron under the bus.
And so in that context, what we're
really talking about whether it's
subjective or not. Listen, I take all
this kind of normative analysis um to be
subjective in the sense that we're just
talking about would what do you think
about ethics? What do you think ought to
happen? I I do think that people have a
desire to talk about the underlying
ethical justification for all sorts of
things including but not limited to
legal action taken by individuals. Um
and I think that there's a lot of people
who care about that. And I think that
you care about regardless of its
subjectiveness, the ethics of certain
people's conduct surrounding this,
including um the sensible triggering
incidents that brought this about the
CPS call, the um conduct of the
snarkers. Like this is all norms laden.
And so I think it's a little bit much to
accept that people are like it's
irrelevant to talk about ethics. It's
irrelevant to talk about moral
justification because everyone's talking
about it and um if someone asks me about
it, I I want to be clear about where I
stand. Um and the more and separate
apart from that, I think there's a
broader norm that ought be established
to like not blatantly lie to your
audiences and all of us.
>> Word of the day is culpable. I've been
seeing some culpable posting.
I've been seeing some culpable posting.
I'm I'm excited. Look, I'm edge of my
seat. I'm at the edge of my seat.
>> Like take do this kind of debunking [__]
when there's like if Kim Pool is accused
of lying about the shooting or whatever.
No one's stopping to say like, "Huh, why
are you calling out lies? What do you
care?"
>> My Pisco is my golem. Pisco is my golem
now. Okay, this is what this what our
Destiny legitimately believes. By the
way, Pisco is my golem. Golem now.
Okay, I'm sending I'm sending him in to
Strangle Hutch. Load the box next.
Ethan is lying about any kind of
motivation uh for to like protect his IP
or do you call it IP or copyrighted
content
>> but but you're saying that that's a lie
because the real motivation is just like
personal grievance but why can't it be
both
conversation and and I definitely want
to have this conversation
>> I mean to me it's to me it's very
obvious that he's motivated by both
because like he he's already on the
record as being someone who was trying
to um bring attention to what he
considered to be like lazy react content
And what what what the three people that
he sued did went even beyond that. Like
it was beyond just like lazy react. It
was malicious in nature. You say that
has no like bearing on the case. This
like malice or whatever. Um but but but
the fact remains that they they were
being malicious about it. Like they were
they were they were openly advertising
that they their intention was to siphon
views. And it happens to be the case
that all three of those people were
doing were participating in an internet
pylon that was like some of the most
vicious behavior from online communities
that I've ever seen in all my years of
being on the internet. Like what they
how they behaved around the whole CPS
thing was [__] vicious. It was
[__] vicious. And so like I think he
was motivated by both of
>> So Pisco is going to have to So like
dude, this is I was literally thinking
this through. I've been thinking this
through the last day or so. like how
would I let's say I was talking to Hutch
or Loner Box like someone who is that in
deep
how do you have this conversation and I
think you literally you have to separate
everything out you have to very
surgically separate each individual
thing out you have to go through okay
motivation
what what do you believe is Ethan's
motivation do you believe Ethan stated
motivation you have to run down okay
Ethan stated motivation. His stated
criteria and stated motivation cannot
possibly be true because obviously this
would never protect anyone from Sony and
Disney. Obviously he couldn't tell
whether they were going to say them
reacting when he stop you had to go
through every step of this. Knock that
one down then go like okay next why is
this justified? Why is it justified? So
what have they done to Ethan that makes
okay? Let's start with Caseyron. What
has Caseyron done to Ethan that makes it
justified to sue her? And then you have
to go down each one and then you have to
go through each individual lie on each
one as well. So you have to go through
the whole CPS [__] with Denims where
they lie about Denim's doing CPS and
whatever the [__] and talk about Ethan's
defamation walk back and all this [__]
like you literally you have to go
through everything. It has to be
literally separated out. And I know that
if you start talking to someone about
this, I know Hutch is going to do this
here. They will keep you will knock
something down and they will keep
bringing it back. You'll knock something
down and they'll keep dragging it back.
So you'll say you'll get through the
idea of it being a copyright protection
motivation. The idea that it's to
protect the react community. You'll
knock that down and I know later on it
will come back. You'll be saying, "Okay,
so Casey Tron's lawsuit wasn't justified
cuz she didn't do anything to to Ethan."
And they'll come back with, "Yeah, but
she should have been smarter because she
was she was infringing on the
copyright." And you know, someone's
going to sue them eventually. They'll
come back with that eventually. You
know, that will reappear and you'll have
to go back through and redo like a whole
[__] thing. Like, I can just see it
in my head so clearly. I can see how it
goes in my head so clearly.
And I can just see if that's what
happens here, I will be I will feel so
vindicated.
of those things like was it right to
bring the lawsuits? I don't know if I
would have done it, you know, but I
understand why he did it. I don't know
if that's a copout answer, but I
understand why he did it.
>> Yeah. So, I I just want to make sure
we're not talking past each other. So, I
I definitely want to have a conversation
about ought he have done it. But before
we get into that, I just like want to
make sure that you think it's worthwhile
to even have that conver like we're not
even talking about the thing itself.
It's like people will question why do
why should we care about these ethicals
and whether good or bad? And I thought I
was hearing something approaching that
critique or that observation from you.
And so before we get into like the
actual meat and potatoes, which I I do
fundamentally reject the view you just
presented on different grounds, I I want
to make sure that you consider that
conversation to be valuable.
>> Let me give you here because like
>> like intellectually valuable. What do
you mean?
>> So people will say things like this.
Peace go this is a boring conversation.
Who the [__] cares about whether these
lawsuits were the right thing to bring
or not? or like I don't really or
someone might say something like I don't
care whether it was right or wrong to
bring the lawsuit and I just want to
make sure you're not proposing those
views of like indifference like maybe
you are indifferent as to whether it was
right or wrong to do but presumably like
you think that that's a worthwhile
conversation when analyzing especially
um now this is getting a little bit into
the argument itself but I I still do
want to have the meta conversation first
to make sure that we both agree this is
a valuable conversation that we want to
have um for someone who presents a lot
of his lawsuits or his legal stuff as
vindicated
>> let's go bashing his head against the
brick wall again and we love him for it
and we love him for it. It is some
broader interest either in a particular
group or in a broader community. I think
that we ought care about whether we
agree with the assessments being uh
rendered by Ethan and co.
>> It's not that I'm indifferent. It's it's
more that I'm agnostic. Like I can I
could you can and maybe that sounds like
a copout answer like I want it both
ways.
>> No, it's like it's not that I'm avoiding
taking a firm position. It's just I can
understand why he did it and I can't
tell you if I would have made the same
decision because I've never been in that
position. I've never I don't know what
it's like to have children and then have
government called to your home
>> to like try to force you to justify CPS
to be allowed to continue to have
guardianship over your own kids. Like I
don't know how I would have felt in that
moment. I don't know what kind of
actions I would take after the fact. Um
but and I'm also sympathetic to the idea
of like [__] I mean that must really
suck to to be bogged down in that kind
of litigation. It's not like I have no
sympathy for people like Caseyron or or
Frogan. Like even though I find their
conduct to be pretty disgusting what
they did with Ethan and Elen and how
they were joking about the CPS calls and
you could argue that Denim's helped to
enable it with the way that she was
running her chat on the particular day
that that po
>> dude literally it's like so predictable.
He thinks that the chat was accurately
represented in that clip, man. He thinks
we're going to literally Dude,
let's just let's just hit let's just
[snorts] bring up the evidence for this
stuff. Where is our channel?
>> Denims.
>> Where's the chat thing?
Anyways,
>> Denims, by the way, was the real villain
of the video.
>> Yeah, here we go. So, this is what Hutch
believes. Touch believes this is denim's
chat.
>> This is a live view of the chat.
>> Touch believes this is actually top
right.
>> I made a good point. You said, "Is this
every comment?" I believe this is a live
view of the chat.
>> What about the top right? I thought
these were
>> No, it's this I think when you full
screen it. No, this is an edit. It's a
cutout of the full chat. It's just
enlarged over the screen. Yeah. [music]
>> So, Hutch believes this is the real
chat. So, this is
>> the first and last frames of the video
that he played. I searched for the top
and the bottom messages in my Chatterino
history. The first one is line 14,472.
The second is 15,428
and they're 5 minutes apart. That's 956
messages in 5 minutes. He showed 65
messages, which is less than 7% of the
messages from that time period. The
funniest thing is that only three of
those 65 messages are ever even on the
screen in the two-minute video that he
featured. So now I'm sure you're
wondering why someone
>> So total [__] insane lie that Hutch
fully believes and is using to justify
this that he's never looked into even
though the evidence has been out there.
Thank you for the $5 crab navy general
CPS's institution that ought to ought to
exist. But also a single visit from it
is so traumatizing that it scars people
forever. I love liberals
up came up and um but even with all that
I'm sympathetic to like [__] I wouldn't
want to be in that kind of a situation
but you know I don't know that to be
satisfactory for you but I just I don't
know what I would do in that position. I
really don't but I understand why he did
it.
>> I don't I don't take I don't think
there's anything inconsistent with you
saying you're agnostic on the ethical
question but also maintaining that it's
a worthwhile conversation to have.
That's what I want like the I want to
say those are distinct questions.
Whether or not you have a firm view
about whether it's good or bad is
different than whether or not you think
it's a conversation. That the
conversation about whether it's good or
bad is worth having. And what I want to
avoid more than anything is someone
after the fact saying, "Who the [__]
cares about this shit?" Or like you
saying, "I don't even give a [__] about
the conversation." Like clearly you
care. We're having this conversation.
It's maybe like the third or fourth time
we've had a conversation about this. You
you have a vested interest. He's trying,
dude. Pisco literally I see what Kilo
was saying earlier
>> about uh being able to see Pisco's
argument just like so far ahead like the
the the building blocks like it's
everything is so telegraphed. You know
exactly where it's going. Why he's
saying everything like okay Hutch
you you're you are literally you have
walked into this raped. You have walked
into you you are already dead Hutch.
Okay. Now, just say yes or no to the
questions when prompted. Okay. Yes or
no, Hajj? Yes or no?
>> Hey, I'm just going to be honest. You
cover some of the other conduct at issue
here that you're weighing the respective
normative weight of what the parties are
doing. You're thinking about is it good
uh for Denims to throw Casey Tron under
the bus? Is it okay for, you know,
Hassan [__] to not donate? And so, I I
think it's a little much to accept that
this is a conversation that the ethics
of bringing the lawsuit. Who cares about
that? But all the other aspects uh you
know the ethical assessments of the
other conduct that stuff is interesting
to me and I will comment on it. So just
to be super clear I I do want to get
into the actual the question here and
then and let's also talk about the other
issue the legal issue whether I think
it's important or not. Um and the and
the lies for sure that you think that
this is a valuable conversation or one
that at least that you're interested in
because if you say I'm not interested
whether okay no but I I want if you want
what I want I just want you like this is
what I want. I want us to agree that
this conversation it matters. It matters
whether or not Ethan did the right
thing. Doesn't it matter to you?
I don't know how to evaluate that in an
objective sense though. [laughter]
That's what I'm saying. I really don't.
I this is such such a messy thing for
me. Like I can't I don't think I can
give you an answer of like this is
unequivocally bad or this is I'm not
saying that's getting into the meat
about whether it's good or bad. That's a
separate question. I'm being very
precise here. You care whether or not
like you care about the conversation.
You care about um the relative
arguments. You care about thinking
regarding whether this is good or bad.
And I I think that's clear. I mean, if
you're really going to say, "Well, I
spent all this time talking about the
ethical implications of Denim's conduct,
of Hassan's conduct, of the snarker's
conduct, but I'm not going to consider
the ethical implications of Ethan." I'll
consider it. It's fine. If if you have a
case to make in terms of like why you
think he shouldn't have made the case,
then then I'm genuinely open to being
persuaded. There's there's a universe
where you could convince me that it was
a wrong thing for him to do, go for it.
>> No, no, just just because I get shared
uh these people who who really don't get
it, and they're making comments like,
"Who the [__] cares?" Like, "Who ass?
Who the [__] asked whether this is good
or bad?" You guys all care about this.
We all care about these norm and the
proof is in the pudding. The fact that
we spend any time on it. The fact that
people feel vindicated and feel that
this is just desserts. Just desserts
meaning these people deserve what's
going on. That is a normative
conversation. It's saying this ought
have happened. It's good that this
happened to these people and this is uh
deserve. This is either a punishment or
some kind of um retribution or some kind
of like uh justice for Ethan. And that
is um intrinsically invoking normative
assessments. So what I don't want to
hear is this kind of like benol
statement that you get from the
Redditors that are like who the [__]
cares who asked about the antic as long
as it's legally valuable that's the only
that matters that [__] is cooked.
Agreed.
>> Um
what cooked the
>> notion the notion that the only thing
that matters is the legal argument. The
only and this is coming from someone who
obviously cares a lot about the legal
argument. My my whole reason of
examining this in the first place was
because it was a a new copyright case
and I have a an interest in copyright
and I've been following uh H3 for a
while and even their first case and I
actually you know really praise them and
if you watch my coverage I really praise
them for their initial lawsuit defense
against Bold Guy. Um but someone
>> like how how do you I I truly I'm
getting a bad sense man. I've just sent
a JTO tweet about the debate. How do you
I truly [laughter] don't understand how
you stay friends with someone like this
already. I would be literally I would be
slinging [__] slurs. If I was Pa
right now, I would be literally in
private. I would be going [__] crazy
at this guy already. The faces he's
pulling the faces he's pulling alone
make me want to just [__] throw
something, dude. Honestly, it's
He's such a performative [__] bro.
He's a totally performative [__] It
is unfucking bearable. It's crazy, man.
>> Does care about the legal argument.
Someone's saying like the only thing
that matters is whether or not it's
legal or not and whether or not they
have a good case.
>> No, no, no. I mean, yeah. Like it's
interesting conversation and like I'm So
I can I can just lay out very clearly to
you the the the
pro case, like the bullish case, the the
case for for this potentially being an
appropriate action.
>> No, don't don't do that. Hisco has laid
out six [__] times. You're not
getting into the arguments yet. You're
not getting into the arguments yet.
You're just going through. Do we care
about whether it's justified? Hutch, say
to me that it matters to you whether
this is justified past just whether
there is a legal argument or not. That's
what he said like six [__] times.
That's where we're at. He just wants you
to buy in to the idea that ethics norms
matter when presenting a civil case
>> and then and then you can tell me your
case and we can go from there. But
>> to be clear, this is not a view that you
necessarily hold. It's one that you want
to
>> No, I have it. I I hold I I hold the
view, but but again, there's like there
is a conflict in me. I'm just being 100%
transparent.
>> On the net, you think it's a good thing
that he brought these lawsuits against
>> you. You're almost like you've got
cognitive dissonance, Hutch. Is that is
that what you might call it? Cognitive
dissonance. Denims, Casey Trron, and
Frogen. Correct.
>> I think a good outcome of this happening
is the possibility that creators in that
space will do more to moderate their own
communities.
>> Right. But you understand that's a
different question.
>> That's the value that I that's the value
that I see. And so that is a potential
that is an argument in favor of Ethan
taking this action. Do it have to be
this litigation action or could it have
been a different action? I don't know.
But like that that is the strongest case
that I would make is that these these
creators existed in a world where they
were totally emboldened. They felt like
had they had total impunity. They
demonstrated no sense of responsibility
for moderating their own communities.
And in some cases, they explicitly or
implicitly egged on this kind of what I
view to be like significant harassment.
Like it is to me a really significant
form of harassment to do a CPS report
and then that ends up with a like
government intervention. That to me is
so much more a malicious CPS report that
is based either on lies or distortions,
things like that, right? Like you
wouldn't say you wouldn't say like a CPS
report by itself is um bad. It's it's
when it's informed by either lies,
distortions, or exaggerations, right?
>> They had a vendetta against
>> if it's motivated by bad stuff, either
lies or or or bad motive, some kind of
So it's not just a mere calling of CPS.
It's calling CPS on a basis that is um
improper such as trying to hurt someone,
not actually being concerned about
what's going on, uh you know, including
lies in whatever you're telling CPS or
exaggeration or things that can't be
reasonably obtained. Yeah. Okay. They
crafted a narrative about him and Ela
that they were these ultra Zionist
genocide supporters. It was a full-on
mass psychosis event for that community
with a collective audience of hundreds
of thousands or millions of people. And
in that collective audience pool, they
crafted a narrative about Ethan and Ela.
Number one, that was just a total
[__] lie. And but number two, that
that narrative that they delusionally
all convinced themselves was was true,
at least maybe some of them did, but
there were there were there was also an
element of like bad faith to this as
well. like
>> dude literally like this hodi tweet as
well like it's just so this is just real
man
this is enraging
wanted to believe that about him so it's
possible maybe the person who made the
report you know like got themselves to
believe this lie about Ethan but the
whole point is like it was fostered by
those creators they had active role in
making a lot of situations
>> they by what do you mean the the
creators like fostered this in their own
communities
>> like intended for them to call GPS Or
what did you mean?
>> They they they helped promulgate these
lies about Ethan and Ela. Okay, lies.
And in doing in doing so, wait, did you
say what lies?
>> I said no, I said okay. Lies. So, I'm so
the how they're fermenting it or how
they're fostering it isn't with a
specific intention for a kind of action,
but doing stuff that with it. Okay, go.
>> I'm not saying that, but but in the case
of I would have to go back and because
it's been a minute since this drama
kicked off. This was like a year ago or
a year and a half ago when the CPS stuff
happened. I don't even remember. But
with Denim specifically, she was um
watching like a bad empanada video where
he was doing these and you you would
agree that bad empanada is a malicious
actor, right? Like just one of the worst
malicious actors in the entire space,
right?
>> I mean that's my understanding of his
reputation. I um have seen him uh do
things that I would consider to be
malicious and so my answer is yes.
>> Like he will lie. Like he will lie, you
know, he will call people pedophiles. He
will he will lie. Like his his whole
thing is he thinks
>> consume his content. I understand that's
his reputation. I've seen instances, for
example,
>> it's not just a reputation. He has a
storied history of li like maliciously
lying about people that he identifies as
enemies.
>> I'm just telling you my uh what I have
access to. What I have access to is I
know he has a reputation for malicious
lies. I know he has a reputation for
doxing and for saying stuff and um I
know that they have their own
justifications for it, you know,
publicly available stuff, but but I kind
of have a different view on on that
issue. And I think that there are
self-standing harms and stuff that he
engages in. uh for example, regardless
of whether or not it's technically
publicly accessible. I think the certain
kind of revelations of information, even
publicly available information can
sometimes I think be considered norm
violating and um yeah, so and I've seen
it make certain connections that I I
find to be malicious. I can't recall
them though as I sit here and I'm not
going to claim to know more than I do.
>> Let's put it this way. Hassan had a no
bad empanada video policy at one point.
>> Oh my god. Shut up, man. Shut up.
either
present the actual instances of the
behavior or shut the [__] up.
It's so annoying.
>> I am going to take a shot every time
Hutch touch his nose. Pray for me,
Queenman.
>> Thank Thank you for the 50 D in the
mirror. Thank you. You appreciate it.
Thank you.
>> That's what I mean. He has a reputation
for
>> He had even he had even acknowledged
that Bad Panata was completely deranged
and unhinged. And it wasn't until Bad
Panata started doing like anti-Ethan
content and like I guess pro pro
Palestine content that that Hassan just
consciously decided to to to forgo that
or to get rid of that rule. And then he
started platforming bad repeatedly over
and over again knowingly knowing that he
that bad
like
record of malicious behavior
>> and people like people like Denims
watched this bad empanada video about
Ethan and if you again it's been like a
year and a half but like her chat on the
screen that day when she was watching
this video they were all doing like CPS
talk and and it was just like she was
making no effort to moderate. Would you
agree?
>> You think she has an affirmative
obligation to do that? Right.
>> Of course. Don't you? I'm not sure what
the standard is for. So, if people are
calling for TBS calls,
>> didn't Destiny call Sunday a PDF because
he doesn't like him? Is Hutch talking
about this Steven Bonell guy?
>> This guy's like some kind of deranged
anti- fan, I think. Thank you for the
$5. Thank you.
>> In the in the chat, I'm not sure that I
would um moderate those opinions. If if
they have the opinion, would you?
>> 1,000%.
>> Okay, you would. Come on. If you if you
had people in your chat that were like,
I don't know, Hutch seems kind of dodgy.
I think he's like beating his beating
his his uh fiance. I think we should
call the cops. You feel like you don't
think you'd have a responsibility to
jump in and be like, "No,
>> I'm not sure. What I'm telling you is I
don't have that intuition that I that
like that this is an expectation or
norm.
>> Peace is awesome." No. Peace is awesome.
Peace is awesome. Yeah. People thought
if people were saying you beating
beating your wife in my chat, I don't
have the intuition that I would ban
them.
Thank you, Pisco W. P guy. That's
awesome. [laughter]
>> That um you have an affirmative
obligation like they have deranged
chatters. Say totally unhinged stuff
like for example, you know, they should
be killing Kilar Garcia. [laughter] They
should be throwing all these illegal
immigrants into the [__] waters and
um that's their you know that was me
that was me in chat support. I go I go
into peace chat and they just support
alligator Alcatraz.
>> I guess I just I don't know if I share
that twist. Now if it's actively calling
for such things that occur, everyone
call CPS. You know, maybe that's
different. Maybe that's or if they're
saying you should Okay, then what I
[laughter] would say then I say have an
affirmative obligation, but then you
have to like
>> you have to answer the subsidiary
questions. And I do want to take a step
back in a second because I think that
we're in the weeds in a way that I'm I'm
concerned about. Uh and I'll tell you
why. You have to then see like she saw
it and she
>> What?
>> No, no, no. I'm not. Yeah. No, no.
Sorry. Sorry. I didn't mean Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, so like I think the nature of
the obligation depends on
>> his wife came in. Are you telling
everyone that you beat me? Are you are
you tell are you coming out about you
beat me? No. No. I'm not. No, no, no.
and what the uh you know what the
expectation is to read chat like often I
don't read my chat but like I want to be
clear I think there are affirmative
obligations to prevent your chat from
encouraging illegal conduct encouraging
false things encouraging you know
government associated things that for
sure but an opinion for example is so
I'll give you the following thing I
think it's justified for CPS to be
called that that be moderated
>> in a in just in a general sense or in
this particular in this particular sense
>> uh it seems based on this that like
they're eating poop and they have a
wrong opinion which I I think it's the
wrong opinion is to conclude
>> no wait hold on sorry are you talking
specifically in this context or just
generally
>> let's do abstract first and then we'll
go to this this context. Okay. So, in
general, someone said, you know, there
isn't this massive um whatever you're
characterizing as a wave of of
harassment against Ethan Klein and this
someone in your chat says, I don't know,
this is kind of [__] up. I think that
some that someone should call like I
think it would be justified. I'll put it
there.
>> If it's a good if it's a good faith
observation, sure. Obviously. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, I we can disagree with that.
But the nature of what the message is
and whether she read it, I think matters
to me. Hutch, I do want to say though, I
wanted to take a step back, right? like
like this is all stuff that I think
indicates that we care deeply about the
ethics of people's conduct online and
that we're you know we're interested
enough you know we had the conversation
about Taylor for example on the chorus
stuff and all of this matters that's
that's kind of the base route here that
said I want to be clear about whose
conduct we are assessing right because
it could be the case that the conduct to
call CPS I do believe that it would be
that it's immoral incredibly immoral to
call CPS on the basis of what Ethan said
regarding the Jardia stuff I think
that's unhinged I wouldn't do it I would
condemn people who would call CPS on
that basis um and just because though
that is unethical doesn't mean that
everything in response is also ethical.
Right? So I want to be clear about whose
conduct
we're who first
>> well we can't analyze Ethan's actions in
a vacuum though. We have to evaluate the
the the conditions that arise that led
to that.
>> But what is our like what is our
dependent variable? What what are we
trying what is the ultimate focus of our
inquiry? Are we trying to figure out
whether it's right or wrong for Ethan to
bring the lawsuit or do you want to
spend some time to build that to talk
about various different actions that
different people took regarding Ethan?
>> You had asked me I mean I I was giving
you my argument for um why litigation
>> I didn't ask you just
>> could be [laughter] justified could be a
justifiable response to what happened.
>> Okay. So
>> that's where I'm coming from with it.
>> So let's start with Casey Tron, right?
It's justified to sue Casey Tron for
copyright infringement
>> because why? Dude, legit.
>> I I would assume you
>> Dude,
it's literally like, did I not lay out
exactly this process? So, you start
going down the lawsuit to say the
lawsuit against Casey Tron is justified
because Okay, Hajj.
Because why? Because what event? Because
what instance? Because what action?
Because what behavior? Dude, it's like
let's see. Let's see how this goes. I'm
excited. I'm so excited, guy. I've never
I've never been this excited for debate
in ages, guys. You have no idea.
>> You would say a she committed copyright
infringement, right?
>> Uh you you tell me. You're the you're
the lawyer here.
>> Presumably, you wouldn't be in favor of
suing Casey Tron if you didn't think
that she committed it, right?
>> No. If it was frivolous, no.
>> And I I want to ask you because I first
of all, I don't think any of these cases
are frivolous. I
>> It's like this uh it's like that 2021
crack. It's like that 2021 cracking a
frivolous lawsuit in this context.
Um, maybe I'm I'm a bit like a purist
about the system that the system
shouldn't be used in that kind of way. I
don't I don't know. I'm just intuitively
like [laughter]
>> I think that's right. I think that we
have this intuitive notion that these
legal frameworks are here to um
represent particular things and we just
have like a structural issue with
individuals who at least in the case and
again I want to stress I don't believe
these are frivolous cases. I don't
believe they're frivolous. I don't
believe they're frivolous. In the case
of a frivolous lawsuit, we think that
the motivation in bringing that lawsuit
um that that is a predominating
structural concern and we don't want the
law to be used for an end that we
consider to be improper and that I think
is especially present when the suit
itself is frivolous because if the suit
itself is frivolous, the the chances
that what's actually being motivated are
genuine concerns under the law are much
much much much lower. So I think that
you're repeating intuition that I have
and that we all share which is the law
protects certain rights certain
vindicate certain interests and to the
extent that we are using the law to
target things that we think are improper
under those various frameworks it raises
a concern about abuse of process I'm not
saying from a legal perspective and um
moral hazard and the moral hazard here
is is especially concerning given the uh
the amount of leverage that particularly
rich person has in the context of legal
system I think a lot of people can
understand that the American legal
system is is one which is is not equal
in terms of who is trying to vindicate a
claim. So I agree with your assessment
there.
>> I have a question. I have a question
then beyond beyond frivvality. Maybe I
didn't understand what you said.
>> Sorry. So there's two two tweets I want
to look at quickly. I just refresh my
Twitter to see these
>> guys.
>> Showing it cuz I because I got it on my
timeline. Showing it because I got it on
my timeline.
Hey men and they are pigs. Crying crying
crying crying.
And these two tweets came up right next
to each other.
>> The Christmas countdown is officially
on. And you might have not
>> dude, why?
>> The Christmas countdown is officially
on. And you might have noticed a few
festive jumpers making their annual
appearance in the office. Need I say
more? Today marks Christmas jumper
dates. It's an initiative started by
Save the Children back in 2012.
>> Okay. [laughter]
The BBC is awesome. I love BBC. Is your
position that you shouldn't bring a
lawsuit against someone even if it's not
frivolous unless you are exclusively
motivated by the desire to get a
particular remedy about that case or can
is it ever appropriate to bring
litigation because you have personal
grievance with someone not necessarily
because like even if the case is valid
right like in this case you say it's
valid like is that wrong to you is that
is that an immoral use of the system to
impose that kind of consequence maybe
for some other unrelated behavior but
you're using the system in that kind of
way is that what you're saying your
moral position is
>> what I'm suggesting to you is merely I I
will get to what my I think my standards
are is that there are situations in
which you know it might not be a crime
to file a frivolous lawsuit though it's
often unethical. um that motivations
behind bringing a lawsuits matter and
someone who is for example we'll take an
easy case suppose that Ethan Klein were
purely motivated 100% not any other
percent 100% motivated with the specific
purpose of um silencing his critics by
filing um justified lawsuits under the
law
>> you think he was trying to you think
he's trying to silence these people
>> this is a hypothetical
>> we'll get there yeah so hypothetical I'm
not saying that this is necessarily what
occurred I'm giving you a stylist
example just to prove the point that if
it were the case, right, if it were the
case that the only motivation, the pure
motivation, this is the easiest case,
that's why I'm making it easy on myself,
um, were to silence critics because he
felt he didn't like their criticism, uh,
he felt that the criticism was like
untrue or something or that he didn't
like that they said it. And that's why
he was bringing otherwise valid claims
of copyright infringement that you would
think that that was bad.
If he was off base with respect to what
his opinion,
>> no, no, no. uh his judgment about like
what they said about him. Like in my
opinion, like you brought up you brought
up the idea of like him using the legal
system in this kind of way, but he is
responding to a community of people that
used the legal system against him in a
way that I would argue is worse.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But but Hutch, I'm what I'm
giving it was a response to that.
>> He's sitting back in the dark. Yes. Yes.
He's back at his uh parents place or his
his mom's place. He's he's in he's
chilling. So like so so in in your
hypothetical it it it depends on like
what was being said about him like
>> right so I'm trying to simplify only
because if you don't
>> basically repeat himself three times
hoping Hutch comprehends even half a
sentence
>> me this hypothetical and the
conversation's over right if you say I
don't give a [__] that his motivation is
to silence his critics as long as
there's a valid claim I don't have a
problem with it then we don't need to
get into the weeds at all right because
you you granted the easiest
>> this is what I'm I'm telling you is that
like we can't we can't evaluate this
without getting into specifics about
like what you're what is being said
about him in this hypothetical. So like
if he's using the legal system to
silence critics because they didn't like
his opinions about things, then yeah, I
would say that that's an immoral use of
the system. That that would be that
would that would be overreach. That
would be too far.
>> He hasn't moved back home to be a
streamer. He still lives away. He's back
home for the holidays. Jimberly, come on
now.
>> But if they're saying if they're
spreading lies about him about like
abusing his children, for example, then
that's a different conversation
entirely, right?
>> We're just saying all else equal. And I
would add like a kind of um there could
be certain extenduating circumstances
where even a a desire to spec with the
only desire is to silence one's critics
if there really is some overriding
concern in terms of like the world's
about to blow up and if you don't bring
the lawsuit even though it's motivated
by this thing like this two weeks
Christmas do don't Hispanics have like
strong family and [__] on that on they
all about that going back and seeing
seeing your mom and [__] I feel that's a
that's a big Hispanic trope.
I can think of situations in which I
would grant it. But in general, this is
why I'm using a styized example of it,
which I like a simplified one that's
not, you know, we can't read minds in
the real world, right? We we don't know
for certain all the time what people's
intentions are. We have to rely on
circumstantial evidence. The only reason
I'm giving you're saying yes for you to
grant me the easy case. So we have a
base to work with because if you don't
grant me that and if you say I don't
really give a [__] if your only
motivation, if your pure motivation all
else equal is to silence your critics,
then we don't then the conversation on
ethics just ends there, right? because
then like all we have to talk about is
like I guess the lies and the legal
validity of the case. But the the
ethical stuff kind of falls by the
wayside if you just don't grant me that
example and now
>> if if he was trying to use the system to
generally just silence his critics then
that would be bad.
>> Okay. Yes.
>> All right. And um you would also agree
that all else equal you know you can
think of uh situations in which this is
not the case. lying about your intention
regarding a lawsuit that independent of
whether the lawsuit it filing lawsuit
itself is bad in general lying about why
you're following uh filing a lawsuit is
itself bad right
>> I mean lying in a vacuum is bad there's
a content element to this where like
Ethan Klein is this public persona and I
think if you if you if you ask his
audience like his his dedicated fans
that like watch all of his shows they
will tell you that Ethan is like a very
kind of like petty person and doesn't
really make any effort to hide it. So
there's him like, you know, maliciously
lying, actually like trying to do actual
subtrifuge or deception, and then
there's like him like being koi, right?
Like you understand that that there's a
difference in those kinds of like
versions of dishonesty, right?
>> Oh, no. What you're suggesting is a kind
of like uh open umness or kind of like
koi wink wink nod nod where, you know,
literally it might be a lie, but
everyone kind of understands what's
going on. And so we don't really
interpret as a lie because it's kind of
like a farce, right? Um so I can totally
acknowledge that distinction for sure.
No, that's not what I'm trying to get
at. What I'm merely suggesting is all
else equal if someone you wouldn't be
like it's good for Ethan to lie about
his motivations. You would be like it's
bad to lie about. Yeah. Yeah. Like now
there could be a very broad sense there
could be some extenduating circumstance
where if he doesn't lie about his
motivation the world will blow up or you
know they'll take away his kids or
something like that and and there can be
some more but in general like we even
think this of our politicians. We don't
like it when our politicians lie. In
general we don't we don't think that's
good and we think that there's a good
norm in making sure that our public
communicators are being frank and being
upfront and it's distasteful to us. We
don't like it. Right. That's this is
just establishing because what will
happen Hutch and it's not really
specific to you is people will say
things like who the [__] cares if he
lied. I guess everyone just kind of
assumed that he lied. I what it matters
to people like these kinds of lies
matter and it matters when they do it
right. It matters when Ben Aiden lies.
It matters when Hassan lies. It matters
when Denim's lies. Fair.
>> Yes. But I feel like we just I we can't
just skip over what I just what I just
said a moment ago which is essentially
just like not all lies are created
equal. Like we should not we should not
evaluate all lies as the same just like
it's just lie equal bad.
>> No doubt. So, for example, on top of
many other context, when they lie about
like the fact that they um you know,
this thing that comes to mind right now
is they lied about whether Costa Rica
would accept Philarber or Garcia as a
third country removal and even though
they said yes, we would love to accept
him. You don't have to send him to
[__] Liberia or Africa. Uh like
there's no reason to do that. You can
just send him here. And when Trump lies
about that, I'm like, yes, this is a
worse lie than a potential lie about a
copyright lawsuit. Okay? All I'm just
saying though is not that there aren't
lies that one lie can be better or
worse. If you lie about whether you know
your girlfriend looks fat in a dress, if
you lie about like, you know, I'm not
saying that all lies are created equal.
What I'm just mainly saying is in
general we would be against Ethan in the
sense of we would condemn him lying
about his intentions. We would say it's
bad, right? Like misleading his audience
about uh the reason behind a lawsuit.
And I think that you would grant me that
fair.
>> But what's the val like? Yes. But like
what's the value of this hypothetical
when we know the particulars?
>> Why don't we just get to the
particulars? Like you're trying to
establish this framework. You know,
you're trying to get me on this journey.
>> I I don't want it to be the case that I
get you to agree that there's a lie and
then you be like, but I don't care.
>> But I just hang on. I just I just said a
moment ago. I don't think that like I
think when Ethan talks I think everybody
knows what motivated
>> okay he literally can't walk down it
because he's just like this is the thing
where someone feels they are on shaky
ground and they just have to throw up
roadblocks constantly try to stop the
conversation moving ahead he's trying to
like preempt now he's trying to like
start to preempt where he's getting
boxed in and he's kind of missing it and
it doesn't he doesn't understand he
doesn't understand the topic well enough
to actually like lie through it. He is
just like authentically [__] Thank
you for the $10, Jimboy. When talking
about lying, first we must determine
must determine I mean whether recipient
is entitled to the truth. This why we
must accept famous takes about Asian
cinema, fashion and heterosexuality.
Thank you Jim. Thank you
Ethan in the first place. And I I I
think it is both of these things like
the personal grievance that he had with
with these people for their contribution
to his family's very real like suffering
and harassment. And I think he also
cares about um malicious react content
as evidenced by his previous history of
addressing.
>> I know your position is that there is no
evidence he lied or the evidence you
don't believe that he necessarily lied
or that he did lie at all. I understand
that that's your position that he didn't
in fact lie. What I'm trying to suggest
to you is if he did, you can understand
why someone would condemn it and that
>> What do you think he lied about though?
Why don't we get to that? What do you
think he lied about?
>> Okay, let's let's get it. Let's get
right to it. I think he lied that his
motivation for the lawsuit was to
protect the React community. That's
number one. That's the first lie. So,
I've identified a lie and uh you can you
can confront me and say he never
actually said that. I think that would
be an absurd thing to say. Number two
lie, he lied when he said that Casey
Tron's apology was sincere. I think that
those at a bare minimum are two uh
significant lies that we should if true
and I think you should grant me it. If
it's true he lied about those two things
or either of those two things you would
condemn it. Fair?
>> I think uh not necessarily no because I
think that I think I I think I agree
with you that he put a little peppered a
little mustard on on the idea that Casey
Tron was being sincere. I think he was
kind of
>> I think it was a kind of gloating for
him. I think it was a kind of figned man
mag being like magnanimous.
>> You don't think he was being sincere
when he told his audience not to attack
Casey Tron and that this was a sincere
apology?
>> No, no. I I think he was being sincere
there. I think he was trying to do you
think
>> he was trying to mitigate like Yeah. Or
or maybe he was maybe honestly maybe he
was feeling magnanimous in the moment.
But when you when you watched I watched
>> like he can't even keep it straight. He
doesn't even know what he thinks.
[snorts]
>> I can't take it. I can't [__] take
this [__] man. God, it's so annoying.
>> The opening of that stream and the vibes
were pretty clear. Like he opened the
stream. I mean that was a [__]
victory lap. Like he was loading like he
was gloating throughout the whole
stream.
>> Do you think that in the moments when he
said Casey Tron's being sincere, don't
attack Casey Tron. We understand her
plight. We understand what's going on.
You think that was part of the kind of
like wink wink loading or you think that
he was being sincere when he was trying
to tell his audience not to go after
her. And if he wasn't being sincere, you
got another problem there, right?
Because then he's wink winking and
saying to his audience, you should
continue to do it. So you got
>> No, no, no. I I think he was being
sincere like both things both things can
be true. Both things like
he can, you know, like Yeah.
You can be sincere and not sincere at
the same time. Actually, guys, didn't
you know that? Didn't you know that?
>> Have a better angel in in himself in the
moment to dissuade like future
harassment.
>> But I I recognize that there's a
difference in terms of whether something
is a lie if there's a kind of general
understanding that this is some kind of
force or display where you're not
expected to believe it. But you don't
think that he was trying to do that with
respect to his statements about guys,
Casey Tron, I believe this is a very
sincere apology, very nice apology.
Don't go after her. You think when HE
DID THAT THAT WASN'T THAT RIGHT? That
wasn't him being insincere. He was being
sincere, wasn't he?
>> No, I think that was him trying to be
responsible in terms of like moderating
his community.
>> So, was he being sincere
or
>> maybe? I don't know. I I think like
listen, I think I think I don't know
Ethan that well to be honest with you. I
don't really know. Like I can't speak to
his character, but I have seen him in
the past demonstrate sympathy for people
even people that he didn't like. So, for
all I know in that moment like he can,
like I said, both of the things can be
happening at the same time. So he can
feel a sense of satisfaction that that
he got um like like justice was served
like there were there were consequences
for bad behavior that negatively
impacted him and so shameful.
>> And at the same time he can also have a
part of him that that that that wanted
to be like responsible with his
moderating of his community in that
moment to to prevent there from the the
the war or whatever from from blowing up
even further.
>> I'm trying to say he can be motivated by
multiple things at the same time.
>> So I'm not when you say he can be
motivated by things, it's very
important, right? And I'm not trying to
just be like super anal about how we use
the words, but it really matters. Like
when we say can, like I will always
grant that it can be the case. If what
you mean by can is it doesn't entail a
logical contradiction. Right? So if you
ask me, isn't it possible that Ethan
could have two motives? I'm going to say
yes, it is possible. By which I mean it
is not entailing a logical
contradiction. So you just have to be
very very careful when you say that
because I'm going to every time you say
that going to say if by possible, do you
mean logically possible? If by do you
mean it entails a contradiction?
>> It is logically possible. I'll say it
that way. It is logically possible to be
to gloat and to show sympathy for your,
you know, conquered foe at the same
time.
>> What I'm telling you is it's it's
logically possible for you to be able to
jump to the moon right now.
>> All we mean by logical possible mean
what are you talking about?
>> How is that logically possible?
>> Because the definition of logical
possibility, the modality of possibility
we're talking about there is
specifically about whether or not
there's a contradiction entailed by it.
So I would be when I say something like
Ethan
>> I would be contradicting the laws of
physics by
>> Right. So that that's like a different
like if you take as given the laws of uh
physics then you can establish a
contradiction in that the laws of
physics. Okay. I don't but but then
you're introducing some oh my god he's
getting stuck on the hypothetical race
stuck on the [__] analogy. He's so
[__] and he will never realize how
dumb he is. It's hilarious man. It's
[__] hilarious
these kind of rules of physics and these
external rules that aren't necessitated
by the uh situation itself. And so
that's why it matters to talk about this
because what people will hear when you
say, "Isn't it possible that Ethan Klein
has two motives?" And I answer yes to
that is, "Oh, well, he just gave the
game away because he's saying that it's
possible to have two motives."
>> No, no, I'm giving you I'm giving you my
best answer. I'm giving but I'm in the
absence of certainty because I have not
personally reached out to Ethan and
asked him like what motivated you in
that moment. So I don't know.
>> Have you reached out to Trump and asked
him the motivations about his malicious
acts?
>> And by the way, when I do this
comparison, I'm not saying Ethan is the
same as Trump, guys. Okay. Are you
suggest [laughter] I want to make I want
to I want to inoculate myself against
that. When I made the comparison to
Trump, I wasn't saying Ethan is like
Trump. It's a comparison.
>> But it's like But it's like you're
you're demanding that I have certainty
and I don't. I I'm giving you my my
vibe, my best guess from my observation.
>> I'm not asking you to say 100%. But I'm
at possible and you're like, well then,
you know, like you don't have anything.
He's asking for anything. He's asking
you to say I think X. That's not
certain. Just I think X or I think Y.
I believe X to be true. Ethan's
motivation seems to be Y.
That's good enough. But he's not doing
that. He's going, "Oh, well, couldn't it
be possible that maybe like everything's
true at the same time? Isn't it possible
that like Ethan could think literally
everything all at the same time? Even
things that are directly contradictory
and totally mutually exclusive?"
No, Hutch. Actually, that's not
possible. Hutch, can you please follow
the conversation? That'd be appreciated.
Thank you, Hutch.
I can't prove to you right now that
you're not a brain in a vat, that Ethan
doesn't actually exist, that you're just
a figment of my imagin. Like there's so
much that I cannot prove 100%, right?
Like I can't prove that 100% that we
live on a sphere. By 100% we mean to an
epistemic certainty. So understand what
I'm saying here is we are stepping way
back to talk about like possibility in
the abstract. And the only reason I'm
doing this,
>> you are you're because you're debating.
It's like it's it's really not an
attempt to debate debating [laughter]
right now, dude. That was the bitchiest
I've ever heard someone
like.
Let's let's get that back to normal
speed. That whining tone
>> and the only reason I'm doing this you
are you're because you're debating it's
not it's it's really not
>> you're debating me right now.
in time to debate bro because what will
happen is you'll ask isn't it possible
that Ethan has two motivations and if I
say no I sound ridiculous because of
course people can have mixed motives
right of course that's why I don't think
that why don't we why don't we skip to
that right so I just want to clarify
what you think right so I I just this is
really important I want to clarify when
I say he doesn't have mixed motive I'm
not saying it's impossible for a person
to have mixed motive I'm saying the
evidence that we have is I think strong
that this motivation, the particular
motivation that I'm citing isn't what's
actually motivating. But but before we
get into that, because I do want to get
into that, I just want to like get an
agreement. If he did s like lie about
Casey Tron's apology and whether it was
sincere, are you suggesting that you
would say that that was good to do?
>> If the purpose of the lie was to prevent
harassment, for example, would you say
that that would be bad? I think that it
w that if you felt that an apology on
anti-semitism on whether or not uh it
was right to invoke Asmin Gold's mother
whether or not you're apologizing to
your very employees that you are
eliciting a known insincere apology why
to protect an insincere person would you
make that if you were a principled
person I would say yeah I don't want you
to lie to your audience about whether
the apology is sincere based on your
feeling that you have to like protect
someone who's being insincere.
Doesn't that make sense?
>> But but but if Thank you, Jim.
>> Co's painstaking boundary setting and
definition grounding suggests he's on a
no damage playthrough of Golem run.
Everyone lend him your power. Back
slashz/
I need to see this conversation with
Loner Box now. Like this is funny cuz
this is like good hutch hate content
like it is Pisco uh bashing his head
against the brick wall. But I need to
see the low in the box convers cuz the
low in the box conversation can actually
get somewhere right. You may hate you
may hate Zog Zbox. You may hate Zog Box
but that can actually get somewhere.
Lone in the box is at least you know
like he's smarter than Haj. Lone Box
actually you know if you present him a
hypothetical he'll be able to engage
with it give an answer. He might try and
weasle a little bit, but ultimately Lone
Box can have a [__] conversation.
Hutch is so [__] that no functional
adult
should feel like capable of having a
conversation with him without self
harming. Like that's that's
like the level Arch is at. like it. He's
the sort of person that makes you just
that you meet
like working a
like, you know, a gas a gas station job
or something and he's like to totally
dull [__] [__] that you like pray
is never on shift when you're there.
So you try you try and have a you try
and have a conversation with him about
something's going on. He's like, "Huh?
What?
Oh yeah, I haven't heard about that.
You know, like that's that's Hajj Hutch
if he didn't have all day to sit online.
If the again you're not indulging my
hypothetical like like if
>> would it be would it be wrong to lie
>> if you're as a creator
>> if your intention is to dissuade your
audience from like
brigading uh Casey Tron streams and and
replies
>> at some level of danger to Casey Tron's
health and security then yes I think
that it was okay to lie if like
otherwise she would get killed or
assaulted or attacked or some [__] like
that and it's harassed or harassed and
brigaded No, no, not that. I do not
think on at the scale we're talking
about here, which is public criticism.
All right. I also love this kind of like
deflation of the word harassment. That
means anytime you get like a bunch of
comments, negative comments and [__] and
negative attention. by that logic like
I'm harassed constantly all the time by
everybody but like harassment like what
I understand harassment to be and it's
it's not just like like it is a specific
wrongful act that puts you in like fear
for your privacy or a fear of like that
you're about to be in physical harm or
something like that or someone's going
to stalk you [__] like that not mere
criticism because you did a bad thing
like it's not harassment that we say
Trump is a piece of [__] or hex needs to
go to jail or we say that all like I
understand these are public figures but
same thing on
right like Hassan Piker's
>> Pisco going so hard into points. Quiqu
agrees with that. Our streamer's voice
is cracking as he gasps and is weak in
the knees. Wow.
>> Thank you for the $3. Thank you.
>> Lying about Israel or Gaza or whatever
he's that you think he's lying about.
You wouldn't be like um okay criticizing
that is harassment, right? If he's doing
misconduct, if he's being insincere and
you criticize it, that's not harassment.
Fair.
>> Just criticism harassment. But but if
it's but if it's organized brigading if
it's or if it's organized brigading you
mean what? Like that they're trying to
do what
>> do you mean? You don't know the ter you
know what brigading means. Come on.
>> Brigading like sending your people over
to their servers or the different
things.
>> Brigading doesn't even necessarily need
to be like orchestrated by the creator.
>> Yes. To answer your question, no. I
don't think that the fear of brigading
is uh enough to justify lying to your
audience about an in about an insincere
apology because because what you're
saying what you're saying is
So, dude, wait, I'm noticing a crazy
parallel here
because I I those some may remember I
had a conversation with HCH once
where he wanted me to make a statement
because he was worried people were
brigading or attacking him from my
stream. and he wored me to lie
and say he wasn't a Destiny orbiter on
stream to try and quell the hate he was
getting. And Pisco is currently having a
very similar conversation.
That's interesting. That's cool.
Obviously, not intentionally, but that
that's cool that I'm seeing get get
raped for this.
stupid belief
>> like sending your people over to their
servers or the different things.
>> Brigading doesn't even necessarily need
to be like orchestrated by the creator.
>> Yes. To answer your question, no. I
don't think that the fear of brigading
is uh enough to justify lying to your
audience about an in about an insincere
apology because because what you're
saying what you're saying is you're
motivated by you're motivated by a
desire to like prevent harm or limit
harm. How could that be immoral? Well,
first of all, I don't I think that his
motivation is to try to
>> um claim it sincere for purposes of his
further,
>> you know, to justify his position in the
lawsuit and to justify the negative
statements made about Biker. So, I I
don't even I don't even buy at this
point. I don't have a good inference
that he's really motivated to um you
know, protect Caseron's uh well-being.
And part of that is because of the way
he talks about Casey Trron's uh
financial situation, which I find
reprehensible, but we can get into that
in a second. Um
>> he can be he can be petty. I I just want
to say that if it were the case that
Casey Tron is being insincere in her
apology and Ethan Klein knows her to be
insincere, you would say that it's okay
for Ethan to lie about that.
I don't think it's necessarily bad,
>> but given the facts that we have here, I
if if under current understandings of
the fact, right, his own your own
interpretation of the facts as you know
it. If you found out and Ethan said to
you, you know what, Hutch, I was lying.
I don't think it's sincere. What would
you say to that?
>> Don't care.
>> You don't care about the
>> No,
>> this is this is why the So, I'm not
going to spend a lot of time.
>> Don't care. I don't think it's
necessarily bad. I think he was even if
even if I indulged your Even if I
indulge your version of it, let let's
say he's just all it is is just him
doing a backhanded like victory lap. I
don't care.
>> Okay. So, that's why I lead with this
stuff. If you don't care about whether
or not he lied about uh her sincerity or
insincerity on the apology, then I'm not
going to spend a bunch of time. If even
if I could establish that she lied,
which actually I will ask you about um
that you would think if if you're not
going to condemn it, right? I'm I'm not
going to spend a bunch of time wasting
like well why you should right like
you're saying basically it's okay for
him to lie about the sincerity of the
apology even if it's not true for him to
tell his audience it is true. If you
think that I have some kind of moral
obligation to condemn him for lying in
that spot in this hypothetical, you
would have to convince me that the
consequences that Casey Tron experienced
were not commensurate with the way that
she contributed to what happened with
Ethan and and all that. No, you would
have you would have to because earlier
in the conversation he said that you
think it was necessarily immoral
>> to bring litigation against someone but
be motivated by some other kind of that
wasn't necessarily immoral. Right.
>> Yeah. So so I think that there could be
motivations that aren't necessarily uh
that it doesn't necessarily make it
immoral. That's correct. I was giving
some sized examples. Um but we we'll get
into the facts about the but the lawsuit
but I just want to resolve this issue of
lying. No, but then but then this
conversation needs to be about like do
you think that Ethan bringing litigation
was
um was was too far of a response to what
how Caseyron
and Froggen and Denims and that whole
community contributed to um the CPS call
and the harassment that Ethan and Hila
got.
>> Right. So, I mean the case you're
basically asking me, do you think the
lawsuits are justified? That's what
you're asking me, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. I do want to get into that,
but I I just want to deal with the line.
Okay.
>> You know, like by by could you mean
could I see some possible world that
doesn't entail a contradiction in which
it would be justified? The answer is
yes. But again, that's what I do. That's
No, no, no. But
>> I don't think it's I think under the
circumstances given the nature of the
lies and what's actually motivating it,
I do not think that and I'll tell you
other
>> I mean, how do you feel about like just
like do you give do how do you feel
about the collective communities that
they had piling on about the CPS stuff?
Like how do you feel about that? And
then the lack of moderation.
>> You understand? How do you feel about
that? Like I I don't
>> No, no, but that's a really important
question. Like how do you feel about
that? So depending on the conduct, I of
course condemn it. If what they're doing
is advocating for or celebrating, for
example, calling CPS on those facts, I
condemn that. If they're, for example,
if let's say it's something weird, like
uh refusing to condemn the death of a
political, you know, the assassination
or something, I would condemn that. You
know, not moderating. Let's just talk
about legisl
I can think of I can think of a
different a bunch of situations where
failure to moderate um is something that
I would condemn on
>> No, but I'm talking about this specific
thing. I just want you to I just want
your thoughts on this specific thing,
right? Do you not think that do you not
do you not think that that action that
they did that the way that they
participated in the whole CPS
>> they I already laid it out for you. We
talked about that before.
>> So it's your so you agree
>> they enabled it. They enabled it. They
were wildly irresponsible at at best and
they were they were maliciously egging
it on at worst. And you think they're
culpable. You think that they're
culpable or what happened?
>> I think they're all like jointly
culpable. Yeah. They all have a part to
play in that. Yeah. When you don't do
when you don't take any meaningful
action
>> to moderate your community, when you can
when you can see plain as day what's
going on in your chat and you're making
jokes about
>> has to start ranting. Are you joking
about it after the fact? Well,
presumably if you're joking about it,
Presumably if you're joking about it
after the fact and only after the fact,
>> how do we know that there's a causal
connection at all between what occurred
and the community? I can I can imagine a
bunch of people laughing at [__] that
they had no. So, for I'll give you an
example, right? There are some Democrats
who celebrated the death of Charlie
Kirk. Agreed. Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> Do you think that
coming out? It's coming out.
He's, you know, Pace is getting testy.
Yeah. Pace is getting testy.
>> Twitter. Sure. Yeah.
>> Yes. Are those people culpable for
Charlie Kirk's death?
>> No, but that's not that's not the same
thing. [laughter]
>> Well, you see this comparison is not the
same thing.
So, have you considered that, Po? This
comparison is not the exact same thing.
You're not comparing two identical
things. Please go. Have you considered
that that you're not comparing two
identical things right now? So why are
you saying it on a not identical peace
guy?
[snorts]
>> Oh my god. I can't [__] take it
>> at all. Wait, hang on a second.
>> Comparison. It's an analogy.
>> No, but this would only be analogous if
they were all in message boards where
they were talking about potentially
unaliving Charlie. That would be
analogous. that he separated it. He said
if they are celebrating it after the
fact and only after the fact, his exact
words,
how can you determine a causal
connection? That's what he said.
[__] idiot, man. I truly It's crazy
that Hutch doesn't like cry himself to
sleep every night. We live in a world
where Hutch feels like confident enough
to not just like cry himself to sleep
every night and never stream again.
They're so [__] up, man. So, what you
need to show, don't you, is a causal
relationship between their conduct pre
uh, you know, incrim incriminatory act
and the act itself, don't you? The CPS
call happened shortly after Denims did
her stream where she platformed a bad
empanada video where he was the making
the he was making the case that CPS
should be called and she made no
meaningful she like maybe she made some
but like she did not go nearly far
enough in terms of moderating her if I
was her. What? First of all, why is she
watching that video? Why is she
platforming bad empanada? Why is she
watching a video with this guy who is
tacitly encouraging his audience to call
CPS? Do you agree that that's wildly
irresponsible as a creator
>> to watch a bad empanada video?
>> Yeah. To watch a bad not just not not in
a vacuum to watch a bad empanada video
of him making the case for why the
viewer should maybe call CPS.
>> Um
if by is it a good thing to do? Is it
respon is it irresponsible is what I
said.
>> Should she do it? I think the answer is
no. I don't think she should do it. But
that's not but but Hang on. Because I
think that all
>> No, but the why matters. The why
matters.
>> I'm about to Wait, I'm answering that.
Did you hear me answering that? I said
when I was
>> Okay, go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead. So
um it I don't think it's good because if
you are um you know watching a video in
which these kinds of you know bad things
are being expressed uh all else equal
without any push back you know
potentially that could um you know
encourage a risk or something of of
something occurring. But but that but
hang on a second. Yes. But hang on but
hang but hang on one second. Do you have
evidence that Denims knew what was in
the video before she watched it? Yes or
no?
>> I don't know off the top of my head, but
she kept watching it. That's not the
point. She kept watching it.
>> He literally can't stop spazzing out.
>> She could have turned it off.
>> So, it's just so insecure. It's so
plainly insecure.
>> The second he brought that up and said,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa. This is way too
>> The answer So, the answer is no. You
don't have any evidence that she knew
the contents of the video before she
watched.
>> Why would you skip over?" No, she
continued to watch it. Dude, she enjoy
>> I just want to do it one step at a time.
So, you don't have any evidence correct
that she knew it was in the video before
she watched.
>> I think you're trying to worm out of
logical conclusion that you just one
thing at a time. Let's just do one thing
at a time. I think you're trying to worm
out of the logical conclusion that you
just jumped to, which is that if the the
reason why it's irresponsible for
someone to do that in her position is
because, as you said, the risk goes way
up that somebody in her community might
act on that.
>> Here's here's the thing. It's an how is
she not culpable? So, so it's an
attenuated risk. It's an attenuated risk
that is not at all sufficient for
culpability. Not even 1%, not even close
to 1%. [snorts] touch the mere acting
and watching of a video that encourages
bad.
>> There's such easy analogies for this,
right? Well, not not like they're not
like perfect analogies, but like you can
easily start running down like this sort
of thing with Hutch where he obviously
won't accept these extended forms of
culpability in other cases. Like we we
go down Hutch, you pay taxes and you
vocally support Israel on on the
internet. Are you culpable for the
actions of Israel? Right. You're you're
increasing. We're paying taxes and by
supporting them on social media, you are
in a in your small pot in a tiny way
increasing the chance that they're going
to carry out war crimes. You're also
you're supporting it in this tiny way.
Are you culpable part? Should you be
held culpable? If someone wanted
retribution
for something happening in Israel,
should they be able to take out on you
>> stuff? Now you are culpable.
>> There's obviously there's obviously a
line. There's obviously a line
somewhere, isn't there? You could be in
some way contributing and not be
culpable.
>> Things that might result from watching a
video. No [__] way that you would
apply this standard to any other
commentator who watches something. Come
on, bro. This is
>> is lying or dumb? Uh, both. It's both.
It's a mix. A terrible terrible mix.
bizarre and wild
me suggesting.
>> In fact, lying is maybe unfair. It's not
quite lying. It's this it's this uh it's
the same cultish willful dishonesty that
you see in like any big like streamer
community or like political thing, you
know? It's like the same way MAGA
retards act. It's the same way DG sick
fans act. The same way Hassan sick fans
act. You know, it's it's like this
willful dishonesty where you kind of
know a lot of the stuff you're saying
isn't quite true, but you're willing to
fudge the details because you kind of
>> you have like a bias or you think it's a
good thing to do.
>> Ask my chat if I moderate. Ask my chat
if I moderate. Like I take steps all the
time. I tell my chat explicitly all the
time. Don't brigade. I do all like
there's there's certain red lines that I
understand that me as a creator as
someone with the following as someone
who could potentially influence someone.
I do think that I have a responsibility
to use that influence responsibly
copable. It doesn't make you culpable
and
>> it doesn't make you 100% culpable but
you are partly culpable at the very
here's a question for you. If if you're
saying that Charlie Kirk has blood on
his hands this is before he's killed.
Charlie Kirk is a fascist. Charlie Kirk
is trying to overturn the, you know, the
democracy of our country. He's doing
these horrible things.
>> And
>> you're doing the Republican thing now.
>> I You're doing Why are you doing the
thing?
>> He can't engage with a hypothetical.
>> Why do you think,
>> bro? He literally cannot engage with a
hypothetical. It's crazy.
>> I'm bringing that up, Hutch.
>> Because there's a difference.
>> Do you think I BELIEVE,
DO YOU think I believe?
>> It's fine when I do it. It's fine when I
do it.
>> Hutch, the fact that you're asking. So I
I'm going to app I am not going to be
deterred from bringing up this example.
The question stands the question is as
follows. If you as a creator are
platforming a video, you're watching a
video in which someone says Charlie Kirk
has blood on his hands. He's allowing
and encouraging criminal actions from
the administration. And um honestly, I
think that he's a fascist and there
should be no moral consideration for
Charlie Kirk whatsoever.
I'm going to finish the question. This
I'm not going to get
>> I have a [laughter] video. I just want
you to watch a video. I just want you to
watch a video.
>> No, no, you can like I'm asking
something. I will definitely watch your
video after I get an answer and then we
we address it. I will definitely don't
worry about it. Right. So, if it's the
case that you have someone who's
watching a video of someone else saying
Charlie Kirk has blood on his hands, he
should have no moral consideration and
he kind of doesn't do anything. He just
kind of watches it. Ends up Charlie Kirk
gets assassinated. Someone comes up to
you Hutch and said you are culpable. you
watched this insane uh video in which he
says no moral consideration should be
given to Carl Kirk. You don't actually
believe it and you have no you didn't do
any push back in that moment. Let me
finish the question. Let me finish the
question.
>> Would that person who watched that video
with
dude? [laughter]
It's so satisfying, man. It's so
satisfying. Holy [__]
Look how just like the posture and
everything, man. Everything about he
just like is enraging, bro. I hate this
guy. I hate this guy.
I hate this guy.
I have a [__] AM rant about this
[laughter] guy, bro. I'm like,
I can't take it, bro. It's so bad.
Without any push back on the notion that
Charlie Kirk deserves no moral
consideration, he didn't push back
there. He let that stand. Would that
person be culpable for the assassination
of Charlie Kirk? Yes or no?
Did the video that was watched
>> I need to I need to ask you about the
video that I hypothetical video did in
the hypothetical video that I watched
>> did the creator of that video suggest
that someone should like explicitly
suggest that someone should unalive
Charlie Kirk?
>> No. No. They he says they deserves no
moral consideration. Whatever happens to
him is justified.
>> No. That's too that's too abstract then.
No. There's no culpability there. This
is not absolutely wait a second. Hang on
a second. Don't you Don't you agree that
there's a risk that someone could get
the wrong impression? Isn't there a
risk?
>> This this is that standard there to hang
on a second. So I'm just asking you
agree with me that there's a spectrum.
Isn't there a risk?
>> You agree with me that there's a
spectrum.
>> So what I'm trying to prove is what I'm
trying to demonstrate to you is the the
mere fact that there is an increased
risk does not imply that there is
culpability. the valitional acts of
others cut off the causal chain such
that we imply culpability even if it's
the case even it's the case that you
>> Hut should not understand a word of that
that what all that peace guy just like
laid out like the core of the argument
here and there is absolutely no way
Hutch registered any of it dude
holy [__]
[laughter]
I'm [__] dying holy [__]
>> cut off the there is mere Fact that
there is an increased risk does not
imply that there is culpability. The
valitional acts of others cut off the
causal chain such that we imply
culpability. Even if it's the case, even
it's the case that you have dangerous
such such that um you know it's possible
there's a risk. You agree, don't you, by
the way, that um you know, Destiny I
think has been based on a lot of his uh
standard of MAGA. Would you deny that
there is a risk that him saying in
refusing to condemn at times sometimes
he does condemn it but at times refusing
to condemn carries risk of the
assassination? Does it carry a risk?
>> I I you kind of lost [laughter] when
Destiny refuses to condemn the
>> dude. There's no way
[laughter and gasps]
I'm losing it, man. I can't with this
guy.
[laughter]
Dude, it's so bad.
It's so [__] bad, dude.
>> Assassination of Charlie Kirk. I I am
telling you that he's inconsistent on
it. Sometimes he condemns it, but there
are moments
>> I've talked all the time about how Yes.
I think I think his rhetoric around that
stuff is way too
>> All of a sudden all of a sudden there's
a uh Republican
>> inconsistent.
>> All of a sudden there's a Republican
who's killed and they even cite, you
know, destiny because oh yeah, no moral
consideration. There needs to be
equality. Whatever that would be, you
would not say destiny is culpable there,
would you?
Oh my god.
He's got going for the [__] throw.
Literally the biggest betrayal I've ever
seen. Most insane betrayal I've ever
seen.
>> But there are moments.
>> I've I've talked all the time about how
Yes. I think I think his rhetoric around
that stuff is way too
>> all of a sudden all of a sudden there's
a uh Republican
>> this is inconsistent.
>> All of a sudden there's a Republican
who's killed and they even cite you know
destiny because oh yeah no moral
consideration there needs to be equality
whatever that would be you would not say
destiny is culpable there would you? I
you again you're you're
>> you wouldn't say would you?
>> You are [__] debate
right now.
>> Dude, he literally can't answer the
questions.
It's crazy. It's crazy. Lone the box
needs to cover this. I want to see Lone
Box cover this. I have to see Lox cover
this properly. Actually address the
arguments being made unlike in that [__]
video the other day. I need to see Lone
Box watch this and see this is how he
sounds. This is literally how he sounds
half the time, bro. He needs to see
this. There's no way anyone can watch
this. Anyone who's got like the
faculties to follow a conversation like
this, which, you know, online it seems
is few and far between. Anyone who's got
the falconies to follow a conversation
like this, if you hold the positions
Hutch does, you've got to be either you
are you have to be either screaming like
the absolute perfect rebuttal like I was
hut not thinking of this or you're going
to be like dude I might be I might be in
a [__] I might be in a corner here. I
might have really taken some silly
positions here.
>> I watched it last night. It was last
night.
>> It's about I just want you to watch a
video. I just want you to watch a video.
We don't need to do that. No, we No, we
actually we actually do because this
shows that there's a principle that we
we're not going to impose.
>> You're not proposing something that is
analogous, dude. These are not
analogous. You need to explain this. You
need to explain the dish analogy then
because what I provided to you, you
said, right? Wait, let me ask question.
YOU'VE ASKED ME LIKE five questions,
bro. Let me ask you a question. Would
you, if you were watching a video
>> and then the creator of the video in the
video that you're watching suggested
that someone should unalive Tim Pool,
would you continue to watch the video?
>> I would condemn that. I'm just telling
that's why. And I would say yes, I
might.
>> Would you continue to watch the video?
>> Yeah, I might I might continue to watch
the video. I watch unhinged people say
unhinged things all the time. Now, I
would probably although unless I forgot.
>> Turn that [__] off. Come on, bro. You
turn.
>> Hey, why
consideration? Are you [__] me?
Wait, are you
>> think you would turn that off?
>> If if I saw a video in which someone is
making a threat of violence, you think I
would automatically turn the video off?
>> If somebody made a specific call to
action, you would be banned in like a
second if you didn't turn it off, right?
>> Listening to it.
>> I've never heard that.
>> You can't Okay,
>> at all. The toos says you can have stuff
like that in there as long as it's
condemned. You can re recreate that for
journalistic or critique purposes. Look
at the toos. It's there very clearly.
I've I would know. I've had YouTube
safety training for very similar things
and it made me select the right option
on the multiple choice thing. So I I I I
know that as long as you say this is
terrible stuff. I'm only presenting this
for journalistic purposes. This is pure
you're pretty much safe.
>> I I maybe
>> you've never heard you've never heard to
prepare a call to action to an
individual
>> a specific call to action to hurt
someone or harm someone. If an
individual is endorsing it but just
merely watching the video.
>> Yes. Every platform that you're on.
Basically, if you're watching a video
that says someone should really go on a
live Tim Fool and you didn't.
>> So, so wait. So, why isn't Destiny
banned?
>> Wait, wait, hang on.
>> No, no, no. You didn't turn that off,
right?
>> Wait, I'm not convinced of that. If If
I've I've watched Maybe it's just
because
>> Give me one second. Give me one second.
>> Okay.
I don't know. Have you guys ever heard
of that? Like I've watched unhinged
people like say crazy things like we
consider and we've analyzed for example
Trump's incitement theories under both
legal and we've watched the videos and
stuff. We watched Jane six videos.
>> You got me shouting so I need some
[__] water.
>> Oh no worries. So
>> if you watch video where somebody said
you know what I really [__] Tim Pool
is just the worst and you know somebody
definitely needs to go on a live right.
You you would continue to watch that.
Yeah. If I was analyzing it and saying
this is a true threat, this is an
example of a true threat. I'll give you
another example, right? In the
>> Well, you said you would specifically
condemn it, right?
>> Yeah. I mean, it depends on the context.
Like if if if there's I think
>> bec because I do think that potentially
a there could be if I just let it play
and don't specifically address it. I
think that there could be action by
Twitch. But again, just because there's
action by Twitch or there's a risk for
my channel doesn't mean that I'm
accepting culpability if something bad
happens. I just want to be clear about
the distinction there. And second, I do
think that there's a moral
responsibility to condemn these acts of
violence or even acts for example of
deception or whatever. But and I think
that there's potential risk and you
should minimize risk where possible.
Here's the difference, right? Mitigation
of risk and an obligation to avoid risk
doesn't equal culpability if something
bad ends up happening after the fact.
And this is easily you can understand
that if you just apply any of the
comparisons that I've talked about that
no one in the context that I provided
that you're examining someone saying
some unhinged [__] about Charlie Kirk
and then all of a sudden oops someone
kills him. No one could ever come to a
lib creat and you would defend. You
would say this is insane. You know he
was watching a video of someone else
doing it. He wasn't doing
>> but what if what if there what if I
could show you a video of Denims herself
saying that somebody should call CPS on
Ethan?
>> Go for it. I would say that's
independently bad.
Okay. Apparently, there's a video.
>> All right. Show us.
>> It's on my stream. Just pull up my
stream.
>> Can you share it on Discord? I
>> uh Yes. Hold on.
>> You acting like I have like a problem
condemning Denims or Hassan or
>> We're getting into all these
hypotheticals though, though. You know
what I mean? Like, like I Yes. I think I
think
>> Hutch, why do you think I'm doing this?
I'm doing this because I don't want you
I love you. I love you, my boy. to weave
people out and be like there's no
[__] comparison here. And like
>> you're you're doing this to avoid the
possibility that these creators did
something that was extremely harmful.
>> If they if they
>> he's trying to get there. He's trying to
get there.
>> Advocated for CPS. I'm telling you right
now, I'm going to condemn that.
>> Even if even if they even by the way,
just so you know, even if they're just
>> Let me watch the clip. Let me just Let
me just watch the clip. Hold on. I'm
pressing play. I'm pressing play.
>> I'm telling you in advance. I don't even
need to see the clip. I I will see the
clip, but I'm just telling you in
advance.
>> I want to see the clip. If if they laugh
about it after the fact, I'll condemn
that, too. Guess what? It doesn't
resolve the issue.
>> But is you don't you don't think Okay,
hold on. Let me watch the clip. I'm done
talking for a second. Hold on.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, you you don't think that laughing
about something after the fact can have
a causal impact on whether it happens in
the first place?
Really, Peace Coco? Are you seriously
suggesting that when I'm making a point,
I have to I have to account for the fact
that time moves in a constant linear
fashion and that one event takes place
after another and that if one event
takes place after another, you cannot
have that event have a causal relation
with the with the preceding event. I'm
going to [__] lose it, man. Just
please even watch the clip
for what your chat. We might have to
pull it up here, I'm pretty sure.
>> See what she says. And then now we
wonder [__] in their house. And then
Denim host this and see what she says.
And then now we wonder why people are
calling child protective services.
>> But they called it before I even did
this stream.
>> He lets his dogs [__] all over his
mansion just and he just leaves a [__]
on the floor. Something that is probably
related to the fact that his former
housekeeper is suing him for a number of
different reasons. So, I would assume he
doesn't actually have a housekeeper
anymore. Or perhaps he he lost his extra
housekeeper. So, now the house is just
like covered in dog [__] and he's he has
kids and his kids like crawl into the
dog [__] and god forbid I don't know
what they do with it. I don't know if
they eat it or if it's just from like
contact with it with their hands or
something, but they contracted a
parasit.
It's the chat clip.
>> So, this is not a joking matter by the
way.
>> So, at no point in this does she
advocate for CPS. compiled by his crew.
>> It makes sense. How is this happening?
You'll be
>> no point in shape for CPS. Pretty sure
Ben
doesn't either.
>> Oh, it was Denim's chat.
>> Dude,
>> I hope you're not going to impose some
kind of
>> strict liability for what your chat
says. That's
>> dude. And it's a lie anyway. It's a
total lie anyway. So, we already went
over that clip earlier.
>> Insane. And you're never going to live
in that state. Nuts.
You're not You don't think Hang on. If
If
>> you don't think you can be held
accountable for some mean comments in
your chat, you kidding me?
>> Hang on. If you're spamming, spamming
spamming on. So, it's a total lie. This
is a total lie. They He's lying here.
>> It was 6% of the messages were shown in
a 900 message space.
They were not. Only three of those
messages happened while the clip that is
playing there plays. It's beyond [__]
parody. It's beyond [__] parody.
>> You wouldn't tell them to not call the
cops?
>> That's not what I said. Wait, wait.
That's That is not what I said, Hutch. I
didn't say that.
>> Do you have a responsibility?
>> They they literally just deliberately
avoid engaging capture in the ray. just
have this virolent urge to kill John
Lennon.
>> Thank you for the $420. So real. So
real. Catch on the R is awesome. Okay, I
hate people who hate on Catcher and the
Rai.
I know no one says it made anyone kill
John anymore, but you know, people hate
on it. People say it's like, you know,
corny and stupid high school book and
all this [__] It's an awesome book.
It's a great book.
>> Yes. That doesn't mean you're creator.
>> Yes. That doesn't mean you're culpable.
You understand the difference there?
Just because you have a self
>> does. What do you mean?
>> No, it [__] doesn't. If someone ends
up So you're saying if I failed to do my
due diligence in uh like saying and
giving an affirmative thing, hey guys,
>> it's good but it's edge lord bait. Yeah.
Well, it's obviously edge lord bait, but
then there's like the step, you know,
it's like it's sort of similar, you
know, it's not similar, but is similar
at the same time to like people the
different appreciations of Fight Club.
You know, there's like the
either you engage with it unironically
or you sort of,
you know, engage past that, you know,
and if you're drawn to it as like a
super edge lord, like for those reasons,
you're kind of engaging with it a bit
unironically.
>> This and you shouldn't call the cops on
Rob Noir. If I don't do that, and if I
just let it play out either because I
don't see it or because I'm negligent
because I'm just [__] twiddling my
thumbs. You think I have culpability
[__] who does that?
>> No, no, no, no. That's not what I said
though. Let me give you a hypothetical.
You love hypotheticals. Let me give you
a hypothetical. Correct.
>> Let's say all of us on uh Live and
Learn. Okay. You, me, Soy Pill, and uh
uh IRI,
>> we all watch the same video
independently with our own viewers.
Okay. Mhm.
>> And in that video,
uh, somebody makes a claim and then and
then and then like all of our chats are
like spamming, you know, like somebody
needs to call call the cops on Rob No.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And then somebody calls and we
don't do anything. We don't police it at
all. And then somebody calls the cops on
Rob Noir. Are are none of us culpable or
are all of us culpable?
>> You're not cable.
>> None of us are culpable.
>> No. The culpable party is the party that
parties that encouraged it. um
explicitly with their intention, their
active intention to do so. Um and those
who did it, that's what's that is the
culprit.
>> Okay. I mean, we just have we just have
philos like major philosophical
differences between like responsible
content creation because
>> so I I I want to under so I want you to
apply this standard standard that you're
just setting out anytime that there's
cuz there have been leftwing acts of
violence and there are chats that uh
will talk about this kind of [__] saying
you know these people should there are
you know these people exist you know
these people exist
>> of course yeah of course
>> and you would never you would never say
well because you failed to moderate your
unhinged chat
as opposed to saying, "Okay, you have a
responsibility to upkeep it." I would
agree with that. No doubt.
>> But that you're capable for the action.
That's insane. That's strict liability
for what your [__] chat does.
>> I maybe we're getting hung up on the
term, but I think like at minimum you
could say that you through your inaction
and through your tacit endorsement
really of what uh uh bad empanada was
was saying in that video and then you
like ignoring your chat like multiple
people in your chat. funny
>> and you have mods like you're looking at
she looks at her chat constantly. She
chose to not like do anything about
those comments.
>> It's all built on a lie. I wish Peo had
all the information here to just like
fight this. So [__] annoying, dude.
>> Like at that point I'm not talking about
legal I just want to be clear. Wait a
second. Listen. I'm not talking about
legal culpability. I am talking about
ethical culpability. I just want to be
clear. I'm not complaining about I'm
seeing people in the chat. So I'm only
talking about ethical copility. Go
ahead.
>> That Yeah, this is a major philosophical
difference between you and me. I think
if you are a creator and you're seeing
specific calls to action,
>> especially something as serious as
government intervention on somebody that
you don't like, you have a
responsibility to step in at that point
and say, "Guys, way too far.
>> Excuse me.
>> Otherwise, you're culpable.
>> Otherwise, you have contributed to like
that event happening in some small way."
or you could at the very least
potentially have done it. The the
reality is we can't know who made that
call. Was it someone from Assange's
audience? Was it someone from her
audience?
>> That doesn't relieve you of the burden
of showing. We don't know. That doesn't
in that burden to show that that they
are culpable. You just because it's hard
to to find evidence of the particular
thing that shows culpability doesn't
relieve you of your responsibility to
show it. But you're
>> culpable. Do you hear like 100%
responsible?
>> No, I I hear I would hear morally
culpable for the thing occurring. That's
what I understand it to be.
>> You're you there's a shared culpability
is my point. And you're you you I think
you're using that like uncertainty about
where the call came from as a means to
just like deflect all responsibility.
Like you're saying that they had no
ethical obligation to moderate their own
chat as they're like like making
suggestions to call
>> what what you're culpable for. What what
you're culpable for is what you did
wrong. What you did wrong was failure to
moderate appropriately your chat. What
you're not culpable for is actually
[__] calling CPS. That is
>> If you were in Ethan, if you were in
Ethan's shoes, just try to imagine.
>> That's not No. So, so we're So, I can
totally grant that if I accept all of
Ethan's priors, if I take his point of
view, we're not talking about from his
lights, does he think it's justified?
He's doing it, I suppose.
>> No, but I'm asking you. I'm asking you
to just imagine like,
>> oh my god,
>> who would you have blamed?
>> Do you think you you you could
understand blaming like the whole pool
of creators that were all dog piling and
encouraging if you were laughing about
it?
>> If you were if you were Erica Kirk and
JD Vance,
>> can you imagine blaming more than just
Charlie Kirk's killer? It's like you
could just do this endlessly. You could
do this all day. It's not the [__]
point. Hutch, make an argument, you
[__] [__]
>> Blaming them for
CPS showing up at your house.
>> That's unhinged. That's unhinged. That's
what they're
>> That's unhinged. No, you would. So, so I
want to hear you say it then. So, so I'm
going to give you another example.
>> Like, well, we can never know. Blame any
of them. You would not do that, bro. If
your community
actively encourages doxing and you fail
to moderate that doxing and then doxing
in fact occur, is the streamer culpable
for doxing?
>> I'll tell you I'll tell you what how I
would feel. No, I'm asking if you could.
>> No, I'm telling you. I'm telling you
exactly. I'm telling you exactly like
like I like I'm imagine me, right? And I
and and I found out that somebody in my
community docked someone and and there
was a thing that maybe we missed like I
was looking away from chat or something
like that. I would feel like I would
feel
>> I'm not going to be distracted. I'm
giving you an example. I'm giving you an
answer.
>> So So no, no, you didn't answer that
question. You said what you would do
that you would feel responsible if some
other [__] happened even when you you
were negligent. That's not what I'm
talking about. I'm talking about a
situation in which community doxes
you're aware of it and you don't
moderate it intentionally. You don't
moderate. you see it's there and you
don't moderate. Is the streamer culpable
for the doxing?
>> I think they are partly responsible.
Yes.
>> Okay. So, it's a standard you would
apply that the that the mere
nonmodderation decisions as to your
community gives you culpability for the
attacks, however attenuated um to that
might occur because uh you know you you
failed to moderate your community even
though those actions. Okay. I I
>> I can't I can't I listen I can't believe
that I'm I'm a bit incredulous right now
because you seem to be you seem to be
totally closed off to the possibility
that a streamer has any
>> any reasonable um like expectation of
being responsible
>> cuz other
literally said the opposite. So I want
to be clear that I literally
>> What's the point? What's the point of
moderation?
>> First I'm going to establish that what
you just represented is literally the
opposite of what I said. So, you heard
me, didn't you, when I said that there
is a responsibility to moderate. You
heard that? Did you hear that? What
>> did you hear? So, I asked I'm asking you
if you heard me say that.
>> I'm trying to make sense of what you're
saying because
>> I just want to make sure you heard it
when I said it.
>> Hang on. What you're saying is
contradictory to me because otherwise
Well, what is the point of moderation
then?
>> So, I just want to make sure you heard.
Can you answer that question? I will.
But can you answer my question?
>> Yes, I heard you. What's the point of
what's the point of moderation? there's
self-standing obligations to moderate uh
to reduce risk that you know a streamer
I think has it's where it's there's a
low cost of compliance and where there
are obvious potential uh benefits to a
lowcost compliance incident the fact
that you have a self-standing obligation
to mitigate risk I'm going to repeat it
make sure you hear it so I'm going to
say it twice that you violated your duty
to moderate does not mean you are
culpable for
>> actions that underly it means that
you're
Oh my god. I I I mean, so you understand
that there are two obligations, right?
There are two moral
>> what you're saying makes no sense
because if there if you're saying you're
there to mitigate risk, but you're not
culpable if something happens, well then
what the [__] What's the contradiction?
You say makes no sense.
>> What risk are you mitigating?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So the the risk that you're
mitigating does pertain potentially to
later on events, but that doesn't mean
that you're cop
>> What does that mean, dude? Come on.
Don't say events. Risk of what? of uh
either bad conduct, malicious conduct,
whatever is responsible, whatever's down
the line. Absolutely. So, so I I just
want I just want to make sure that you
understand the distinction here. Do you
understand a distinction between a duty
to mitigate risk that is by properly
moderating and the culpable actions of
intentional uh people who are doing the
thing and the the reason I'm asking this
of you is if you don't understand that
difference I think that there there's
like a huge issue in communication here
because just because you fail to
moderate and fail to uh optimally
minimize risk doesn't mean that you're
responsible for the valition malicious
conduct of other people.
>> No, you're not. You're not. Obviously,
listen, whoever called CPS, that was
their decision. Ultimately, they're
responsible for their actions. But you
seem to be like aloof to the idea that
people with tremendous levels of
influence, especially when we're talking
about that particular
[__] I'm not trying to discern you.
You're acting aloof to the idea that
these people could potentially influence
their own audience through through
action or in
>> guys. We have got a long way to go yet.
Okay,
we've got a long way to go yet.
So now is a great time,
okay, to talk to all 300 36 one of you
people here right now about the fact
that there are there are like 280 of you
who could
like the stream right now but haven't.
So if you wouldn't mind, please move
your cursor a thumbs up and clicking it,
pressing a thumbs up on your mobile
device, that huge appreciated.
If you want to take your support one
step further, however, you can donate
directly through a stream owners link in
the pin chat message. Great way to
support the stream. Bypasses all YouTube
cards and everything. Great great way to
support obviously al all support
appreciated, but that's a direct way.
Other ways to support though include
buying a membership to YouTube,
gifting a membership to YouTube to
another user in chat, gifting many
memberships all all at once to multiple
other users randomly throughout the
chat. It's very awesome. Very, very hype
and awesome. We love memberships. We
love gifted memberships. You also buy a
super chat which will highlight a
message and read it on CTS or a super
sticker which YouTube image or gift that
we highlight in chat. I'll describe it
to you. You can go to discord.gg/quman
twitter.comman or.com/gleman.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. We're
going to keep we're going to keep
pushing through with this. Okay. We keep
pushing through in action to to do
something like that. So, is Denim's 100%
responsible for what happened? No.
>> Set a goal.
Okay. Set. Let's set a goal.
Um,
how far in are we? 4 hours into the
stream. Okay.
Well, we'll set a 1 hour goal and we'll
see we'll see how we do. But she's
partly culpable in my opinion because
she contributed to that culture and that
community and that rhetoric that led to
ultimately the call happening in the
first place. I can't give you like is
she this percentage to blame or that
percentage
generalificability
>> culpability. So So does Denims have
significant culpability for the CPS call
that she did not place at There's no
evidence that I seen her encourage
before the fact.
>> I never said that. Wait, wait, wait. I'm
just asking you the question Hutch. Do
you think that there is significant
culpability or buy denims or cases
>> define significant? Are we talking
percentages here?
>> That is a primitive and I will but I
will say I'll put a percentage in on it.
5% significant
>> maybe. Yeah.
>> So you think that denims is 5%
responsible?
>> I don't know. I
>> at least 5% respon.
>> You're being asked
the question.
You just said yes and now you're going I
don't know now that you think it might
be [__]
>> Way to give you a maybe sure that is and
and and what percentage is Caseyron
responsible?
>> 2%. I don't who cares it doesn't matter
at a bare minimum Casey Tron as I
understand it insignificant
responsibility there.
>> No it's you're missing the point.
There's a shared culpability friend. So
I first of all I I don't even accept
that we would apply the the the culpable
standard to the actual act itself. We
would apply a culpability to the the
failure to moderate and uphold the
normal moderating, but it wouldn't
extend to the the actual act itself. But
even assuming that we would the notion
that you would put five or greater
percentage on a call that you have no
evidence that she encouraged, no
evidence that she knew about it, the
only thing you have is chat comments
that you can't prove she read
>> um that have been provided in a video to
you. That's all you have. And you're
willing to say you're willing to say
risky, right? Wait. You said that was
risky, right? Wait a second. So So if
she knew about it, what I'm trying to
think, oh my god, this is crazy. So I I
just want to lay out.
>> You say my 5%. I'm going to lay out the
case.
>> You think it's 0%.
>> For me, it's 0%. 0% capability for the
call. Unless you
>> But wait, you just said a minute ago
that if you don't moderate, there's a
risk that someone in your audience could
do something, right?
>> Correct. That doesn't mean that you're
culpable for the actual
>> How could it be 0% then?
It's
>> he just said like six times because that
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
culpable for the action itself. That's
how it can be 0%
touch. That's how it can be 0%.
>> We're not the same wrong. Do you
understand?
>> I'm being told I'm being told to finish
the clip. Hold on. There's more to the
clip.
>> Go for it.
>> Already lost the clip. Uh I stopped like
a minute in here. Hold on. So, I don't
know if you're watching the same thing,
but she's telling her audience that uh
you know, she's she's strongly implying
that Ethan's children might die.
>> A-OK, no problem. A child, a small
infant that has no immune system
shouldn't be catching anything.
>> No wonder his house is covered in dog
[__] and he's neglect.
>> That's That's not strongly implying they
might die. That's saying there is a risk
to children from catching diseases.
that children raised by nannies have
contracted parasites previously unknown
to science from the feces.
>> Is is death a potential outcome? Yes.
But that's like saying
>> like you you can set without catching
any disease ever, right? Like it's so
[__] stupid, dude.
>> I wonder why he skipped over all of this
cuz everything that he said, everything
that I said in this story, which by the
way was apparently comp compiled by his
crew playing.
>> No wonder this [__] is always
saying the fake.
>> It all makes sense now. It all makes
sense now. It makes sense why he doesn't
care about Palestinian children when he
is neglecting his own. How are you? How
is this happening? How is [laughter]
happening? How How is this happening?
Okay.
Wow. Terrible stuff, man.
>> What did she Sorry. Where did she say?
What did she say? Give me the words.
>> Like, just click to a minute into the
video.
>> I I don't know what video. I don't I
don't see any video.
>> I put it in the Discord.
>> Okay. One sec. cannot just Why is he
just screen shares? This guy's like so
[__] bro. [laughter] An
>> image.
>> How can they all believe that Dr. Chat
when there was a whole video debunking
it? Because they refuse to engage with
anything remotely oppositional because
they're literally it's built on they
know it's built on shaky ground. Arch is
just like a pathetic [__] idiot.
Like truly, it's like so embarrassing
that he's like this. It's like I can't
believe it. He's like in his [__]
late 30s
>> [__] in their house. And then denim host
this and see what she says. And then now
we wonder why people are calling child
protective services.
>> But they called it before I even did
this stream.
>> Watch that clip and try to tell me she's
0%. Bro,
>> he lets his daughter [__] all over his
mansion just and he just leaves a [__]
on the floor. Something that is probably
related to the fact his former
housekeeper is suing him for a number of
different reasons. So I would assume he
doesn't actually have a housekeeper
anymore or perhaps he he lost his extra
housekeeper. So now the house is just
like covered in dog [__] and he's he has
kids and his kids like crawl into the
dog [__] and god forbid. I don't know
what they do with it. I don't know if
they eat it or if it's just from like
contact with it with their hands or
something, but they contracted a
parasite that I had previously never
heard of in my life called Giarda from
the dog [__] that is all over his house.
>> True, dude. How is it? How is it that
like maybe once a week I I look into
what Ethan Klein's been up to and every
time I managed to find more and more
terrible [__] This is where Ethan tells
the story about his family getting
Gardo.
>> We already have mold Mondays, now we
have [__] Saturdays.
>> Also, this is not a joking matter, by
the way. It can be very severe and
deadly to small children. I mean, much
like many other illnesses, it's very,
very, very dangerous when infants get
the same sicknesses that adults get.
There are lots of things that you can
get as an adult. You're totally fine.
You'll be a-okay. No problem. A child, a
small infant that has no immune system,
shouldn't be catching anything.
>> No wonder his house is covered in dog
[__] And he's neglected children raised
by nannies have contracted parasites
previously unknown to science from the
feces. I wonder why he skipped over all
of this because everything that he said
everything that I said in this story,
which by the way was apparently com
compiled by his crew playing.
>> No wonder this [__] is always
sick. Yeah. Yeah. It all makes sense
now. It all makes sense now. It makes
sense why he doesn't care about
Palestinian children when he is
neglecting his own. How are you? How is
this happening? How is [laughter]
happening? How How is this happening?
>> There's the puppy.
>> I feel how this is encouraging someone
to call CBS.
I didn't say that it encourages someone
to call CPS.
>> Okay.
>> You don't have to you don't have to
encourage
>> Do you have to encourage someone to call
CPS to contribute to the risk of someone
calling it?
>> No.
>> Okay.
>> But what I'm trying to to sus out for
you clicking back.
>> He's not asking about whether he it
contributes to the risk. He's asking is
there a culpability
for that separate malicious willful
action? That's what is being asked every
time. That is the point. Is there
culpability? Does that person know is
culpability on them for the action? The
answer seems to be no.
Mere uh you know potential increase of
risk. And I agree. I mean like the the
mere fact that she's reporting like even
viewing the video at all, right? Even in
a critical lens might increase the the
risk of someone uh calling CPS, right?
The even if you were call even if you
were examining a video just to criticize
it, right? Just to tear it apart. Um if
you're a big enough streamer, that might
contribute to a risk on net that you you
don't know everyone who follows you
[__] watches it. So what I'm saying
is there's a self-standing obligation to
moderate 100%. But that doesn't coextend
to um substantive and here I'm not
talking about legal ethical culpability
that I'm going to impose some kind of
ethical breach with respect to the
substantive act that we're talking about
and the notion and I'm going to lay it
out here because we I I watched the
whole clip that you're going to give
denims as you certain sit here 5% or
greater responsibility. You came up with
that number.
>> LET ME YOU BOUGHT it right. So the fact
that I said
>> he said Pisco said significant. Hutch
said what is significant as a
percentage? Pisco said 5%. Hutch said
yeah it's more than 5%.
It's [__] crazy, man. It's [__]
crazy. I just can't take it. Dude,
you didn't have to adopt that. You
didn't have to say yes, I agree more
than 5%. You didn't have to say. You
asked me what do you consider
significant? I gave you a number 5%.
[laughter] Go and you said yes. No one
put a gun to your head, Hutch, that you
had to accept that number. So for you,
it's chicken [__] right now for you to
be like box me in. I'm not thinking
about and there it is. He's trying to
box you try to box me in because you're
wrong. If you're getting boxed in, it's
either because you're a [__] idiot or
you're wrong. It's one of the two. But
either way, your argument isn't making
sense.
Just stop spazzing and figure it out.
So annoying, man. I can't take this
[__]
Holy [__]
>> About these things in like percentage
points, my friend.
>> You adopted it.
>> I'm thinking about I'm thinking about
I'm at a much more top level view of
things.
>> Right. Right.
>> I'm not going to tell you 2% for Casey
whenever. See, guys, this totally isn't
like the mark of a complete [__]
[__] at all, is it?
>> You're trying to pin me on the on this
micro issue. Well, how about we just
talk about the macro thing instead? Oh,
I can't defend any of this on on the
micro on the micro level. Let's just
talk about the macro when you really
look at it. Don't they just deserve it?
Don't they just deserve it? [laughter]
Great stuff, man. Please delete your
account. I'm begging. I'm begging Hutch.
I'm starting a petition. Hutch, resign
from YouTube. Quit YouTube.
>> 5% for this.
>> My brain is your lawyer brain is going
there. And I'm not
>> When I say significance, the 5%
significance. Lawyer brain meaning able
to follow a train of logic. Able to like
you know flesh out an argument and
follow it to its conclusion
draw reasonable inferences from
from sets of evidence. Yeah. Lawyer
brain. You know lawyer brain stuff that
only lawyers can do. Stuff that only
lawyers can do.
[laughter]
>> Like a statistical if anything it's not
my lawyer background. It's like my I
don't know econ statistics background
from undergrad. uh that I know that
there's a 5 percent significance level
1% and so here I'm giving you know 5%
but you know I wouldn't even give 1% so
I'm being more generous and saying okay
significant in this in this range um uh
I guess I'm being less generous with 5%
but but I just want to be clear so I'm
going to lay it out so you got to let me
lay it out. All right
>> you are because you did adopt it unless
you want to come back and say I'm not I
I take back 5%. Are you going to say
that?
>> I I'm going to stick with it. I'm
sticking with the 5%. In fact I'm saying
it's specifically 5%. That's what I
think.
>> Okay. The fact that you would say that
Denim's deserves 5% culpability, not for
failure to moderate and her norms with
respect to her moderation
responsibilities and her norm to
minimize risk.
>> Hold on. Wait, hold on.
>> Oh my god.
>> Hold on. Wait. It's I want to I want to
It's I'm going to say it's 5.25%.
>> Okay. Greater than 5%. Fair. Okay. Well,
how you're doing this right now sounds
like you're kind of like being like
you're trying to say that what I'm
saying is ridiculous. That uh a little
bit. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, so what's the [__] is your
point with that? How would we assess
significance in any other degree? How
would we supposed to So clearly you're
arguing that they cuz you're not going
to say that if they have insignificant
responsibility that they should be
punished this way. Fair. So how else am
I supposed to assess their culpability
in relation to what happened? because I
think you're trying to come at it from a
direction of of like you're you're
you're hitting it with this like degree
of specificity that I don't think like
that I think you're using that to try to
to try to like weasel out of some pretty
just obvious observations to make. Like
if you were in Ethan's shoes, [laughter]
it's just like non-argument after
non-argument. I I'm like totally
>> blinded, man.
>> It's so bad.
>> It's so [__] bad.
>> And you couldn't know for sure like from
whose community this caller came,
>> you would do a shotgun blunder
regardless of their responsibility.
Regardless
>> any No, what I'm trying to say is any
reasonable person in that position would
have a shared kind of like animosity or
sense of blame towards just the whole
group
>> even for people who have insignificant
responsibility. That would be
reasonable.
>> I don't think there's anything
reasonable or not Hutch. But but this is
what this is what I think you're doing
with like you're using these words like
significant and trying to get at these
percent.
>> Answer a single [__] question when
you cannot answer a single question.
That should worry you so bad.
>> Oh my god, bro.
>> Try to engage with what I'm saying
without trying. You're trying to say
that
>> further. a person in Ethan's position uh
given the fact that he can't pinpoint
exactly who justified who among the
culpable parties had is most responsible
would be justified in being angry at the
whole
>> I understand what you're suggesting but
the question is there's a minimum
threshold you wouldn't say that a a
person in Ethan's position
>> um but this is unquantified
>> oh my god Hutch let me [__] talk so
you wouldn't say that someone in Ethan's
position it would be reasonable for them
to you know target someone who has like
no culpability right there
>> like yes of course
>> all right and you would also uh you
would not accept that he target people
who have trivial responsibility whatever
word you want to put on it man I mean
like
>> I don't think but I don't think it's
certain though none of that
>> that's what we're talking about and
that's why you're asking for specific
percentages you did ask you did ask what
do you mean by
>> you did you're the
>> what do you mean by significant
>> but but yeah exactly but like you're the
one that's introducing these like
individual values that we can't quantify
the point is someone in Ethan's position
I think would be justified in being
suspicious of everyone in the sense that
like you know like I don't know who but
it could have been any of them and and
and just being angry at like all of them
and certainly he was justified in
feeling a sense of like what I would
think would be like righteous rage that
after the fact it became a joke. It was
like a joke to these people. And at at
that was at best it was a joke. At
worst, at worst, the same creators after
the fact, including more recently Taylor
Loren, who was making a joke about it,
like they they thought it was like the
like a source of comedy.
>> Yeah. Why?
>> But that would I don't know about you,
but that would make me I would boil with
rage if I if that was me.
>> Okay.
>> That's not funny. There's nothing about
that that's funny. We're well beyond
internet beef at this point. The
government, you're in the system now.
like you you're maybe you're asking
yourself like oh my god are they gonna
take my kids away that is way too far
and I don't think it's trivial to mock
that or make light of it or justify it.
Whether you think it's trivial on some
other norm of being like respectful to
people you know after some tragedy
occurs of like you know having some uh
standard of decency that is a separate
inquiry as to whether or not they're
after um you know conduct behavior
like it violates some separate norm or
standard of decency separate from the
act itself right be I'll give you an
example Right? If someone laughs at the
fact that Charlie Kirk got assassinated
after the fact, you wouldn't say that
they're culpable for the act itself. And
you would recognize that that's that
having their own like moral violation in
the laughter is separate from extending
culpability of the assassination itself.
You understand that, don't you? Yes.
>> It would be a different kind of
calculation instead instead of right.
But but this is not this is both. This
is a both situation. So like all of
those creators were number one saying
that it was justified and number two
they were joking about it after the
fact.
>> I have I have been I've been asking for
people to present when one of these
three creators said that calling CPS was
>> you just watched a video you just
watched a video
>> in which she never said that this this
predates so so I just want to this is
the logical entailment of you. You agree
that that that video edited in the way
it was represents and purports and it
makes sense that it does that this
happened before the CPS call. So she
can't say you can't say that this is her
justification of the CPS event because
linear time. Correct.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's the point. That's the
point.
>> What do you mean?
>> This this was before like Okay, hang on.
Let me walk you through this. Okay.
Did she um did did she agree with the
claim that Bad Empanada was making in
the video that Ethan's kids got gardi
because he was negligent?
>> Uh she says that it's dangerous. She
said it was dangerous.
>> No, no, no, no, no. Um
>> she she did she agree is what I asked.
>> I'm not sure that. Uh hang on, I'll I'll
I'll rewatch it.
>> All of this cuz everything that he said
>> I'll rewatch it, too. To me, she's very
she's very clearly saying like, "Oh,
this explains so much to stop talking.
Stop talking."
She's very obviously agreeing with the
claim.
>> It all makes sense now. It makes sense
why he doesn't care about Palestinian
children when he is neglecting his own.
How are you, how is this happening?
>> So, someone asked that and she's reading
from a viewer who said who says it makes
sense that he doesn't care about
Palestinian kids because he's negligent
about his own.
>> No, no, no, no, no. Like, it start at
like 50 55 seconds. And is it how is it
that like maybe once a week I I look
into what Ethan Klein's been up to and
every time I manage to find and more
terrible [__]
>> This is where Ethan tells the story
about his family getting
>> Gardo
>> I'm not seeing what you're alleging. So
what did you say? Did Did she agree with
the assessment of negligence?
>> I'll give I'll give you the exact time
stamp. Hold on.
>> Why doesn't he just screen share as he
said this?
Honey, bring your boyfriend here. He
sued them. Ethan sued the terrorists.
>> Thank you for the $5, Jim. Thank you.
>> So 144. She goes, "H,
what do you think she meant by that?"
>> Hang on. So this is I'll
go to 129.
>> Start at 1:30. Start at 1:30, but start
at 1:30.
>> So it it cuts the first cut after 1:30.
It It goes to bad.
>> Is covered in dog [__]
>> No wonder it's covered in dog [__] The
children raised by parasites previously
unknown to science from science. I
wonder why she got kicked over all of
this cuz everything that he said why he
skipped over all this story which by the
way was apparently comp compiled by his
crew.
>> No wonder this
>> Okay, so I'm willing to say based on
that reaction
that's bad. H she's kind of being cute
and suggesting that Ethan is hiding.
>> What if I say cute? What
>> what I mean to say is I I'm going to
grant you something. Okay. Can you
Are you Are you listening? I don't know
if you're listening. I
>> I'm listening, but I want you to She
keeps going.
>> It's like so frustrating. This
>> [__] is always sick.
>> No, no, but did you listen to the It
makes sense now.
Makes sense why he doesn't care about
Palestine.
>> She says, "No wonder." So, she's like
obviously granting that uh Badinata's
claims are correct.
>> Okay, listen. I think that she uh by her
uh tone and indication there is
suggesting that she probably is
sympathetic to the view that uh this is
neglectful. Okay. I think that that
that's uh pretty much implied by her
conduct. I don't think it's explicit,
but but here's what I'm going to ask
you, Hutch.
>> I will accept that. But I think
>> very
>> Just shut the [__] up for one minute,
dude. Please.
>> Mild interpretation of what she said.
Cuz when she says, "Hm, no wonder D."
That is her very obviously saying
>> she's suggesting to
>> she she believed that what he was saying
was correct. She's suggesting that um by
her kind of like demure or kind of like
little koi little thing that um she
thinks that there's something like
either negligent or [__] up or that
like there's potential credence to
what's going on.
>> I'm going to ask you this Hutch.
>> Does taking the view that that Ethan was
neglectful in the contraction of Yardia
as described by Ethan is having that
view that it in fact was neglectful. If
that is your view is does someone with
that view who expresses that view are
they culpable or
>> now I'm gonna let me ask the [__] You
won't let me [__] talk because you
know you know it's absurd. IT'S ABSURD.
LET me finish. No, I'm not going to move
on.
>> I'm going to lawyer you. I'm going to
lawyer you.
>> I am not moving. I am not going to
respond unless you let me.
>> No, but you're doing the [__] You
can't take Will you Will you put your
foot basically to applaud Solita? Do not
move. Hold the line. Do not move.
Literally, this has to happen every time
now. Do not move on. If he interrupts,
do not move on. Stand on this point.
Don't let it move off. Receive an
answer. A yes or a no.
>> Ask your question. So, you presented
that to me. I granted you something. I
My question comes first touch and then
you can ask and I will answer. I've
answered all your questions.
>> Why are Let me I will I start to ask my
question I start to ask the question
interrupt me. All right. So these are
the question.
>> Ask the question again. Go ahead.
>> Is is the expression
>> of the view that one feels that Ethan
Klein was in fact negligent with respect
to the Giardia incident. Does expression
of that view on one's stream pres give
one culpability for a CPS call later on
by some unknown
>> in a vacuum with no other factors? No,
that alone would not be enough to
convict. Okay, but you're familiar.
>> Close.
>> But you're familiar.
>> Hold on. But you're familiar with the
concept of like factors, right?
>> I I understand factors.
>> Okay. So other factors. So like it's her
substantiating
bad
like literally I would be in such a
[__] rage. This guy's literally
trying to talk down to you when he is
the stupidest [__] in the world.
Washed up COD YouTuber. when you're like
a [__] you know, decent lawyer, went
to a decent school, was at a big farm,
quit to stream, know way more about this
topic than him. Been raping him on the
substance of this topic for two hours.
This guy's never won an argument against
Pisco and he's trying to talk down him.
He's trying to condescend now. He's
trying to go, "Uh, you understand the
idea of factors?"
Yes, I understand factors. Hodgej
and so everyone understands factors.
Hajj
very clearly is telling her audience, oh
wow, this makes so much sense now. She's
very clearly saying
>> implicitly doing that
>> very clearly. And then she also says, by
the way, guys, this is really serious.
His kids could die.
And then also,
>> I'm not done. There's one more factor.
Okay? And then also there's hella people
in her chat spamming. Somebody should
call CPS.
>> So he's getting away with this lie. He
is getting away with this [__] lie,
dude. It's so annoying. Oh my god. I
need to send it to Peace Go
telepathically.
Now, would you agree that that is some
level of possible culpability?
>> No.
not for the action itself, for the CPS
call. That's unhinged to think that she
has culpability for for that merely that
for the CPS call that's unhinged. Okay?
>> And let me explain why because we're
we're going to get into it, right? So
give you think it's a 0% chance.
>> So she so that I think is a violation.
One, I don't think it's necessarily
negligent what you're talking about.
Kids will do things and uh accidents
happen and I don't think that it shows
negligence. I just want to be clear
about that that um they contracted a
disease. All right. So, I want to be
clear that I don't agree that this is uh
necessarily indicative of negligent
behavior, just to be honest with you.
Okay. And I
>> with Ethan with his f. Okay. Yeah, I
agree.
>> I'm just expressing why do you like say
like I agree. What like
>> Oh my god. Thank finally. He's literally
he's getting so annoyed with it. Oh my
god. Finally.
I don't know how Pisco has so much
patience, dude. Pisco has so much
patience. I don't understand how it
hasn't happened already. How he hasn't
already got out.
>> Oh my god.
>> What are you
>> I don't know how we got there. What are
we doing? Are you on your So the thing
is I'll say things and people will
distort everything I'm saying. So I want
to be clear about where I stand. I don't
think that the mere fact that your kid
contracted Jardia, which Ethan states
very strongly uh that he believes that
his children have during the video, I
don't think the mere fact that they
contracted it, even through feces, even
through dog feces, even through uh even
a perfectly responsive parent, this kind
of [__] happens. And I don't think that
you've shown negligence by the mere fact
that they've contracted this disease.
The reason I'm saying this, Hutch,
because it feels like I need to justify
everything I say to you is to make sure
people understand my view on whether or
not this entails negligence. It's not my
view that it entails negligence,
>> but the notion that the if one has the
belief that it is negligent and they
express that belief that they feel it's
like, "Oh yeah, that's negligent. Why?
How could you let I would never let my
baby do that? That's just irresponsible
parenting." at the expression of that
view in by in isolation or in
conjunction with the the different
things that you've said that that
constitutes culpability for some whack
job later on who calls CPS that is
bizarre, untenable, totally [__] up,
not true and you would never apply this
standard to anyone else. I mean it it
really just boggles the mind that you
think that that independent conduct now
they could be violating their own norms
of moderation. They could be vi
violating like the the um you know a
standard of decency with respect to
other graders to give caveats etc. But
that is a different ethical violation
than culpability for the act itself
which I want to get to at some point.
You'll let me um put that out.
>> Well now
>> yeah exactly that's part of the point
right English accent. You can't you
can't tell you can never know who called
it for all you know it's a H3 fan
deliberately false flagging in order to
or a Destiny fan deliberately false
flagging in order to stoke tension. Like
that literally could be the case because
you have no information. You do not have
any information on the identity of this
person.
So how how can you point fingers?
I want to to like test your ethics here
because like okay so let let you know
for example we've had we've had um
there's been an example of of of a LLM
that um enabled someone's unaliving
ideiation and then that person went on
to unal alive themselves. Now the
ultimate culpability for the taking the
decision to unal alive themselves
>> that now I want to to like test your
ethics here because like okay so let you
know for example we've had we've had um
there's been an example of of of a LLM
that um enabled someone's unaliving
ideiation and then that person went on
to unal alive themselves. Now the
ultimate culpability for the taking the
decision to unal alive themselves that
that would be rest on the person right
like ultimately they're the one that
made the decision but like does the LLM
and the software company that engineered
that uh model have any culpability there
>> yeah so we're talking about is the
context of products liability and um
there I I think that you can make an
argument that if the usage of the device
itself um constitutes an unjustifiable
risk uh such that we can reasonably
foresee that this kind [__] would happen
uh based on that. I just think I think
think you're close to making that
empirical case uh for this kind of
conduct and and certainly not the
conduct if it's merely negligent in the
context of these kinds of statement to
to like if someone who's negligent on
that you're going to get a civil
judgment or something in the again we're
talking ethics here so we're just
removing it from you for that for that
not for copyright
>> knowledge that there can be causes of
action and uh culpability for for
negligence and stuff but but not when
it's being like the causal chain here is
being broken by the clearly culpable
actors who do the bad thing here. And
so, for example, I'll give you I'll give
you an example. Let's say that you have
um some kind of inherently dangerous
device. Okay? So, you have a lawn mower
that um
>> Why is his face like that? AIDS or
something? Probably aids from having
loads of [__]
>> sharing needles or something. He's
pulling faces cuz he's a [__]
performative gay loser. Okay. It's just
like totally the most unbearable
[__] womanly behavior. just pulling
faces.
>> God, it's so [__] unbearable.
>> All right. And Tain's a product defect
and it is dangerous to maneuver and
sometimes the [__] flies off.
>> You think it makes sense?
>> And so someone is operating it and uses
the lawn mower to kill their own kid on
purpose. Would you say that that lawn
mower which has the defect which could,
you know, cause the death of a child in
certain circumstances carries with it a
risk? You would not. Exactly. Right. So
you have to understand that there's this
notion of uh in the in the damages
context in in in log and we're talk but
I think this also applies to our own
intuitions and ethics there's this
notion of proximate causation. Okay,
that in order to really feel liable for
the kinds of things that we are talking
about here and we're talking about like
big lawsuits and from an ethical
perspective but in the civil damages
context for whatever harm is being
caused that there's some kind of
attenuation and and often times the
causal chain is cut off by the culpable
conduct of other people. So for example,
let's say that um you know there are two
actors involved in some kind of lawsuit
and one really they did something
horribly intentional and malicious. this
notion of proximate causation which is I
think reflecting our intuitive notions
of morality that is going to
notwithstanding potential reckless
conduct of others we're going to see uh
the cause and source of the harm as uh
being too attenuated to to track to the
specific actor who was negligent but not
intentional and malicious. And so that's
what I'm trying to describe here is no
doubt that there potentially is some
like source of of negligence here or
some kind of uh bad statement that's
made by Denims. I would agree with that.
I even agree that like she is implying
that she agrees that it was negligent.
What you're failing to provide is a
close enough proximity to the malicious
conduct. You're not even close to
ascribe the kind of malicious
intentional culpable conduct that would
justify these kinds of things and you
know bankrupting people. I mean that
that's what you
>> I don't know how to but I don't know how
to um I don't know how to reconcile what
you just said
with with respect to culpability and
this idea that it's absurd to suggest
that she had any culpability. I don't
know how to reconcile that with the fact
that you called her negligent and I
don't know how to reconcile that with
the fact that you said that by not
moderating you increase the risk of
something happening like you you you
seem capable in one moment of
understanding that someone can be that
someone can have um can indirectly
like contribute to something happening.
You you you seem to be able to
comprehend that over here. But then when
we get to the point where I say she's
partly culpable just like all those
creator creators are, you fall back on
this idea that it's preposterous to
>> Let me build a case. So because clearly
I'm not explaining myself well. You
understand there could be different
ethical obligations. Correct.
>> Generally.
>> Yeah. So like you have an obligation.
What do you mean?
>> Yeah. In life like you have an
obligation uh not to infringe the rights
of others. You have an obligation to
take due care when you're driving the
car. Okay. And a violation of one
ethical obligation doesn't necessitate a
violation of some other ethical
obligation that is distinct. Correct. So
like the fact that I Okay. So when I say
that you could have a self-standing
violation of an obligation related to
responsible moderating and that doesn't
entail culpability for the specific act.
What I'm telling you is the following.
You have a self-standing ethical
obligation not to pursue frivolous CPS
calls or um you know harassing
>> is the currency.
>> Thank you. And we should call it I I
slammed at Corona. That's what I'm going
to call it. Thank you, Limbo Gang. Huge
appreciate. Thank you.
>> False reports to CPS or whatever. And
that
>> listen to take a second to listen. All
right. So, there's a
>> little wordy sometimes. Okay. Just All
right. Ethical obligation number one. Do
not falsify maliciously CP or state
things to CPS that are frivolous or not
bases for genuine concern or something
like that. Okay? Or not sufficient.
>> Ethical obligation number one.
>> Ethical obligation number two, do not
needlessly increase uh risk by failing
failing to responsibly moderate. I just
gave you two different ethical
obligations. Yes.
>> Yeah. And you would agree that violation
of one ethical obligation does not
entail in any way violation of both.
Correct?
>> No, not necessarily. Nobody. So, one one
can violate one and not the other,
right? One could not moderate
responsibly and do the malicious call.
One could do the malicious call and not
responsibly like these are not they
don't entail each other, right? They're
they're separate. So when I say there is
a risk yet they're not culpable for the
violation of the ethical obligation,
what I'm telling you is they're perhaps
culpable for something else, you know,
failure to responsibly moderate. But
human beings and you and I see the
culpability of that conduct as a lot
less significant than the one person who
intentionally, maliciously, maliciously
violates this obligation on the CPS
front. Okay, that's what I'm talking So
the so the person who made the decision
to make that call that is the much
bigger violation in my opinion like that
person committed something that is more
immoral
>> my contention
>> than being than being negligent but
that's not the same thing that's not the
same thing as saying that that denims is
has 0% culpability because if you
acknowledge that creators wield
influence and if by not setting an
example they increase the risk of
someone in their audience doing
something then they of course
>> necessarily have contributed to that
>> they don't necessarily do that just just
merely so if I increase so I'll I'll
give you an I'll give you an example all
right so this should be very intuitive
>> someone says to their this is an
unfortunate example sometimes that these
we have to do these someone says uh to
their daughter their child
hey you know go out into the bad part of
town I think you'll be okay if you go to
that part.
>> Negligent parental advice there.
>> Mhm.
>> This is a very good
>> I'm I'm going I'm I'm going to
>> analogy. By the way,
>> someone That's where my mind was going
too, by the way.
>> Shut the [__] up. Shut the [__] up.
Sorry.
Someone does something horrible to this
person. A murder.
I don't know if this guy is like fried
by aderall or if his dose isn't high
enough. Like what is going on? This is
like [__] child levels of ADHD
interruption. Like two words in, oh
there
man, shut the [__] up and learn how to
have a conversation like a [__]
adult.
And someone says, "Mr. Father, sir, you
are culpable.
You agree
>> partly? Yeah.
>> Having a bad saying.
>> If a father told his daughter, I want
you to go to the bad part of town where
people get raped and killed and then the
kid and then the daughter gets raped and
killed and you don't think the father
would have any culpability.
>> Ethical culpability for the murderer.
All right. Not because they contributed
to a risk or the murderer.
You understand what I'm saying? I
understand that the father in this
situation didn't literally murder the
daughter, but people would rightfully
ostracize that father.
>> Yes, they would say yes. Yes. What they
would say is
>> listening to this smoothrained idiot not
understand high school level logic has
been the most anger inducing moment in
my week. Thank you. I guess
>> thank you for the $20. You appreciate
it. Thank you so much. Thank you.
>> You're culpable for imperiling perhaps
your your daughter with bad advice. They
wouldn't say that you share culpability
in the murder.
>> Okay.
>> Not legal culpability,
>> ethical culpability in the murder. Okay.
Exposing yourself. Okay. I
>> Hold on. But but the murder in this
situation, right, would not have
happened if the father didn't give that
horrible advice, right?
>> I understand that there are but for
cause. No, you have just to be clear
here. I understand in the example I just
provided that the father is a but for
cause. You haven't even shown
>> in any respect that she is a but for
cause for the CPS call. You haven't even
start I just want to be clear. You have
I just want no wait. I I I just want to
make I just want to make clear for the
audience that you haven't even started
to make the claim. No wait. I just want
to make sure that the audience
understands. All right. So I'm just
going to make sure the audience
understands. All right. This is not for
you audience.
No one has even started make the claim
that denims acron or frogan are but for
causes for the CPS call not even
started. So an example yes for sure the
father is a but for cause for the death
of his daughter.
>> We don't say in the typical course of
analysis that the father is partly
culpable for the murder of her of his
daughter. What we say is he's
responsible in negligence and parenting.
PE. There's literally still another
[laughter] [__] hour and 40 minutes
of this, man.
>> Okay. Okay. [laughter] It's fine.
>> Uh, you know, culpable for creating an
environment where that type of thing
could occur. What he's not culpable for
is the malicious and unlawful killing of
his daughter. Agreed? Yes or no?
>> Ethically, I do think he's culpable in
this spot. I totally disagree. I mean,
there's a there's a different
>> Well, there's a different scenario that
we could we could we could use, right?
like um [laughter] something more direct
like what about um firearm storage,
>> right? Like let's say your parent has a
firearm and they don't properly store it
>> and then a kid finds a firearm and
starts using it like a toy, accidentally
kills himself.
>> Mhm.
>> Is the parent culpable?
>> I think culpable for um negligence and
for creating a an unjustifiable and
substantial risk.
>> Huh. And you don't think that a father
telling his daughter to go to a part of
town where people are raped and killed
would would be a similar kind of logic.
>> The same logic applies in in the course
of the the parenting advice. What he's
not culpable for is the murder. Do you
understand the distinction there? The
murder. So
>> I don't understand how these [laughter]
are different. So do you understand how
society views death in the abstract,
accidents in the abstract, the causing
of death of someone else as uh generally
bad but they view
>> murder as something horrific.
>> You understand that distinction between
someone dying for example of natural
causes and murder. Okay. So
>> yes.
>> So there are instances in which people
can be have culpability for the death of
somebody. No doubt have have culpability
and and usually when we apply
culpability and this is another case
that this totally fails on only when
you're uh failing to adhere to a
substantial and unjustifiable risk.
Okay, sometimes there are justifiable
risk. Sometimes it's not a sub, you
know, substantial risk. Let's say for
example, you know, you tell your kid to
go out into the good part of town, but
for you telling her to go to the good
part of town where she would be safe, uh
it happened to be that the killer was
there in the good part of town. You're a
butt for cause there, but you haven't uh
breached. Okay, got it.
>> I understand what you're saying.
>> So, just because you share potentially
some culpability in the death of
somebody um
>> in in the case in which you've done
something unjustifiable and you're
substantially increasing risk, right?
Not just moderate increased risk,
substantially increased risk, right? You
tell your daughter to go drive a car
down to the [__] supermarket. Now,
you're increasing risk, but it's not
substantial and it's not unjustifiable.
So, but in the case in which you are
doing those things, I'm going to finish.
Let me finish. I know I'm worried.
You're culpable for increasing the risk.
You're not culpable for murder. That's
that's the difference. Okay.
>> You're culpable, I think, partly
culpable for your daughter dying. You're
not maybe we're quibbling about the
words here, right? But
>> but here's here's the distinction,
Hutch. What Ethan wants
>> you almost had something there. Hold on.
You you you figured out where I was
going there, right? So like so so so so
um denims what you're saying is like
literally not culpable for um like the
act of calling CPS but this analog
really figured out where I was going
there and and Hutch doesn't even know
where he was going. He starts short
circuiting and can't figure out what his
next sentence was going to be. Nice one
you [__] idiot.
>> She could [snorts] be culpable for the
fact that CPS was called. Okay. So, she
could be culpable for the uh for the
increasing the risk on that and the fact
that it was called. Here's the problem.
You haven't even begun. You haven't even
begun to make the empirical case for
that. And that's not So, the reason that
people are mad are is the malicious
aspect of it, the the incriminating
conduct, the call to CPS, not the the
fact that you've, you know, increased
the risk minimally or you potential
risk, right?
>> Thank you for the $5. Thank you. Huge
appreciate. Thank you.
Hold on. Wait, wait, hold on. I I really
am trying to explain it in the best.
>> But you're filibustering, bro. Every
time.
>> Yeah, you are. Like, so are you telling
me right now that there is a 0% chance
that someone in Denim's audience called
CPS?
>> No, I'm not.
>> So, she did. Did you understand? So,
when you say could, you're going to say
logical. Hold on.
>> Did you understand suggesting that?
>> No, you stop. So she could be partly
culpable for CPS having been called?
>> No. Not in my opinion. No. By unless by
by what you mean by could.
>> You just said it was not 0% though.
>> Culpability does not totally turn on
whether or not someone happens to emerge
from particular causal pathway in which
they come from the community.
Culpability uh relates to someone's
actions at the time that they're taken
and whether so right at the time that
she takes these actions that's the time
at which we analyze whether she did a
bad thing. Correct?
>> Yes or no? Of
>> course. Okay. Of course. So at the time
at the time she takes the action that's
the point at which you have to analyze
the culpability of her conduct. At the
time she says that is there a
significant chance in your mind? Right.
Or have you
>> not significant? No. Don't add that
word. I didn't say that. Yeah. So, so
when when all you say is is there a
chance? That's trivially [__] true.
There's a chance someone interprets your
words like the people are [__] crazy.
What do you mean? Like if all you mean
by chance is logical chance that and
that's crazy.
>> It's not it's not trivial because we
can't know. And so in the absence of
certainty,
>> so much of these arguments just ends up
coming back down to the
>> when when you ask possible, do you mean
is it logically possible or is it
plausible?
That's where it always comes back to,
man. Every time if Ethan knew for sure
whose audience that person came from,
and it did come from one of their
audience. Okay. This that like surely
you would agree like the fact that the
the the the that CPS was called like
within a week of that stream like like
and and then and she wasn't the only one
watching that. Um like so it came from
that space of the internet. Would
anybody even deny that?
>> Is there a chance that it came from is
it a chance? Is there a chance it came
from your community, Hutch? Sure.
So, you're just denim.
>> It's Do you think that the chances are
anywhere close to uh the idea that it
came from one of their audiences?
>> I don't know. I mean, do you have an
intuition for that? I My intuition is
>> I have an in my intuition came from my
my intuition is that like um it's
probably more likely on the margin that
um it came it comes from one of these
particular communities. The point is the
mere chance that it comes from a
particular community isn't enough for
you to say that that there's
culpability. So you acknowledging you
hang on a second. You acknowledging that
there's a distinction between the risk
factor with respect to you versus denims
is you acknowledging that significance
of risk matters. And that's why you
can't ignore significance of risk. When
you say I don't want to talk about
significant of risk, well then the idea
exclude the significant point when
you're talking about chances. So there's
a chance of anything, dude. Like there's
always a chance. So is there a
significant chance? Is there a
foreseeable significant chance that an
event that an outcome will be caused by
an action that you take,
right? That's always the question when
you talk about this stuff obviously
because if it's something you just
totally can't foresee, we wouldn't we
wouldn't place culpability. If it's not
significant, we certainly wouldn't
either. So like but but those that needs
to be
addressed
>> by your lights if significance of the
risk doesn't matter. You and I are both
culpable because it's possible. I guess
it's something we said triggered some
[__] crazy person. So, you need to
talk about significant risk if you even
want to get close to culpability
>> here. I just want to I'm I just want to
get like cuz I feel like it's been two
hours now about like we're trying to get
what we're what we're ultimately trying
to get at. Why is that
>> was you know was Ethan justified in
being furious with these creators?
>> No, that's not what you're trying to get
at. No. Like that's the point that I'm
trying to get at.
>> No, [laughter]
>> no one cares, Hutch. No one [__]
cares, dude.
>> That's like what this conversation is
all about.
>> Trying to because we're Hold on. Don't
go. Hold on. Hold on. Because Because
we're trying to unpack like whether or
not Ethan's actions were justified or
they fit what happened is like basically
what we're trying to get at here. And in
a situation like this where you can't
know and you'll never know. There's no
[clears throat] way unless the person
came forward and and admitted it and
said whose community they came from, you
just can't know. And so if you're in
Ethan's shoes and you see a pool of I'll
make it up, like a dozen creators and
they're all making light of the
situation, tacitly encouraging it,
justifying it, making jokes about it,
but you can't know which one
specifically that it came from. The
point is it could have been like any of
them plausibly. It could have been any
of their audiences. And so in that
moment I understand being angry with
like everybody at the ve at the very
like I mean you understand the very
least I mean surely you understand you
mean like you can understand his human
emotion. I mean
>> I would understand so I guess no no no
beyond beyond an emotion I can
understand in that moment wanting
accountability wanting to
>> the question isn't the question isn't
whether you understand
>> to impose consequences for that
violation done to me.
>> The question Hutch isn't whether you
understand the feeling or [snorts]
wanting it. The question is, is it right
to is it right to file lawsuits in this
context or to do whatever act that we're
going to if we haven't even breached yet
and talked about if you're not sure
whether a particular person is culpable
for the action or is is either for
example intentional about what they're
doing or significantly increasing risk.
Right? Would you ever say that it would
be justified to do something like
otherwise bad or malicious towards an
individual who doesn't a have evidence
that they intentionally incre like
increased risk or try to do it or b uh
no evidence that the risk that they
imposed was significant? No, you
wouldn't. You have to examine the the
quantum of risk here. Is it possible to
to ignore it?
>> I think I think we evaluate
responsibility just way differently. I
think this is an irreconcilable
difference of opinion.
>> You can't even argue your position,
Hudge. It's so [__] annoying people
do this.
>> No, agree. So, just to be clear, is it
your position today that uh denims
significantly increased the risk that
someone called TPS?
>> Yes.
>> Uh in virtue of what?
>> In virtue of the What do you Why are you
asking me this question?
>> In virtue of what do you think that
factors significantly increases
>> three factors? I'll say I'll say them
again though. Do you want me to say them
again? I already said this. It's the
three factors.
>> What's the What's the empirical case?
>> Number one, number one, she platformed
the bad empanada video and uh co-signed
his claims.
>> Co-signed onto them and and and and
expressed very, in my opinion,
explicitly that she agreed with the
claims. She then said that Ethan's kids
might die. and she saw people in her
chat making a call to action to like
somebody needs to call CPS and she
refused to moderate.
>> Wait, do you have any do you have any
evidence that she saw those Do you have
any evidence that she saw those
messages? Do you have evidence that she
saw those messages?
>> Uh, no.
>> You can't know. You can't know that she
was refusing to moderate responsibly,
right?
>> She constantly stares at chat. It's like
a meme with her. It's constantly.
>> You just said on your on your own
lights, you're not aware that she saw
the message.
>> Do you think it's plausible? Do you
think it's plausible that she wasn't
looking at chat at all? I had no idea
what was going on.
>> If by plausible, you think that it's
reasonably likely? Yes. I mean, I don't
look at chat. I haven't been looking at
chat.
>> Likely? No. Come on.
>> Based on in virtue of what? You know
that she like steadfastly intentionally
refused to moderate. Are you telling me
that you see every one of your chat
messages?
>> Have you watched a lot of her content?
>> No, I haven't [__] watched it. Most
of it content.
>> Hang on a second.
>> This kind of blows my mind. I've watched
a lot of Denim's content.
>> Oh my god. These are You haven't watched
a 100 hours of Denim's Twitch streams?
>> You're saying you haven't watched a lot
of her like at all? Like at all?
>> No, I haven't watched a lot of Denim's
content.
>> Why are you speaking so confidently on
this?
>> Oh my god. Because none of it requires
that. None of it requires that, dude. He
is literally trying to find any out he
can. Dude, Pisco should It's crazy the
level of just patience and turning the
other cheek Pisco shows. How are you
going to let your friend rap [__] you
constantly like this in a conversation?
He's being such a slippery, worthless
piece of [__] man. Truly, how do you
let him just rap [__] you like this
repeatedly?
>> I don't understand why why are you
giving your opinion about like, well, it
doesn't seem likely to me if you don't
know anything about her content.
>> But there usually is a requirement,
right? If you're going to make a case
that she intentionally it's your claim,
isn't it? that she intentionally refused
to moderate those calls to CPS. Isn't it
your burden to show that?
Is it your burden?
>> I'm I'm just a little burden.
>> He's trying anything to not talk about
it.
>> Seriously, dude [laughter]
experiencing with you right now.
>> I mean I mean you can you can make all
these appeals. Don't you think Don't you
think it would help you in these
conversations to spend some time like
familiarize it help you in these
conversations to like have a like you
know high school level education? H
don't you think it would benefit you in
these conversations not be dented as
[__] Don't it benefit you in these
conversations not be like a [__]
stimulant adult [__] spazzing out and
interrupting every two seconds? these
people, their character, their
>> Is it your burden when you have a claim
analysis? If you make a claim, if if you
make a claim, is it your burden? Yes.
>> Do you constantly stare at Do you
constantly stare at chat and respond to
it?
>> Yes.
>> Do you read everything that the chat
says?
>> Not all the time. No.
>> Okay. So, in virtue of the fact that
someone tends to look at their chat a
lot of if I'm having a conversation with
you, but if it's just me and chat and
I'm watching a video, I'm constantly
watching chat.
>> Okay. So, but the mere fact that someone
tends to look at chat, don't you have an
additional burden to show that they
actually disregarded uh uh you know this
this risk and that they actually saw
>> YOUR WHOLE WAIT I'M asking I
that's what you're saying you're saying
[laughter]
or not and you have the burden that's
the question I'm not interested in this
line with interest in this line of
question you don't have the evidence
preposterous
>> you don't find it preposterous find that
you make a claim that you don't have you
don't have burden
>> you I don't think you should have such
confident opinions when you don't know
anything about
>> Oh my god, dude. There's no way.
>> Peace go. I cannot believe he is not
just losing it with this guy right now,
dude.
>> You make the claim that she disregarded
and and intentionally didn't moderate or
did I make that claim? Who among us
made?
>> Why wouldn't you familiarize yourself
with her out of curiosity?
>> Between us, who made the affirmative
claim about Dennis? want to move past. I
don't Hutch. I'm not going to move past
it because you're making a claim and
saying that I'm doing something uh weird
by not watching all of Denim's comment.
>> You said it before though. You've said
it before.
>> Here's
a simple question. As between us, who as
between us who made the claim about
Denise?
>> I don't I'm not going to go down this
road with I'm not going to not go down
this.
>> You made you made this conversation
about like whether or not his actions
were justified or appropriate like an
appropriate response.
>> [__] him. It's actually disgusting, bro.
>> But then you'll also say that you don't
really know much about the creators or
what they did. It's like
>> why wouldn't you take the time to like
look into that first?
>> So this this is an artful thing that
you're doing. The mere fact that I
haven't watched all of Denim's content
wait. The mere fact that I haven't So,
I'm just going to address what you just
said. I am going to go back to my line
so you're not you haven't distracted me
from that. The mere fact that I haven't
watched all of Denim's content or all of
Casey Tron's content or all of Rogan's
content, that is not any contradiction
between me and my opinion thus far. Can
you identify a contradiction or some
kind of thing that uh doesn't make sense
on that view?
>> Well, you seemed taken off.
>> Can you or can you not? Can you or can
you not?
>> You got you you got taken off guard.
>> You made You just made an additional
claim. You You just made an additional
claim. You said it was weird that I had
a
Generally think speaking though you
don't think it would behoove you to like
familiarize yourself with these creators
what they said said and did during that
time you seem to have not like looked
into it very much but you also have
these strong opinions about the scope of
the scope of myity of like what he did
compared with what he was responding to
>> for for the scope of my claims I believe
I've done appropriate research for the
scope of my claims I haven't made
broader claims that would require me to
do the kind of research that you're
talking about you. Wait, did you So, so
hut hut hut. I just answered all your
concerns. I would like you to answer. I
just hut
hutch. I just answered your claims and
you're not claiming he's taking it too
far. I just I just answered your
concerns.
>> Did you make a claim about Denim's
intent or not?
>> Yes. Isn't your Isn't it your is it your
burden?
>> I think to any reasonable
>> Oh my god. Just answer the question,
dude.
who is familiar with her burden and
familiar with her
discussing
what was going on. Is it so is it your b
is it your burden to demonstrate that
>> beyond a like beyond
>> a reasonable to a reason to a reasonable
certainty to a reasonable certainty.
>> I'm not I'm not here to try to convict
in front of a jury. I'm just saying a
reasonable person would come to the
conclusion that she was watching her
chat and she saw what they were saying.
So, but I'm not asking for rhetoric
here. I'll give you something to support
the claim. I'm not asking that. No, no,
[laughter] no, no, no, no. So, first I
want to establish it is your burden. You
agree it's your burden to demonstrate
your claim. Correct.
>> Who
>> is it your burden or not? Can you answer
it if
>> I'm tired? I'm I'm tired,
>> dude.
You can't make it up. You can't make it
up. You actually cannot make this [__]
up, man.
This is just crazy. This is just [__]
crazy, man. I am losing my [__] mind,
bro. I just I can't, man. I can't.
This is the most embarrassing showing I
have seen in a debate,
months, years. I truly like it it it's
been a long time.
>> Come on. Actually,
>> this would go by a lot faster if you
just acknowledge obvious. If you make a
claim, you got to justify, don't you?
>> These lawyer tricks trick, bro. You make
any reasonable person thinks that she
was looking at her chat [laughter]
was 100%. So, you're saying are you
saying that you assume it? Are you
assuming it?
>> I think it's a safe assumption.
>> Are you so So, so you're So, an
assumption, in other words, is something
that you don't justify. Fair.
>> It could I could be wrong.
>> Okay. So, so, but you made a point. So,
>> so is anyone in his community going to
point out that he just pulled what
Vardeem did to him?
>> No, they have no self reflection or
introspective skills or anything. No,
they've got literally no capability for
that.
>> Here's the problem, right? If you make a
claim about a particular intent, and
this is, by the way, not too dissimilar
to what you say of me, right? Like,
don't you say the same thing to me?
You're like, you can't say you know
Ethan's intent. You have to prove that.
And now when I come back with you and
say, "Hey, listen. Uh, when you're
trying to speak about Denim's intent,
don't you need to show that? You're
like, I don't want to answer that
question. I'm You made me tired. I mean,
what the [__]
>> Okay. Do you think it's possible that
she didn't see anything in a chat?
>> By possible. Do you mean logically
possible?
>> That's like I That's That's like a
subtle highlevel
jab undermining to the audience there.
You made me tired. He's dropping the
what was it? Peter Coffin
Destiny reference to an audience of
DGers
undermining Hutch h reminding you and
being like isn't he like that other
embarrassing guy
ve very very
mean of Po to do that. Very mean.
>> Plausible that she didn't see any of
that.
>> So So I think plausible is like you know
is there a decent chance she didn't see
it? I think it's
>> made me tired.
>> Okay. Cuz cuz guess what the reason I
have that intuition is because both you
and I agree that we don't see the
entirety of our chats and there are you
would agree by the way between you and I
that we don't see
>> there's just some old like Destiny
versus Peter Coffin like communism
debate or some [__] where you know Peter
Coffin can't answer some questions going
you know what you've done you've made me
tired
>> majority of chats that that come in our
chat correct
>> I think I think I say most of the chat
it's only when I'm having conversations
like that like Now,
I really invest in what I'm watching.
But at this point in my career, back
when I was playing video games, [__] no.
I barely looked at chat. It wasn't that
often. These days, I constantly look at
both chats. And so does she, by the way.
>> I think
>> that's her whole thing. She's constantly
interacting with chat. That's her
pattern. That's what I know about her.
Wait, hang on, hang on, hang on. I'm
trying to support the claim, okay? Like,
I know this about her as a creator is
that she is constantly interacting with
her chat. [laughter] like constantly
like they're they are a big part of
their content. Like some creators like I
don't know if Destiny necessarily does
it in the same way like he he interacts
with chat but it's like he's off doing
his own thing he's doing he's kind of
doing his own react or whatever like not
everybody works that way.
>> I try to make a concerted effort to look
at my chat and I miss like 50 plus
percentage of everything that comes up
there.
>> You say it's plausible she missed it.
Okay.
But but even even putting that aside,
even if I granted it, Hutch, even if I
grant it that she bears culpability, her
failure to mitigate um you know these
kinds of risks, failure to moderate, it
just doesn't extend to the act itself.
That kind of thing. We we don't have
that that normative intuition that um
you know, a failure to adjust for for
risk that this is a substantial risk
that based on this content someone's
going to call CPS. You couldn't justify
that, man. You couldn't justify that
there's a substantial risk that uh you
know given that statement that someone
as a result of that is the natural and
probable consequence of that is that
someone calls CPS. It just isn't
tailored to it.
>> I can easily justify putting myself in
Ethan's shoes and looking at the whole
space that dogpiled and joked about it
and egged it on and justified it. I can
easily justify
in that moment feeling like they all
share culpability for contributing to
that to to their collective audienc's
culture of like
>> but that's a separate
>> unrivaled levels of like were beyond
hostility at that point. It's just it's
just uh it it was one of the most like
vicious
>> they do that
>> pylons I've ever seen in my entire
career going back nearly two decades.
The lefties do that to you.
>> Not not not like Listen, I've had I've
been on the receiving end of some
vicious [__] and nothing came close to
what the clients went through. I mean,
do you acknowledge
>> No, no, no, but I'm not.
>> Do you acknowledge that the act of like
Hold on, let me let me
>> Yeah, CPS [laughter] is bad. That's why
I said, why are you talking about it?
And yes, I did say that.
>> All right. I have a different question.
Yeah, go for it.
>> What do you think was what do you think
is worse? Like what do you think is the
more significant action? the laws or the
CPS
>> calling CPS vindictively and
maliciously.
>> Okay,
>> but that's not the question. The
question isn't between
>> No, it's [__] not. You need to
connect the creators to the culpable
actions and uh even if by the way you
you did
>> culpable in my mind,
>> including yourself, right? Because
there's a chance it came from
>> You have to lay that out. You [__]
you have to justify that, dude. Well, I
Okay, we get that Hudge. I everyone
understands that you have a position you
can't justify. We're asking you to try
to justify
>> from your community.
>> No, listen. Like for for egging it on,
for making light of it, and for joking
about it
>> and for that so so that community.
>> Yeah.
>> So I I I am so pleased that I'll see
this. You applying this standard to
liberals. You apply this standard to all
sorts of creators who have, let's just
put it modestly, less than stellar
reputations and act.
[snorts]
Yeah, face guy. Let's just put it. Who
are we talking about? Who are we talking
about? Less than stellar reputations
that Hutch might not apply the standard
to
>> for making light of it and for joking
about it and for that. So, so
>> they fostered that community.
>> Yeah. I I I am so pleased that I'll see
this you applying this standard to
liberals. You apply this standard to all
sorts of creators who have let's just
put it modestly less than stellar
reputations and actions when it comes to
moderation of their communities. Let's
just to put it mildly. I mean like you
are going to stand out.
>> Okay.
>> Called them out
>> that that they're culpable. So someone
crazy does something to Pisco because
they say that he's you know whatever
they say you're going to be like oh all
these people who are making false claims
and piling on Pisco people have
collective responsibility for the murder
of Pisco. You would never say that.
>> Surely surely you would agree that that
when we're talking about like
politicians
>> that that kind of culpability that would
be spread out like amongst hundreds of
thousands of creators and people with
with platforms and influence. It's a
little bit different in this situation
when we're talking about If you if you
just if you just spread out the
responsibility among enough people, none
of you are responsible enough to ever be
blamed for it. That's Hutch's position.
If we just all if we just all like
I don't know,
throw darts vaguely in one direction at
someone. Hundreds of us throw darts
vaguely in
the direction of someone
then you know is anyone really culpable
for the murder individually
>> about Charlie Kirk that after the fact
the Democrats are fostering communities
where they're doing things that with
their natural consequence is it causes
crazy people to I just want you to know
this entire thing I've been trying to
show you that the standard you're
applying is the conservative standard on
Charlie Kirk and you just said it
perfectly. Yes, it's scattered across.
That's the Republicans theory for why
Democrats deserve culpability for all
these crazy lunatics doing crazy [__]
You just described it.
>> You think if you think I'm being
inconsistent, you should just ask my
chat. What was I saying about people
that were making jokes about Charlie
Kirk?
>> You were not saying they're culpable for
murder. You were not saying that.
>> No, no, no. What I was saying was
>> You weren't saying that, right? You
weren't saying that, right?
>> No, that's not what I was But like
again, this is not analogous at all. But
what I was telling my chat like that
day, the day after, like I didn't find
any of the jokes funny. Like I was
telling people that this was a time for
everybody.
>> That was the question that you were just
asked. So it's a good thing you said
that because that was actually the
question you were asked. Pisco said,
"Oh, should you find jokes about Charlie
Kirk funny?" That's what Pisco said,
wasn't it? We all heard that like a
minute ago when Pis Pisco asked that,
right? Everyone heard that. or or or or
am I just in a shared delusion with
Hutch?
>> It's me being consistent though. I'm
saying like we all have calling them
culpable. You're not you're not so
>> No, but like you would be culpable in a
much more abstract sense.
>> Let's be concrete to that kind of
culture. And the only reason that I'm
picking on Destiny here is simply
because he has the most like I don't
know um spicy takes on the Charlie Curt.
>> I called him out.
>> No, but you don't. So
>> So here's the question. I'm not saying
you did you call him out or not. Don't
confuse the issue such and I'm not going
to get confused by it. So just be clear.
>> Is Destiny culpable for the murder of
Charlie Kirk because he joked about it
afterward in ways that you find
reprehensible? Is he culpable for the
murder?
>> No.
>> Okay. So the mere fact that you're part
of a collective that jokes about it
after the fact, makes light of the
murder, does some kind of funny memes
about it, that is not enough to satisfy
culpability. But but even what No, but
even what I'm not talking about like so
there's culpability for like a shared
responsibility for fostering communities
where this sort of behavior is
encouraged and celebrated and joked
about like that's one thing and then
there's like culpability for the act
itself and then there's like joking
about it after the fact
but no but I'm saying all of these
things are relevant considerations when
we evaluate was was Ethan justified in
extreme extreme action.
>> I totally agree. But here's the problem
though.
>> Okay,
>> here here's the problem. The culpability
for failure to moderate, the culpability
for failure to to making light of stuff,
right? And when you shouldn't do it,
it's being conflated with the malicious
act of the call itself. That's the
sneaky part. That's the part that
doesn't but
>> whether you are or not, people are and
they're saying, well, and you almost did
I actually think you did it here by by
saying, well, don't you acknowledge by
failure to moderate you acknowledge that
there's some culpability there. arguing
that for like half an hour, an hour. He
was arguing for like a full hour. He was
literally arguing that exact point. What
do you mean?
>> No, we cannot conflate these. We We
really can't.
>> I don't I I'm not conflating it. I feel
like you're trying to do this thing
where you're conflating it to try to
like uh make the point that you Well,
it's absurd to say that they're
responsible because ultimately it's up
to the person that did it. That's what
I'm saying.
>> Have been more clear this whole time.
I'm saying like if you are irresponsible
in your lack of moderation in in your
own words increase the risk for that
you're responsible for that but but but
if that conduct if that conduct
>> doesn't rise to a certain level of
significance it's negligible right so
you need to make the de so right it's
not enough to say you increase the risk
>> you you accept you will accept this
hutch it's not enough that you raise a
risk
>> I don't it's not it's not
>> dude listen to what he's going to say
you [__] idiot uh not trivial. Not
none of this is trivial. I don't think
any of them had clean hands in this
situation.
>> That that's not my point. You would
agree, wouldn't you, that raising the
risk minorly isn't culpable cont
literally according to your standard.
No, but you but you have
>> no on your view. I'm not asking on my
view. On your view, on your view, if you
raise the risk just a tiny little bit,
that's not culpable conduct, is it?
Not necessarily. No, but like here's the
thing though. Like
>> Yeah, I can smell it.
>> Is something okay?
>> There. No, they painted they they there
was a pipe that burst and so they had to
fix
cookie. I He might not be trustworthy,
but uh I like I liked him after that
interview with Ezra. Just I'm just
saying, you know, sun for a while. He's
very sharp. He's [__] super sharp,
but I know that that was like that
interview was Democrat porn. Just want
to that out there.
>> Oh yeah, I was living out for sure.
>> You're my boy. I'm not trying to to meme
on you or or like insult you or
anything, but it really like in order to
show
>> Don't worry about me.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. I'm not taking it personally. I
don't take it personally. I But I I
really want to emphasize that it's not
enough to show some trivial risk, some
insignificant risk. If you want to
demonstrate that there's culpability in
the context of increasing risk uh in
this context maybe I would grant that
there's some uh nominal duty to impose
these kinds of standards of moderation
on your own community absolutely but to
race for culpability uh with respect to
risk of the underlying act you're going
to have to show some significant risk
increase there and I don't think that
you even started to make that case for
for any of the creators like Caseyron
what the [__] what what is the evidence
that Casey Tron contributed to this
>> she she was um justifying it and joking
about it just the same. They were after
the fact. No, on no different terms than
someone on no different terms than
someone after the fact joking about
Charlie Kirk's assassination.
>> We saw the same thing contributed to um
his death. You would say this is in bad
taste. This looks bad. This is
independently a wrong thing to do. But
it's not
>> he's got nothing to say and he's just
sitting there like gritting his teeth
and shaking his head.
>> No, but it's not just a CPS call. Like
if you are if you as a creator and you
have a platform and and you're making
jokes about the CPS call or whatever,
you're you are contributing directly to
a culture that is being fostered in that
community of celebrating something that
I find to be like really reprehensible,
abhorrent, disgusting behavior. And
anybody in Ethan's position would have
been furious. Like do you understand
that? Like even if we found out, for
example, even if we could even if we
could say for sure that person came from
bad empanadas community specifically.
>> Oh, you would still justify too.
>> I WOULD STILL in my mind No, no, no. I
would still in my mind be um think and
and say that they're all culpable
because they're all contributing in
their own ways. And it's like obviously
we're getting very abstract here, but
that's that's where my mind goes with
it. Like it could have been regardless
of it could have been
>> regardless of the significance of the
rest any of them right like it could
have been it could have been any of them
so they're all responsible
>> so people calling Charlie Kirk a fascist
and saying
>> stop don't stop cuz you know you know
that's why you
know I don't no Charlie Kirk was a
national figure who had
more way more
>> wow it's bigger wow it's bigger you
can't compare it.
>> Idiot. Idiot. Idiot. Idiot. Idiot.
Idiot. [__] idiot.
>> But like if you're going to ask me is
not a national figure. Like what what is
the distinction here?
>> Like Charlie Kirk. What are we talking
about here?
>> Are we really making a distinction on
that? Like okay like Ethan I don't even
know if that's maybe in our bubble but I
don't I don't know that Ethan Klein is
lesser or more popular than Charlie Kirk
or more wellknown. They're comparable,
aren't they?
>> Like let me just ask you like Okay. So
you have family I assume. So like
>> Yeah. let's say a bunch of like like a
deranged MAGA person who who who
followed you.
>> Um there was a bunch of smaller
creators, you know, or big bigger
creators, right? Like and they all
started like memeing about how, you
know, one of your family members was
like abusing their kids and then CPS
showed up at the house, right? Like and
are you telling me you wouldn't be like
almost equally pissed at like everybody
who was possibly indirectly responsible
for that?
>> Yeah. I mean, I think that I would be
pissed at people who are making light of
it. people make it if I had evidence
that they were encouraging it. If I felt
that they were like spreading lies that
uh someone could take that way that's a
different you keep trying to find
different ways to ask the same question
which is could there be independent
obligations. Yeah, I'm trying to explain
like you're finding different ways to
ask it, but fundamentally you haven't
crossed a divide which is the mere
increase of a risk in violation of some
ethical obligation to you know moderate
or to be wise with your words or not say
stupid [__] that someone could take a
certain way that does not translate
culpability for the malicious vindictive
acts and we cannot conflate those levels
of responsibility or culpability and
what's being used to justify these
lawsuits. Um, again, putting aside the
issue of whether his intent is to
protect the React community, which is so
bizarre and [__] up and not true, but
even putting that aside, the the
argument you get is that [__] doesn't
even matter. Like, [__] that analysis
piece. Who cares about it? Because these
people are just so awful because they're
culpable for the CPS call. That's what
I'm what I'm hearing. And I just think
that that is just a totally wrong-headed
analysis.
>> I don't say listen, I think they did
awful I I think they did an awful thing.
I think all of them contributed to a
really awful thing and they all mocked
it and trivialized it. I think it was
disgusting.
>> Was it disgusting for Destiny to
ridicule Charlie Kirk's death?
>> I think so. Yeah, I said so at the time.
>> I said it.
>> Would it justify retribution
in in the form of legation?
>> Disgusting.
>> What is he culpable for?
>> I had people I had DGG in my audience
that were pushing back. I said, I don't
think this is funny. I don't think this
is a funny moment right now. And what is
he capable? What is he cable for?
>> I think I even
>> I think he's culpable for in that moment
for um contributing to a culture of
political violence through his rhetoric.
>> Isn't that the Republican argument?
>> No. The Republican argument would be
like Destiny himself is like directly
responsible because of this that or the
other thing. But we're getting into more
abstract kind of ideas, right? That's
the scope of my claim with respect to
denims is you cannot conflate the moral
ethical obligation with respect to the
substantive act with some kind of
>> I didn't but I still think what they did
was disgusting.
>> I think it was disgusting. I think it
was so dehumanizing. I think it was anti
>> peace. They sent Skol's house. Peace go
peace. Peace go
on there. You understand? Peace go.
And I think all of those creators
>> abused the influence that they had with
power on their own in their own like
way.
>> And I think they they knew that they
have that power. They know they have
that influence and they all knowingly
used it
>> knowing full well that the risk was
would go up of something like this
happening and they did it anyway.
>> Let's deal with Casey Tron. What act? So
the vindictiveness or the aggression or
the anger at Casey Tron is justified
because
>> they all did the same thing is my point.
They all
>> justified the CPS claims, joked about
it, continued to say that it was
justified.
>> What if anything did Casey Tron say
about it? You know,
>> I I'd have to pull up the videos. It's
been a minute. But all of them did.
>> You don't want me to do what you did to
me, right? Because I'm going to say
what? You don't even know the basic
things of what they said and you haven't
done your bare research to have an
opinion.
>> I know. You can ask my screen.
>> You understand? That's annoying, right?
That's That's [__] annoying to do.
Like you don't have
>> because I can't remember particulars,
but I'm telling you like you can ask my
stream. We've we've watched plenty of
Casey Tron clips. We've watched plenty
of videos.
>> Hutch's chat. Is Hutch really well
researched? Yeah, Hutch is really well
researched. Wow, that was a really
enlightening conversation. Wow, great
stuff. Wow. Thank you. Thank you, Hutch.
ing what all these various creators
said. I smoked a lot of pot for a lot of
years and I can't give you particulars
but they I'm telling you they all joked
about it justified it continued to
justify it. That's the point.
>> Okay. And given that the fact that they
joked about let's let's say assume that
Casey joked about CPS call, right? I'm
going to assume that for the purposes of
the next stage of talking about that she
joked about the the CPS call. Um
therefore it's justified to supposing
this is the motivation um to sue her on
that basis alone.
I think it's justified to want to impose
consequences and the debate would be
about like is this an appropriate
consequence and I've already told you
I'm somewhat agnostic on that. like I'm
>> okay
>> somewhat conflicted because
>> I'm sympathetic to his desire for like a
sense of justice or a sense of like
wanting to punish the people who who you
feel contributed in their own way to
your family like suffering in your own
personal suffering but I'm also
sympathetic to um like I don't want you
know I don't want denims to be her wages
garnished for the rest of her life or
>> like you wouldn't want them to be
financially destitute right for laughing
>> I mean I don't wish that on my worst
enemy you
And and obviously you like they
shouldn't be beat up for for joking
about it, right? They shouldn't be beat
up. They shouldn't be um you know, they
shouldn't be banned for it. Should they
be banned?
>> Well, I wouldn't I wouldn't be I
wouldn't condone violence. I mean, I I
you know, as far as they should be
banned like uh I I think it would be I
think it would be justified for for some
kind of like some kind of um penalty. I
I never I don't know if I've ever
>> advocated that people be permanently
banned from Twitch, but the fact that
like th those that crew, that crowd,
they get away. They've gotten away with
so much [__] that nobody else would get
away with.
>> They got a 30-day ban for a [__]
[__] tier list about who can say
habibi, dude.
>> And I think it's pretty obvious at this
point people in
>> I'm not here to deny that. That's why I
think that the level of research I've
done is appropriate for the scope of my
claims is I'm not making a claim that
they have got haven't or have gotten
away with.
>> You know, there's like six different
clips of Nicholas Dioro claiming that
Habibi is a slur.
He thinks it's like this this the C word
or like uncle uncle for Arabs
stuff. I'm not making a claim that
they're good or bad people. I'm not
making the claim that they haven't said
[__] that by itself is reprehensible or
bad. I don't think it's justified to
make in of implications that on the bare
thing that Ethan said, even the Jardia
thing. I think it's disgusting
oversharing that you would say that, but
that's just my own personal taste. I
don't think that it's justified to
conclude that therefore it's negligence.
I I don't and I think that anyone who
does you need more facts to establish
negligence in that it's a mere fact. But
but but just because I think that
doesn't mean that I think that they're
culpable for the underlying thing. And
here's
>> you.
What's that? Culpable for
>> Oh, yeah. That was that was literally
one of the categories on the tier list,
too, wasn't it?
>> It's like crazy how bad the [__]
research is from people who claim they
have standards like that fat [__]
Oh my god. No. [laughter]
>> For not substantive thing, but for
failure to moderate or whatever the
negligence perhaps in that, but not but
not like with respect to the actual CBS
call. That's the diff.
>> I don't know how to make sense of that
in my mind. Like she's negligent because
she's negligent because she she she did
something that increased the risk of
something happening and then the thing
happened, but but because she didn't do
the exact thing, you know, it's really
kind of trivial her negligence. I don't
I don't know how to make sense of that.
That doesn't make any sense to me. So I
think those are evidentiary problems on
all this, right? So there's an
evidentiary problem that the kind of
risk by making these kinds of like cute
little you know guys who this increases
significantly the risk of someone
calling CPS. I don't think that that's
established that the any one of those
jokes or something or even intimations
that something is wrong. The conclusion
therefore is that there's a substantial
and unjustifiable risk that uh a CPS
call will occur. So even just on the
like the empirical case for for this
being a significant risk um I don't
think that the people who are claiming
that it's a significant risk have made
uh their case for that. Secondly, to the
extent that they have any culpability,
so far the evidence, I think you'd agree
with this, doesn't show that they
intentionally tried to actualize a CPS
call. Fair.
>> Uh,
>> there's not enough evidence to conclude
that, right? So, I could be wrong
because people should not treat them as
though they intended it. Fair.
>> No, wait, but hang on.
>> Should they treat them? Wait, should
they treat them? First, answer that and
then you can explain. So, should they
I'm trying to go back to the question. I
understand, but I just want to hear this
first. Should people treat them as
though they intended a CPS call on on
current facts?
>> I think people should treat them as
though they uh explicitly justified it
to their audiences.
>> That's what I'm saying. That they
intended for this to occur and they
wanted it to occur.
>> Oh, I you'd have to ask her, but that's
not I mean that's not even the the most
relevant consideration though. Like that
kind of doesn't matter. like was she
intending for someone in her audience?
Does she better knew? She knew she was
taking a risk. She knew that she was
being uh well maybe maybe she didn't,
but like I think she knew. I think all
of them knew that that they were I think
they were like dog whistling about it. I
think they thought Ethan was evil and I
think I think that they think that
making him suffer was justified. All of
their rhetoric and behavior.
>> Do you think that they should be treated
as though they intended for this result
to occur?
I think it's it's understandable for
Ethan to to to view it that way.
>> Not what we've been asked.
>> The question isn't whether
>> here's the question isn't about
understand. Let me try to explain. Let
me try to explain.
>> You can say that I don't know. That's
fine. I just want to answer the
question.
>> No, let me let me try to explain.
>> Answer the [__] question, dude. It's
so annoy. Bro,
>> because like
>> like even if like again even even if we
could even if we could specify, okay,
the person came from Denim's audience.
Okay. The fact that it could have been
any of them, that's the point. No, so
like even if it came from like so so
that sense of like imposing
responsibility in a collective way,
that's where that comes from because
it's like
>> but to the extent that you're imposing
responsibility could have been any of
any of their audiences.
>> But but my question I'm asking isn't
whether you can
>> guys we've got another hour left on
this. We'll see how much we get through.
Now is a great time to remind you. Okay,
330 people watching right now. 116 likes
to stream 200 or so people. And please
know the curs thumbs on clicking or
pressing a thumbs up on the mobile
device. That would be huge appreciated.
If you want to take your support one
step further, there's a bunch of
different ways to support. Okay guys,
first of all, the stream elements link.
Very important. Direct direct donations.
We love direct donations. No YouTube cut
on those. Very epic. We love we love
stream elements. Very cool.
Uh you can also donate through YouTube.
You can support through YouTube. Lots of
way support through YouTube. You can buy
a membership to the channel. Gift a
membership to the channel. gift a whole
bunch of memberships randomly throughout
the chat. Buy a super chat which you
highlight a message and read out on CTS
or buy a super sticker. What's your
YouTube image or gift? It'll be
highlight in chat and I'll describe it
to you. You can go to discord.gg/quman.
Twitter.com or.comman
twitter.com. Very important guys. Very
important to go to Twitter. I'm always
retweeting clips guys. Always retweeting
clips. Do you want to see clips? You
want engage with clips? That's the place
to go. You'll get you'll get them.
You'll get them there. Very awesome
stuff. Lots of clips already up from
this stream. A huge huge shout out to
Substance on Twitter clipping this
stream right now. Huge huge W from
Substance. So, make sure you go and
check that out, guys. Yeah, let's carry
on. And yeah, this is an endurance test.
I kind of want to try and finish it
tonight cuz I I just don't want it to
drag over into multiple streams.
>> Post some level of responsibility
because we've already had the discussion
and we're going around circles on it.
The question is not precisely that. It's
should they be treated and not you
understand whether Ethan could have that
view.
>> Thank you for the five gift memberships.
[music]
Thank you. Huge appreciate. Thank you so
much. Thank you. Very generous. Thank
you.
>> That's not what I'm asking. I'm not
asking on Ethan's view. I'm asking on
your view. On your view and only your
view. Should people treat them as though
they intended for this result to occur?
Not on Ethan's view. Not that you
understand.
>> Honestly to us honestly to a certain
extent. Yeah. in virtually. Yeah. In
virtue of the fact that they continued
to justify it after the fact. Like it
already happened the first time. So if
you're justifying it after the fact,
we're like, "Actually, I think it was
good that CPS got called."
>> Are you as though they wanted it to
occur and were intending it to occur?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> I don't agree with that. I think it's
>> after after the fact they're saying
actually it's good that they were
called. It was justified. Are they not
significantly contributing to the risk
of it happening again at that point?
>> I mean, I I don't happen to agree. I I
don't
>> Is it all memes? Are they all joking?
Should I not take them at their word or
what?
>> I don't think that mere justification of
an act um by itself entails that it's
significant for the act to to reoccur
that you've increased the risk. I think
that there's more of a burden that you
need to show. I don't think that's
>> to me that event was like just such a
clear case of almost sociopathic levels
of harassment and if you're after the
fact saying it was a good thing that it
happened
>> you're
>> who said that I think you're
>> all of them
>> they all said it was so they all said
that it was good justified it
>> they all said it was good that CPS was
called
>> yes
>> I haven't seen that I mean I've been
having these debates for I even think
Ethan backed away from that claim didn't
he make a video saying he never alleged
that Denims are responsible or justified
it.
>> No, what he said was that Denims didn't
tell his audience to call CPS. That's
what he said.
>> So, so what do you take to be the
justification that for the CPS call
specifically that Denim said? Do you
have any even like notion of what was
said that after it she like laughed?
>> We just saw that. Hold on. We just saw
that. We just saw the same video. We,
you know,
>> that was before. That was before.
>> That was before. That's even worse.
>> But, but that wasn't Oh my god. Oh,
wait. It's so [__] stupid, dude.
>> Of course it was. What do you mean? Of
course it was. No, it wasn't.
>> No, it wasn't. No. CPS had nothing to do
with what was being said in that, dude.
His kids have giardia and they might
die.
>> Is that a justification for A CPS CALL?
>> YES.
>> NO. WAIT, WAIT.
>> YEAH. If someone's kids have a disease,
you could you're allowed to call CPS on
them.
If someone says, "My kid has has a flu,
you're allowed to call CPS on them."
That's Hutch's position. What are we
saying here? What are we like? He's
Yeah, he's justifying the CPS lie right
now. I'm shaking. I'm [__] shaking.
I'm justifying the CPS lie against
Ethan. I'm [__] shaking.
>> Hang on a second. [clears throat] The
mere fact that
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN? The mere the mere fact
that a child contracts a disease illness
even through a potential like a
negligence event that is not
justification for a CPS call.
Justification for CPS call would be
something like this.
>> Wow, they're you know a danger like I
think that CPS should be called or
someone should talk to the government
about this or this would like people
need to check in on his kids and like go
to the authorities. Those are things
that sound like justification for
intervention. Pisco, she said or or very
explicitly implied that Ethan Ethan's
kids might die.
>> That's not a justification to call CPS.
>> No, it's not. No, it's not.
>> What? Come on, bro. Are you What are we
doing here?
>> So, the mere fact that a
>> I'm getting a little frustrated with
you. Of course, that's why CPS exists,
bro. I'm not saying she was right about
her her um her analysis of like Gardia.
Apparently, Gardia is like very common.
But she was telling her audience like
that they have this thing and they might
die.
>> That's what she said.
>> So is
>> CPS exists.
>> If I had if I had that view, you're
saying if I had the view that this is
dangerous for the child and that they
were negligent, that that means I'm
justifying CPS.
If you're telling your audience that
someone's kids might die because they're
being neglected, then yes, that's an
obvious like assume she was being assume
she was correct,
right? Like assume assume assume she was
correct and they were being neglected
and they might die. Was that is that a
justification to call CPS?
>> Yeah. No, like like I I think that
someone could use that as part of their
justification to call CPS. That's
different. No, let me let me explain.
No, no, you need an additional
assumption. You need an additional
argument to call CPS. I'll give you an
example, right? So, there are f I'll
give you an example. You're going to
agree with this one, right? So, if
someone says, you know, if you don't
vaccinate your kids, it's dangerous to
the health of your kids. And and look,
these guys aren't vaccinating their kids
and it's dangerous to the health of
their and they could die if they don't
get vaccinated. Look, there's something
on. Is that justification to call CP? Is
that person justifying CPS calls? Yes or
no?
in their minds and to their audience.
>> Yes.
>> No. The mere fact that you're saying
that people are imperiling the lives of
their kids is not a a justification for
calling CPS. And the example I just
provided, you would never say if a
liberal like I'll just give an example.
>> You're not you're not understanding my
point. You're not understanding my
point. You're sailing past my point.
>> Oh my god. Cuz you know it crushes your
argument. Cuz you know it crushes your
[__] argument. The question, it's not
about whether or not Giardia actually
represented what a mortal threat to the
kids. That's not the point. She was
claiming that the kids were going to die
because they were being neglected.
>> Wait, so so
>> and so she claimed that they're going to
die. Wait, did she claim they're going
to die?
>> I didn't hear that.
>> That's You just watched the same clip,
man. Do you need to watch it again? We
watched it twice.
>> So So
>> she said kids can die from this, bro.
That's what she said.
>> Okay. So, oh, I'm this is the context in
which I'm giving you I'm trying to apply
your standard to a case to see if you're
consistent. This is testing you. It's an
>> the dog [__] that is all over.
>> That's true. Dude, how is it how is it
that like maybe once a week I I look
into what Ethan Klein's been up to and
every time I manage to find more and
more terrible [__] This is where Ethan
tells a story about his family getting
giardo.
>> We already have mold Mondays. Now we
have [__] Saturdays.
>> Also, this is not a joking matter, by
the way. It can be very severe and
deadly to small children. I mean, much
like many other illnesses. It's very,
very, very dangerous when infants get
the same sicknesses that adults get.
There are lots of things that you can
get as an adult. You're totally fine.
You'll be a-okay. No problem. A child, a
small infant that has no immune system
shouldn't be catching anything.
>> No wonder his house is covered in dog
[__] So she we're you know the rest of
it there is stuff there but not that
relevant. So she didn't say that at all
did she Hutch? She didn't say that.
>> She read a chat message said can be
deadly. She didn't say they could die
broch
that the kids were going to die because
they were being neglected.
>> So so
>> and so she claimed that they were going
to die. Wait they're going to die.
>> I didn't hear that.
>> That's you just watched the same clip
man. Do you need to watch it again? We
watched it twice now.
>> Okay. So, so, so
>> she said kids can die from this, bro.
That's what she said.
>> Okay. So, I'm This is the context in
which I'm giving you I'm trying to apply
your standard to a case to see if you're
consistent. This is called testing you.
It's an internal critique. I'm trying to
see if you're being consistent. Right?
So, if a liberal is watching a video of
some conservative say, "I didn't get my
my kids are totally unjabbed and on
everything. I didn't give them the jab
of anything. I don't give it on COVID.
Let me finish the question, Hutch. Uh on
COVID, I didn't give him the jab on uh
MMR. I didn't give him this on anything.
And frankly, I think the health results
speak for themselves. And they they
they're fine. And and a liberal
commentator says this is very dangerous.
They could die of these various
different illnesses. This is so
negligent. Is that yes or no them
justifying calling CPS
>> in their minds? [laughter]
>> Yes. No. No. No. NO. YES.
>> [laughter]
>> OKAY. SO, sure the words aren't
justifying it, but they're thinking it.
They're think I know they're thinking
it. I know they're thinking it,
dude.
>> I think that's it. It could justify
someone if someone intervention.
>> So, if if someone calls CPS in virtue of
that statement, would you apply
culpability to the person who said,
"Hey, this is dangerous."
>> Perfect.
>> No, you wouldn't. YOU [__] WOULDN'T.
OKAY, say what you want to say and then
let me say what I want to say. Go for
it.
>> Okay, so let's say I'm like a super
provax like YouTuber streamer guy and
like my content is like focused on like
uh Fizer being [__] awesome and all
the vaccines being so great and and
let's say I cultivated an audience of
like thousands of people and my whole
thing is that you know like MAGA parents
are putting their their kids at risk for
uh that they might kill their their kids
because they might get co and they might
die. And then I said like and then I
implied um that that uh that uh yeah
like their kids might die. And then
somebody in my audience or or or shortly
after this happened like called the
authorities and tried to have government
intervention like this. This is
>> and then afterwards
>> would I be partly afterwards? No you
wouldn't. No you wouldn't. So if
afterwards if afterwards this goes out
what
>> you would not be. This is not
that.
>> I literally do. This is how So if
afterwards someone called CPS on the
antivax or whatever and the streamer
came out and said, "Guys, why the [__]
did you do this? This is wrong." No one
would be like, "Hang on. Uh, you
justified the call of CPS." They'd be
like, "No, that's not what I said. I
didn't justify."
>> Sure. Sure they might. Sure they might.
>> But who would who would have the better
of the argument? The guy who said, "Yes,
you told me to do it."
>> Doesn't matter. Who cares? The argument
doesn't matter.
>> Who has the better of the argument
doesn't matter. She was making a shitty
a like a um uh unscientific claim as she
often does. By the way, she was making a
bad claim. It's not true that like that
that the giardia was as deadly as she
was presenting. I think like a quarter
of kids in the country at any given time
have giardia or something like that. But
um but but that's not what she told her
audience. She told her audience that
Ethan's kids might die.
You could I'm the example I'm giving you
is one in which that the same kind of
same these kids could die if they go
don't go don't get vaccinated. You
understand the lethality rate for this
if you don't vacate.
>> No, but there's precedent but there's
legal precedent like right like I think
people generally kind of or they could
Google stuff when like when is it
appropriate to call um CPS? If it was
true that Ethan was neg neglecting his
kids in the way that they were
suggesting then it would be justified to
call CPS, right? There's a there's
there's an additional inference that you
need to make that that that I would
impose on anyone claiming that this
person is culpable for that action that
I could say something like this. So,
I'll just tell you, right? Like,
>> no, you didn't answer my question,
though.
>> Wait, wait, what was your question?
Sorry, I I I missed it then. Say again.
the if you found out that parents were
neglecting their kids to the extent that
the kids were literally um like playing
with dog [__] and contracting um uh
>> what is it a viral disease? What is
whatever it is?
>> I am not a doctor.
>> Okay. Uh if if you knew that parents
were leave out let's leave out giardia.
If you knew that you there were some
parents out there that were neglecting
their kids so much that their kids were
were playing with dog [__] just like all
throughout the day.
>> Would you be justified and call it CPS?
I'm not sure that you would be
on on those facts alone.
>> In my view,
>> there there's no way you think this.
>> No, there's no way you think.
>> What I'm saying is they're very
different things, right? Like that a
person making the argument that it would
just be justified on those facts. That's
different. Like if someone were to give
out those facts and ask you the
question, is it justified to call CPS?
Then congratulation, you justified CPS.
But there's an additional inference that
needs to be made that government
intervention in this specific case is
warranted. And there could be a a ton of
contravening factors that would cause
someone to say notwithstanding that it's
negligent, notwithstanding that there's
a risk of uh someone a kid being
materially affected in terms of their
health that calling CPS is still not
justified given X Y Z. there's an
additional set of inferences and
considerations that any reasonable
person is going to think about,
especially half of these people who
don't even think the police should exist
and think that like everything should be
[__] social workers and there should
be no coercive force of the state at
all. So all I'm saying is you haven't
made your case alone by saying they call
justify CPS by stating merely that they
thought that there was a material effect
on health and that they're negligence.
And even here like is less of an
inference given the fact that she didn't
actually say that. She just kind of like
and so like
>> No, no, no. She said that kids uh will
die from that disease.
>> No, she didn't.
>> That that she agreed that bad empanada
was like she agreed with all that and
she said that kids die from that and
it's very serious. Like what if a kid
went to school and told his teacher, "My
parents neglect me all day and I play
and dog shit." Would the teacher be
legally obligated to call the
authorities?
>> That's different. Yeah. No, I think that
there there could be a duty to report in
those circumstances. That's a se that's
a separate question. It's ra whether the
individual that's a separate question
from whether the individual who made
such claims is themselves justifying CPS
to be called. They someone could make
that claim. You ackn I I want to hear
you acknowledge this. All right. Someone
could make that report and say, "Yeah, I
saw them playing in dog shit." D and
then let's say the teacher is a
mandatory reporter. Call CPS and then
they go there and the person who said
that, "What the [__] Why did you call
CPS? I didn't want you to do that." And
there's nothing there's no contradiction
there. Agree. Yes or no?
I don't follow.
>> Okay, the example is as follows. A a kid
or let's say another adult, a fellow
adult talks to a teacher and says, you
know, Billy, they're they're letting
them play in like this very dangerous
backyard. I I don't think that it makes
sense. I just, you know, I I don't know
what to do about it. Tell the teacher.
The teacher understands their
obligations to that they're mandatory
report or whatever. And they go and say
that and then the teacher comes back and
says, "I had to take your, you know,
your [__] to the higherups." And then
the person who reported it says, "What
the hell? I trusted you. Why did you
call that? That was wrong to do. Why'd
you do that?" And there was no inconitu.
>> Oh my god. The question is, is there an
inconsistency between the person who
made that complaint and them being
frustrated and upset that CPS was
called? Is there an inconsistency? No,
there's not, Hutch. No, there's not.
someone could take the view that
notwithstanding the risk to the child
that notwithstanding the fact that
there's uh you know perceived negligence
that that the cost and harm of calling
CPS
I [laughter] we're at like such base
level [__] man does this
>> it's it's I don't quite how to say it
but it's like literally like there are
two things that obviously are not in
contradiction
And for some reason, Hutch is just
having to pass him out like as if, you
know, it's as if sympathy for Ethan or,
you know, feeling a certain way about
how he treats his kids or whatever, he
immediately justifies like the um
the firm belief, the the assessment and
the action. Just because you understand
where they're coming from or you can see
a perspective, automatically everything
else is entire. No, it's not. obviously
>> make an additional inference before you
make the claim that they justified it.
Unless you're willing to grant the
vaccine cases, which I I don't even know
like are you even trying to distinguish
those? How are you even trying to
distinguish those?
>> We're what what I'm getting at is the
what what Denim's alleged she supported
these claims. She agreed with the claims
and expanded on them. The claim that she
was making was that Ethan's kids are
being so severely neglected that they're
playing in dog poop and contracting
serious diseases that can kill them.
>> Right? Those are facts from which one
could justify uh calling CPS. They are
not themselves a justification for CPS
statements.
>> But I'm not making that claim. I didn't
make that claim. No, but the the whole
point of raising this is to say the mere
fact that someone has that opinion. You
should not carry with that the intent
that they that they want to actualize
the state of affairs in which CPS is in
fact called. And what I'm calling out is
a notion that people will claim that
based on these statements that they were
advocating it happened that we should
treat them as such. And that was your
claim.
>> She didn't but she didn't present it as
an as an opinion. She presented it as a
fact. Ethan's kids are being severely
neglected. They're playing in [__] and
they're contracting diseases that might
kill them.
None of what I just said is why is none
of what I just said turns off I'm trying
to demonstrate I'm you said before that
her um lack of moderation was was uh
negligent and I'm trying to demonstrate
why it was negligent is because what she
said somebody who's watching her stream
who takes her as a good faith actor who
takes her at her word might feel uh
justifiably concerned about uh Ethan's
kids.
>> That's true of anyone because of that
lie. That's true of anyone who even
watches the video at all. Even to do the
the the bare minimum of criticizing the
view. The mere fact that someone could,
right? Doesn't mean that it's likely.
No, no, no. Hang on.
>> It's not the same thing, bro. If you're
watching a video and criticizing it,
you're saying, "Well, the same thing
like if you keep running, it's just kids
are going to die.
>> If you keep running if you keep running
into the same wall, I'm I'm gonna bring
it up every time. the mere fact. You
don't need to just show that the mere
like it's possible that someone could
have that interpretation. What you need
to show is that they either intended it
or that it's extremely likely like
likely that it would occur given those
statements. And I I just don't see a
case for that. But but that's
>> we haven't even reached the lawsuit
aspect of it. This is just to like I
think this is an insanely harsh
standard. And I'm not just saying that
because they're [__] lefties. [__]
them. And they and they did this [__]
with [__] Kamla and whatever. I don't
think that they endorsed Kamla and all
this other [__] about the election. I'm
not here. I'm just here because I'm
noticing [__] and it's making people
upset that this kind of standard of
moderation where they're responsible for
the substantive acts because they they
fail to moderate responsibly. That is a
standard that ought not be applied to
people across the board and it is not
applied to people across the board.
>> So she was negligent but she has no
responsibility.
>> She is she is negligent to the extent of
violating the obligation to
>> they hate it when you notice. They hate
it when you start noticing risk. What
she's not culpable for is the actual
calling of CPS. That's what she's not
culpable for.
>> No,
>> nobody made that claim.
>> THEY ARE MAKING THE CLAIM. HUTCH. What
the [__] Are you even in the disc?
People are claiming
>> Who said who said that she like called
CPS? That's not the statement that's
being made. Hutch.
>> No. No. No. Culpable for the CPS call
doesn't mean she literally called CPS.
All right. Culpable means morally
responsible for the CPS call.
>> That's what
>> obviously is she is obviously uh
ethically responsible to moderate her
audience and to be responsible with her
>> like every other creator and very
serious consequences that happened as a
result of actions that they all took.
>> They all did it. All of them did the
same thing. And they're all, in my
opinion, responsible
>> as though they're as though they're
intentional actors. And one
>> Ethan literally did say she was culpable
and had to walk it back. For sure.
>> I I I don't think that you would ever
apply that standard to
>> anybody of your No. No.
>> You You think I'm You think this is
about the fact that they're like
lefties? That's what this is about.
Really?
>> If I call So, for example, I call
>> a bunch of MAGA people in the
administration and these influencers
fascists. You agree that that could lead
someone reasonably to take that as we
should kill them. But you would not
>> No, no. We have a difference opinion
about reasonleness here because fascism
is a real thing. There's descriptors.
You can make the case and this that and
the other thing and then you can also
make the case a lot of it subjective and
people disagree the way that No, no, no.
The the difference again is that like
there is no element of you even remotely
implying that it would be justified to
do political violence. The difference
between that and Denims is that she did
>> lay out her justification a
justification and attempt
you wouldn't say
>> you wouldn't say you wouldn't say
because I called Charlie Kirk a fascist
>> now someone could take that statement
and believe it's true
>> and then justify the action against
Charlie Kirk but I am not justifying
>> no this is what Republicans do right
they think because I call Charlie Kirk a
fascist that I am saying he should be
killed But that's an inference that I
didn't make. I'm the the scope of my
claims are the scope of my claims. Now,
there could be instances in which one
could imply it. I'm not saying I'm not a
literalist, okay? And don't try to paint
me as a literal. I'm not a literalist.
>> Just likely contradicted what he was
saying two seconds ago. It's so [__]
annoying, bro.
>> Denims. There is not even an implication
there that what she wants to see, what
she wants to actualize is the state of
affairs in which CPS is called. And even
Ethan has backed away from that claim as
I understand it. that that but
nonetheless her and all of them
contributed in their own ways with their
own communities
>> just like I did to Charlie who
>> no I don't I don't find this analogous
at all. Can you explain why
>> can you explain why they're different?
>> Because you are trying to make the case
that it is plausible that she didn't she
didn't see what was going on in her
chat.
>> Like you're trying to and I don't
find that plausible. [laughter]
I think she obviously saw that and I and
I suspect that's why she started to go
down that road rhetorically even talking
about that. I think she was bouncing off
of them at that point.
>> I think that is the logical inference.
But I'm what I'm telling you is a
Republican can come back and say,
"Listen, I don't care." You know, Pisco
didn't moderate his chat when they were
calling Kirk fascist. Uh there were
people in his chat saying, "Uh, Kirk is
like a Nazi." They're saying, "No,
that's not the same. Why not?" Explain
why. Explain why.
>> To make it the same. To make it the
same, you would have to have people in
your chat that were saying we should
unalive Charlie
>> explicitly. Explicitly.
>> Yes.
>> Explicitly. And if the case is that I so
and and if I see that and don't moderate
the thing, I'm responsible for Kirk's
death. I want to hear you say that.
>> I would say in that moment that you were
responsible for contributing to a
culture.
>> That's not what's being asked. That's
not what's being asked. Hutch. That's
not what's being asked for the 500th
[__] time in this conversation.
>> I would say that about you without any
evidence that Tyler Robinson that first
of all that my contribution is
negligible. We would have to not know
who we would have to not know who shot
him for this to be analogous. Right.
>> But at the time I I saw someone say kill
Charlie Kirk and I'm just like whatever.
I'm not going to ban this guy.
>> At that moment I am contributing to a
culture that could cause the death of
Charlie Kirk and so I'm partly culpable
if he's killed.
>> I don't I see where you're going with
this, but you're but in that moment you
would be contributing in your own way. I
think that is like a much more kind of
abstract kind of situation here because
Charlie Kirk has the attention of like
so many other people. So it's like it's
almost like infinitely bigger than what
we're talking about right now. Whereas
what I'm talking about is a very
specific
>> Charlie Kirk is infinitely more famous
than anything you think. That's not
true, is it? Hajj
>> group of like a dozen people who were
all pushing the same thing about this
situation. But I would say in that
moment they were being irresponsible.
No, no. I grant that though. I No, I
grant that. But the question isn't am I
being responsible? I'm going to keep
going to this. It's the am I culpable
for the murder.
>> Culpability. We're quibbling about the
word culpable.
>> That's precisely what we're doing.
>> It's a difference of opinion. I think
we've reached the point where it's just
like agree to disagree.
>> I do think I do think you have a
responsibility and I think they are.
>> No, but when you say that it's a plan
that I that I think they don't danced
and joked about this situation, it was
[__] disgusting. Don't say it like I
don't think they have a responsibility.
You just heard me acknowledge that I
think they have a responsibility for
moderating and you know applying
standards of decency and whatever and
all that stuff. What I'm saying isn't
that they don't have a responsibility.
What I'm saying isn't that they don't
have a responsibility. What I'm saying
isn't that they don't have a
responsibility. What I'm saying is they
don't have uh culpable responsibility
for the specific malicious act
underneath it. No, but you just said a
moment ago. You just said a moment ago
that there's a nonzero chance that that
that uh that Denim's um rhetoric and
behavior that day indirectly led to it
happening. You said there was a non-zero
chance that yours did, right?
>> No, there's not.
>> Is there a nonzero chance that yours
did?
>> You would agree that there's
>> is there a nonzero chance yours did?
That was a sufficient.
>> Why would you estimate or the chances?
>> I'm not you apply to condition. So you
apply you apply you apply to answer that
question. Yeah. So I I think that yours
is probably smaller, but you applied a
sufficient condition.
>> Smaller. I want a Give me a percentage.
>> Probably givingven the the scope of your
audience and your statements, you know,
in my opinion significantly smaller. But
but hang on a second.
>> But no, no, I want I want a number. I
want a number. What What's the
percentage likelihood that it came from
my audience versus uh denims? If you had
to pick numbers,
>> I think orders of magnitude maybe
something like
>> Okay, then stop. Stop. But but but
>> Hutch, listen to my thing. You said that
a sufficient condition is nonzero
chance. That's your standard. So I
acknowledge that there's a difference
between the likelihood between your
audience and hers. But what you said,
right? I'm just reflecting your standard
what you said to me. And I just want to
make remind you. You said, but you
acknowledge there's a nonzero chance.
And so I come to you. Well, you agree in
your case there's a non-zero chance. And
so you say, well, isn't there a
difference between us? Yeah, but so we
have to actually get in the weeds about
what we think is significant. And you
don't want to get in those weeds. And
that's why we're pointless.
>> There is a big difference here in this
situation because you know why I'm not
culpable? You know why I could like rest
my head at night knowing that I didn't
contribute?
>> I never [__] made the claim that it
was justified to call CPS and I never
would and did and did no matter how much
I dislike I never
did. So you you said you said you're not
you said you're not culpable because you
didn't make the claim that it would be
justified to call CPS. Did denims in
fact did denims Wait, so I'll just ask
them one at a time. Did denims make the
claim that it would be justified to call
CPS? Did she make the claim? Did she
make the statement?
>> Are we is the answer no?
>> Are we circling back to this for the
fourth time now?
>> So So factors
>> we're back there. We're back there now.
These are like ad hoc factors that
you've um created that it's um
>> ad hoc.
>> They're not relevant. What do you mean?
>> They're outcome oriented. They're
outcome oriented. They're the three
sacred factors because these are what
you think that for the purpose of
getting to the results you want. Those
are the ones that matter to you. But the
the three factors that you're talking
about
>> No, they matter just because they
matter, bro. I'm telling you why.
>> Okay. But I hang on. I grant that it was
irresponsible. So why are you saying I
don't I don't know why you keep doing
this. Right. I granted in the first
second that it was irresponsible. Do you
remember when I granted that in the
first second? Do you remember that? I'm
asking that question.
>> Yeah. But I can't reconcile it with
everything else you're saying
>> because you really don't see a
difference between ethical
responsibility versus one obligation
with respect to your moderation and the
responsibility for the underlying
malicious act. You really don't
understand the difference between those
two. I mean, I recall earlier in this
conversation you were saying like she
didn't have an ethical responsibility to
moderate her chat and now now it sounds
like you're singing a different
>> I never said that Hutch.
>> We'd have to go back in the [__]
stream.
>> Go in the [__] man. I I So I was
consistent. You said, "Does it increase
the risk?" Yes. Does it does there an
ethical obligation? Ought she do it? I
said,
>> "Yeah, she ought not play the Didn't you
Actually, I'm going to ask you. Do you
remember when I said that she should not
have played that uh bad empanada clip?
Do you remember when I said that?
>> Not really. My brain's mush.
>> I don't So like why if you're not
remembering things frazzled because my
brain is fried trying to trying to walk
you through my thinking here and trying
to like navigate. [laughter]
>> Dude, look at VO's face. He is like so
annoyed at this point, bro.
>> Yeah. Your your uh your your craftiness,
your casiness, your lawyer tricks.
There's no tricks, bro. It's very
simple, very clear. different ethical
obligations with different ways that
people interpret them. Right? A
violation of one ethical obligation is
have going to have very different moral
implications than another. So the
ethical obligation with respect to your
moderation abilities, with respect to
your your course of conduct for decency,
people are going to take from that a
different sense of just desserts than
one's uh ethical obligation with respect
to uh failure to avoid intentional
deprivations of rights or infringements
of privacy or you know malicious
conduct. that those kinds of um
implications are different as between
those two ethical obligations. That is a
very simple, clean concept and that's
not confusing at all. And it ought not
be confusing for you either.
>> My stream is uh experiencing problems.
It does this. Oh no.
>> I don't know why it's I don't know why
it's doing this.
>> It's weird. It's the same time every day
at like 3:30 I start dropping hella
frames and it gets bad.
>> For real. It's grade school [__] and
he's acting like it's law school [__]
That's so fact our country. That's just
so accurate. Russia, Soviet Russia.
>> I don't know what causes blackouts.
>> Hey, listen. At the end of the day, I
think uh I think you think that Ethan's
actions were disproportionate. And I'm I
I already told you like I'm open to
that. So, I don't even know what we're
arguing about. Like I'm open to the idea
that like and and I don't have a good
answer for you, you know? Like I I don't
know. I can't tell you if it's like too
much or if it's appropriate. All I can
tell you is that if I was in Ethan's
position, I fully understand
>> this is now call this out.
>> This is cowardly.
This is not a position. He's refusing to
take a position
because he knows that he can't justify
it. So, he's going to try and stay in
this line because he knows that any
serious interrogation on this topic
would mean he would have to change his
position. he would have to be on the
other side. So instead, he's going to
fence it, but just constantly signal
towards Ethan being right. It's so
cowardly,
>> right?
>> Try to impose con
>> I understand that on his on Ethan's
view. It's trivially obvious that he
would understand that that he would have
that view cuz he's the one doing it. The
question isn't on his view. It's on your
view as you
>> be justified.
>> Oh, so it's your view that it is
justified.
>> No, but I'm trying to give you the best
answer I can and I'm not trying to be a
copout. I'm not trying to give you a
copout answer. really not. But how how
it feels is like you ever have those
Israel Palestine debates where people
like I understand why Israel would do
this. I understand if I was Israel why
they would do this or I understand why
or even from the leftist perspective I
understand why Hamas would do that and
if I was in the Hamas's shoes okay but
that isn't the question right like who
the [__] cares like that's just trivial
it's obvious that if you're Hamas you're
going to understand you're going to like
have the sympathies that Hamas does and
same thing with you know Ben Gavir or
whatever the [__] or these
>> I've had those conversations I've had
literally those conversations so like I
understand
>> that is useless like masturbation it's
not like the question is do we think on
our I mean, I just No, I don't think
it's useless because like listen, like
there there's
there is no there is no like science to
this. You know what I mean? Like there
there just isn't. We can't we can't you
can try to appeal with like laws of
logic and that kind of stuff, but like
there is no like explicitly correct
answer here and and I am trying to be
nuanced and and and that's not me like
trying to wiggle out of taking your
position or whatever. Like
>> yes, it is. I you know I I am
sympathetic to like all the parties
involved here. I'm less sympathetic to
Denims these days to be honest with you.
I'm less sympathetic to her because I
just you know I don't know if you saw
her recent stream but
>> but
sympathetic for Casey if you think she
did this horrible thing and that she's
culpable for this awful you she you
called her sociopathic. Do you realize
you call her sociopathic? Why would you
feel sympathy why would you feel
sympathy for a sociopath? I just don't
understand on your view how you could
feel that.
I feel sympathy for people that get the
death penalty. I feel sympathy for
people that are, you know, in prison for
>> sympathy for Hitler. Is that what you
mean? The Kanye West version of
sympathy?
>> I mean, you're really testing my morals
here, but like, no, I I I really I I I
don't try to empath.
>> You know how bad he must have felt? He
killed himself. He literally killed
himself. Did you know how bad he must
have felt,
>> dude?
That's It's [__] up, man.
>> With people that I don't even like. Like
I I do try to I I do have sympathy for
people that have done
>> sociopaths that want to do horrible
things and are malicious in all their
conduct.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> And that want to take even kids away.
You feel sympathetic for them.
>> Yeah.
>> And you don't want you don't want to
ruin financially sociopaths who only
produce malice and bad things in the
world. I mean that
>> depends on the day you ask me and
depends on the day you ask me and what
mood I'm in, I suppose. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Isn't that what it is to be a human
being? Like do we really have perfectly
consistent kind of
>> You know what I'll I'll grant you this
Hutch. There are some times when I'm
like you know what Hitler didn't choose
to have the brain he did. You know these
sociopaths they are born slashnner
nurtured in a particular way that makes
them the way they are. But I didn't for
some reason I didn't think that that's
what you were talking about that
ultimately elastic version of sympathy
when you were talking about Caseyron. It
seemed like you weren't sympathetic in
the sense of well I'm sympathetic to all
beings regardless of what causes them. I
thought that you were saying something
more particular about her circumstances
and like uh that don't have to do with
like this kind of like ultimately
>> totally expansive version.
>> I think both it's both of those things
like the idea of like everybody in her I
don't know if she's supporting her
family. I'm not 100% up to date on her
situation there. But no, I wouldn't like
the idea of like her family uh you know
losing their home or something like that
if they were relying on her for
>> that's beneficial then like okay maybe
you feel some sympathy but like she
deserves it. She deserves to have to pay
all this money.
>> He didn't do that though. He didn't do
that though.
>> I'm asking you like do you think that
she deserved what she got?
>> Yeah.
>> Even though the copyright infringement
has literally
zero to do with
>> Yeah. Yes. Yeah. I think she I think I
think she deserved that uh that uh
little walk of shame. Yeah, I think she
earned that. I'm glad she doesn't have
to pay pay money for the rest of her
life.
>> Are are you often I mean the other day
you agree it was an insincere apology.
Do you often like people to give
insincere apologies and you get
gratification out of it?
>> What kind of a question I This is not a
very normal thing that comes up in life,
doesn't it?
>> I don't know why people get like
satisfaction out of uh these like fake
apologies that that aren't actual like
justice. Maybe in the sense of like if
they have
>> if I was pushed that what they did was
like truly horrendous or whatever. Um
the mere fact that it's
maybe it is a deterrent effect of some
kind, but that's just going to ground
out into our priors about and evidence
for the purpose of the lawsuit. So maybe
that's what um why there's a
distinction.
>> Well, do you do you do you think that
there should have been any consequences
for what they did
>> for copyright infringement?
>> No, no, no. Well, sure. I mean, I don't
know. That's a separate discussion. I
frankly I don't care about that
discussion. Uh, but like I'm talking
about this
>> isn't talking about the whole purpose
that like the whole purpose is whether
or not we agree with the lawsuits and
the lawsuits are about copyright. Like
how can you say you don't care about
>> the lawsuit specifically, but it's more
about just this idea of like imposing
consequences on somebody who violated
your family. Isn't that what it's about?
>> Yeah. But but you don't agree with
beating them up?
>> Sure. I obviously think that there's I
don't think they should be killed.
>> You don't think someone should I mean
you don't think that someone should call
CPS on them, right?
>> No, I don't. Right.
>> I think that would be really bad. of
your lines, right?
>> No, no. Answer the question. Answer the
question. Should there be should there
any consequences, right? Like,
>> yeah,
>> doesn't need to be legal, you know, but
like some accountability, some kind of
punishment, some kind of something,
right?
>> Yes. They should get like a slap on the
wrist from Twitch.
>> All right, then. That's that's the
that's the disagreement.
>> Okay.
>> Just the severity of it. Like, we agree
that she did a bad thing and she
deserved consequences.
>> You're banned for a day. You should
moderate your you should moderate your
chat more so so they're not actively
calling for CPS. That's what just
happened.
>> Yeah.
>> And you definitely should not be joking.
>> It should be proportional and tailored
to the kind of thing we're talking about
here. That's number one. And number two,
separately, if someone is being
deceptive about those,
>> he settled though. He settled though. He
didn't make her destitute. All she had
to do was apologize. All she had to do
was get up there and prostrate herself a
little bit
>> or what?
>> Apologize.
>> So, so, so the apology was extracted by
what? Why was
>> he had leverage?
>> Yeah. It was coerced by financial
motivations. Correct.
>> Because she violated copyright. Correct.
>> That don't that don't relate in summer
or substance to the underlying claim.
Fair.
>> No. No. I think I again I think it's
both. Like I think he genuinely does
care about like lazy react and I think
he felt but if I had to guess I really
don't know. If I had to guess I would
say he was probably more motivated by
the abuse that his family suffered as a
result of uh like a culture that arose
out of all of their communities. I maybe
don't you agree that he wanted them to
infringe?
>> Uh yeah, I think so. I think he was set
in a trap.
>> Yeah. So, in what sense can you say he
wanted to punish them for infringement
>> and that uh that this was a bad thing
that was done to him if he wanted a
predictable thing.
>> He wanted But you're saying he wanted it
to occur.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So, so the harm
>> there. Yeah. But wanting something to
occur like I I might want I I might want
a bad thing to happen because I think a
better thing will follow that bad thing.
Like we confronted we're confronted with
this in politics all the time.
>> Right. Right. So the but that's that's
my point that uh
>> yeah Hutch lost his bottle. Hutch was
like oh no too many people are going to
starve if we let our snap go for too
long because so uh actually cave to
Republicans. That was Hutch. That was
Hutch
>> is achieving the better result isn't the
grounding for the basis of what's going
on. It's the pretext. It's a pretext.
You agree it's a pretext,
>> but it it is to a certain degree, but
again, we disagree because I think it's
both. I do think he does genuinely care
about
>> lazy react. He obviously cares about it.
He's had a history of caring about it.
He confronted XQC about it, talked about
it on his podcast all the time. So
clearly this guy was already like he
does like give a [__] about that, right?
>> I mean I I grant that at at least at
some point he did care about the React
community that he did care about
copyright infringement. What I deny is
that this lawsuit is motivated by that
concern. That's what I deny.
>> Well, where's your certainty though?
Yeah. Where do you get the certainty?
>> It's it's based on my what I think are
reasonable inferences on a set of
evidence. Do you want to hear it?
Yeah, but you'd have to explain like so
like you acknowledge that he has a
history of talking about lazy react and
he car he definitely cares about that,
right?
>> That's one of the reasons that No, no,
no, no. That is part of my rationale for
why it isn't motivating this. So the
fact the track record here is not
helpful for him in this context given
the nature of what his stated rationale
was, it's hurtful. That seems
preposterous to you. I can explain why.
Um,
I'm a little stuck on your thing of
like, oh well, why would you want the
bad thing to happen when you're against
the bad thing? But it's like you could
use that logic to to say like, well, you
know, like why did the FBI do a sting
operation where there was a drug
transfer, you know, like selling drugs
is bad, right? So that doesn't make any
sense. Do you understand that that logic
is a little flawed?
What logic are I mean I don't understand
what
>> you're saying like oh well how could he
say he's you know he says he's against
the thing but he trapped them to do the
thing and it's like well you know I
don't understand what I'm what I'm
saying is um if you have a prior
principle
>> that one upholds and one sticks to the
principle then I think that that
justifies an inference that one is
maintaining the principle but if there's
a pre as opposed to a blank slate if
there's a previous principle and that
one makes statements either in
contradiction or or that undermine uh
that principle previously stated. I
think that that most people in view of
those uh what I take to be an
inconsistent application of previously
stated principles. The inference usually
from that is indicative of more deceit.
Right? A prior inconsistent statement
and statements that that don't make
sense in light of each other that
>> How long have we got left on this man?
Holy [__]
>> Intuitction.
Okay. That this is
>> about 20 minutes. Okay. Crazy
deceptive in setting a trap. Sure. You
know,
>> not merely that. I mean that I think at
a bare minimum you have to establish and
also you would agree.
>> I don't see the issue with that. You
know, like you're deceptive when you set
a trap for like vermin in your garden.
You know what I mean?
>> No, I I I understand that that in there
are contexts in which deception can be
justified. All right. That's not that's
not what I'm suggesting. The deception
that I think is not justified is what
he's stating to the audience. And this
is the the the what he's stating to the
audience.
that part of the reason, one of the main
reasons in fact, for bringing this
lawsuit is to set a precedent to protect
the destruction of the React community
as we know it from uh absolutely
shattering precedent that Disney or Sony
could set. Those are
>> Yeah, but the thing is it's like, yeah,
it is awesome. It's great content,
but it's great content for like an hour,
two hours. touch is too [__] for an
actual conversation. So, it it wears
quickly. And we are
like three and a half hours in. I want
to see the Loner Box conversation.
That's what I want. I need to see Loner
Box react to this. I need to see Loner
Box talk to Hutch about this. And then I
need to see Loner Box talk to PeaceCo.
And then and then [laughter] we'll be
I'll be happy. I'll be satisfied.
Are his words, Hutch? Do you believe
those words?
I have no reason to disbelieve them
explicitly to be honest. No.
>> Okay. The reason I disbelieve them is
because a they're not plausible. They're
not plausible at all. The notion that
Ethan might think that um suing
like Denims and Caseyron and um Rogan
would at all affect the the nature of
you know Disney and Sony suing and
establishing terrible precedent. That is
preposterous. The more outlandish a
belief is, the more the the more
unlikely it is that someone actually
holds it. That's only part. I mean, I
there's so much more that we can get
into.
>> Well, what if he's just wrong then? That
that wouldn't mean that he's lying.
Like, what if he believes it, but is
wrong?
>> I I understand that by itself, it
doesn't necessarily prove to 100%
certainty or even [__] a 90%
certainty that that's what's going on.
That's just part I'm building I'm
building blocks. All right? And you have
to look at the the wall as a whole at
the totality of circumstances. So, the
first piece of evidence is the rank and
plausibility of the claim. The notion
that someone who's fairly, you know,
learned about uh copyright infringement,
this guy um had lawsuits regarding
copyright infringement that he's lost
before, I think, and and now and he's
also won against the bold guy, that um
that he has this view that the this
intentional stated uh malice is the
scene quinon of copyright infringement,
the kind of way that he presents it in
the video is preposterous. One, as a
legal matter. Second, the notion that
someone like that Ethan Klein thinks
that when he establishes precedent on
fair use, given his view that the vast
majority of these kinds of react
channels that there's rampant theft,
what he calls theft of intellectual
property, that any kind of uh decision,
any kind of legal decision either from
from a legal precedent perspective that
that
>> blow the books shame Dorio doesn't
>> precedent is going to protect the react
community as opposed to
significantly curtail
>> Lon Box has shame. You can tell
Lonabox's embarrassed when he's saying
something [__] The Oreo does not
feel embarrassed when he's saying
something [__] He just makes
calculated risks about how far he can
lie.
>> The current meta, which is
overwhelmingly infringing, is ludicrous.
He must know that in pressing a claim on
a reaction video, he is going to give
the court an opportunity to opine on the
four fair use factors. By the way,
they're not exhaustive, but the four
main uh fair use factors. Yeah, I read
yesterday
>> in such a way. Right. Right. So, for
example, for uh purpose and character of
the work, usually the main focus of the
inquiry there is transformation. Any
precedent on summary judgment or
dispositive motion um related to uh you
know whether this is transformative or
whether there's a the character or
purpose of use um sides on the side of
fair use. The the court in coming to
these determinations go through all the
factors and they're going to go factor
one uh this is not transformative. It's
not transformative because look at the
percentage of the video. Look at how
much commentary is in there commercial
purpose. Um is this providing sufficient
commentary? How many portions of it, you
know, include commentary such that you
do you actually need this? And the the
tests start to merge because the purpose
and character of the use merges with
like the amount and substantiality here.
You know, Denim's used all of it. She
used the heart of the work. Was that
necessary to the nature of her critique?
especially when she's spending, you
know, this amount of time kind of giving
just bllythe remarks. Look at this
precedent from SDNY with this judge in
previous cases where it's more of like a
watch party as opposed to, you know,
deliberately splice things. Anyone with
a single brain cell, and Ethan surely
knows this, knows that these courts,
they go one, two, three, four. And those
factors aren't just going to bear poorly
on uh denims, it's going to bear poorly
on the React meta as a whole. the
specific thing he's saying he has no
intention to undermine uh and and that
is with respect to execute etc. But we
can keep going.
>> Wouldn't wouldn't it be the purpose and
character of the use? Wouldn't that be
the key consideration here?
>> Stated intentional mouse. [__] no.
There's a case called Warhol and what
Sonia Soayor in the majority writes is
that purpose and character of the use is
an objective factor. It is not
subjective. That the mere statements of
the artist don't uh make a a particular
purpose or character of the use a
particular thing or not. that case was
decided recently and there is certain
statements from old cases like Harper
and Row from the Supreme Court that
suggests that like good faith might play
a role in an analysis but in the most
recent president on on Scotas and in um
in the Warhol decision they said it's an
objective inquiry. It's it's not about
intentional stated like you could say so
for example it would be like saying the
following right at the start of your
stream you go this is transformative
this is fair use therefore it's fair use
and transformative the mere statements
of an individual is not uh part of the
analysis at all
>> okay all right uh now I'm curious do you
um
>> do you even disagree with Ethan that
there is rampant sort of abuse of of
copyright
>> of course not
>> you don't agree with that
>> no I don't disagree with
Okay. So,
>> that's why I think that that's one of
the reasons that this is disingenuous.
>> Okay. So, you don't disagree that
there's rampant
>> abuse. Yes. Get there. Come on.
>> Correct.
>> Fair. Fair use with with but
>> really chugging along as
>> exemplified by
Asmin Gold, Hassan [__] all these
people. So, what is your ideal remedy
here? To write new laws to ex to expand
fair use or because because you're
saying you don't want them to come back
with a decision that will like
fatally chill the react community so as
to basically like destroy it. So, like
what what is your preferred remedy to
this situation?
>> I just want to be clear it doesn't bear
on what I think theception is here. my
state of I just want to know because if
you don't if you don't agree with
>> I I do think that the current law is
such that um these react streams are
basically you know 80% infringement and
I think that there ought be new laws uh
that clarify the scope of you know
reaction videos maybe they're platform
specific maybe they they have certain
set sets of factors um but but no I
don't think that um I don't think that
in fact uh the current laws as they are
would be approving of the kinds of
content that you're seeing from all
these React streamers.
>> Yeah. It's like uh when video games
first started showing up on YouTube
stuff, technically all those gaming
companies could have filed copyright
claims and they still could today. In
fact, they do sometimes. I think
Nintendo has done it.
>> What do they do when there's an
infringement?
>> Uh they take the video down. There's
like a DMCA claim and they take the
video down, right? Yeah. So like but but
but but the thing with the video games
is like they just they all realized that
they would probably make more money if
they just allowed YouTube content
because
>> Oh yes. Yes. Yeah. Some have chosen
>> getting all this getting all these views
or whatever. And so so there's
>> some have chosen not to press potential
claims that they have.
>> Most mo the vast majority
>> I would say most go through the DMCA
>> because
>> for video game stuff no definitely not
>> to the extent that there's infringing
content to the extent
>> well it's all infringing. That's the
point. like anytime you post a video of
like yourself playing Call of Duty
>> to the extent that there's infringement
and they have a desire to uh take
action, what they do is they don't they
don't follow file a lawsuit. They they
have a DMCA takedown.
>> Right.
>> So the notion that setting precedent
that's an additional reason that this
isn't plausible. the notion that setting
precedent in the form of a legal ruling
which by the way now he's settling which
he isn't achieving so I I guess I don't
know what precedent it is but to to the
extent that there is any precedent it's
not going to curtail these kinds of the
main enforcement mechanisms of things
like Disney and Sony which is not
through lawsuits it's through DMCA
takedown notices that people don't
contest um and that they they are able
to take down [__] so like it's it's not
in any respect protecting only a fool
only someone who so deranged and um and
it really has no understanding would
think that this had any effect on what
Disney or Sony is going to do. And
that's even further that's even further
emphasized by the fact that what he's
settling with with uh with [__] Casey
Tron for some for marginal amounts in
which there's no [__] precedent been
established other than he leaned on
people for you know apologies that don't
relate in to kind of thing that
>> yeah I think that's the difference
between you and me is that even and you
might be right that that's what he did
like may maybe the whole maybe he didn't
get that had nothing to do with
copyright and I guess the difference
between you and is like that that does
not bother me in the way that it bothers
you.
>> So if the only intention was to make
these people destitute and he's lying or
or to impose a punishment for the other
statements that don't relate to
>> copyright.
>> Well, clearly clearly he didn't want to
make her destitute, right? Like you
settled, right? And if if the purpose is
not to protect the React community, but
is instead only for something that he is
not at all in any respect to protect the
React community. If that's the case, you
would have a problem with it, wouldn't
you? I thought you said that lying in
general is bad.
>> No, I didn't. No, no, no. I said that
precisely the opposite. I said not all
lies are created.
>> Oh, I said I said lying in general is
good actually. Right. Okay.
>> Equal. And this particular lie if it's
if because it's kind of content at the
same time, right? like he's got his own.
Oh, you can lie for content. Hutch is a
pedophile. Hutch is a pedophile. I have
on good authority. Hutch is a pedophile.
Hutch is a pedophile and I'm covering
Hutch to protect kids. It's for content.
What's the problem? It's for content.
What's the problem? What's the big deal,
Hutch?
It's just It's so [__] stupid. I
can't even like engage at this point.
retribution, his own kind of cause of
retribution. And it's also like this,
it's like a spectacle all at the same
time.
>> And so
>> I don't know how moral calculus that
it's a spectacle.
>> A lot of things could be spectacles.
>> I don't know how that
>> like
pedophilia like
it's like a show. It's like a like a
show sex offender
>> and I understand why he feels that way
>> and I punish him for being sex offender.
>> So we agree,
>> right? I don't know if I ever disagree
with that, but like I don't I don't see
that as necessarily a bad thing
>> and says from Disney and Sony when it
almost so clearly not. And and and also
it's not it's specifically not on the
ground that he states, which you
couldn't [laughter] have predicted at
the time he set the trap uh intentional
stated malice. That is certainly not
what he was planning to do when he set
the trap. So, in order to even buy that
that was in his mind, you'd have to um
come on, let's get to the end of this
now. I need to which precedent he wanted
to set uh in between when he said the
trap and when they did it. And
>> maybe maybe he's all over the place.
Maybe he convinced himself. Maybe he's
lying. Maybe
>> this is this is ultimate charity.
[laughter] This is ultimate charity to
Ethan Klein that you don't apply in the
slightest to the people that you hate.
>> That's okay.
>> I don't think that I don't think that's
true. I don't think that's true. I I
don't have enough information. Like I
could reach out and ask him, but like I
don't pry to that level. Like I just
don't know. I don't know.
>> To acknowledge. All right. This is this
is what I want. But I want him to
acknowledge is basically
>> see there it is. I can reach out and ask
him. And that's what this is all about
is avoiding taking a position so he
doesn't have to sell Ethan out because
it's his big YouTuber friend.
>> Like okay this is it's not true. When I
started with this whole react gate stuff
this isn't about that. It's not about
protecting from Sony and Disney. That
was wrong when I said that and I was uh
you know that really wasn't at all
motivating me. That's what I think would
be honest.
>> Isn't that kind of implied when when he
settled with with with Casey Tron and
now it looks pretty likely that he's
settled with Broen as well. So what you
just said, isn't it implied that isn't
at all motivating him when he settles?
>> Hey, that's
>> So you're mad that he lied. That's what
this is. Like that's that seems like the
such a minor part of this entire story.
>> I'm mad that he lied and also even
though I don't think it's a legal bar to
bring the claim. I actually think it's
chicken [__] to use copyright statute to
settle scores. Um even if it's a valid
claim saying even if it's a valid claim,
I think it's chicken [__] and wrong to
use the copyright statute to primarily
like settle scores on unrelated matters.
Especially
>> what did I say? What did I say last time
I covered the last Pisco conversation? I
was saying I wish Pisco would stake a a
firmer claim and say it is wrong to use
in bad faith unrelated statutes that
dude oh my god finally finally we're
here we're here
>> if you felt
>> if you felt like somebody abused your
family like actually abused your family
like very substantively impactfully
abused your family
>> well one I I think you have to raise a
certain level of misconduct and then
it's going to ground out into what about
before where do exactly um but second to
that I that like if they abuse, you
should like s to them for the abuse of
conduct. You should you should do the
thing that's tailored to the issue. I'm
not a big fan of these pretext and I
especially don't like um that it's kind
of solely in my image of Ethan as a
defender of copyright, the same
copyright approach, which he did, right?
It was beautiful, magical when he was
attacking XQC for his garbage, malicious
conduct, which it was. And Ethan Klein
says it was intentional siphoning when
XQC did it. And so I don't I don't buy
this thing. It's like, you know, I don't
mind thieving. What I mind is when you
say really bothers and I had this very
positive view of Ethan Klein as a as one
of the best people of like the lay
people and the influencers on copyright.
He would always jump to have like a
calibrated take that wasn't far-lefty
get rid of all intellectual property,
get rid of copyright, get rid of
patents, it's all theft, but he didn't
go as far as like XQC saying like or
sorry the opposite of saying we should
enforce all the time and there should be
no room for fair use. That kind of
thing. I really appreciated that and
this is always my image of it. And don't
try to [__] and also personally we're
going to go by malice. Oh, I mean Mike
from PA dude. What the [__] What the
[__] And then also by the way, wait,
did I say that? No, not you. He did. He
quote tweeted you. Not too dissimilar to
how you quoted Taylor Lance. We didn't
talk about that, by the way.
>> Wait, when did he quote tweet?
>> I saw that.
>> What did he quote tweet me? He didn't
go.
>> He basically said, "What does this do?"
He didn't stand up for me then. Just
saying. I don't think I saw that.
>> You didn't say I see that.
>> Okay. But he's basically comparing me to
some local and um
>> or people who consider local who never
actually, as I understand, was admitted
to the bar. Implying that I'm not a real
lawyer, implying that I'm uh you know,
misrepresenting myself, whatever. And
and basically uh
>> I stick up for you, bro. I do. I'm
saying I'm just saying like that
happened and and listen I don't first of
all I'm not have a conversation with me
or Dan Sman have a conver with me.
>> I mean I would I would like to see you
guys have a conversation but um but but
you know talk about moderation like
sometimes our spicy interactions evoke
strong opinions in my chat and you can
ask my I tell them all the time like I I
tell them all the time that we need to
compartmentalize like for me I'm a big
boy. I know you're a big boy. I know you
like the inter the intellectual exercise
of arguing. It's it's fun for you in the
same way that it is for me. you've
sharpened your your brain a little bit
more than I have in terms of like all
the legal stuff, but like I tell my chat
all the time like when that argument is
over, we're good. And so like I I try in
my own little way to manipulate and
dissuade people in we're good. But all
I'm saying is like I I understand that
people kind of have this question, why
is he spending so much time, part of it
is because as I think about it more, I I
just do think that there are certain
standards that we should expect from our
creators. And I think in most cases, um
I give you for example like the Timool
example where let's say that you're
reacting to something and it was clearly
copyright infringement and um he's just
trying to [__] with you because you said
something about Russia. Like I'm so I'm
so bad about the rush. I think his
stance is getting firm all the time.
Just like literally getting stronger
opposition. So good. Oh my god. Thank
[__] Thank [__] Can't can't be swayed.
>> You actually have that conversation and
we would all kind of stand. And so I'm
just trying to say like what how would
we react to this kind of tactic? And in
general, most people would be against
it. The one situation where we would be
in favor of it if if there's some really
just like predominating [__] up [__]
that these people did to a certain
degree of threshold. And what I've heard
from people who respected their
misconduct is in the realm of I'm just
sorry to say it's not this kind of like
we're extolling you to call CPS maybe
bad empanada maybe bad empanada so bad
empanada on that stuff but I haven't
seen the evidence for these people to
suggest that like they rise to that
threshold where I would kind of be
accepting of this tactic. That's what
I'm saying. I mean at the end of the day
that's what we're talking about. But but
it is kind of tactic that I find
unsavory and I think it's wrong.
You can disagree man. Hey I mean I hear
that. I do. I hear that. And I also know
that if like if somebody if it's if like
Esme is pretty insulated from internet
stuff that thankfully she there's been
some weirdos that have reached out to
her and like but if if I if I felt like
like an entire collective community like
pulled together and started attacking
her and making her life like really bad
and I had leverage, I would probably use
that leverage to try to like push back
against those people, whether it's like
legal leverage or whatever. Like I think
I would be I would be similarly
compelled to take action to try to
punish those people for hurting her. M.
>> So that's that's what I think about
more. Like that's where my mind goes.
>> If that's what's going on, then don't
give us this whole like and if you're
trying to bait them into something where
you would have leverage, which was his
plan, I don't want to hear this
implausible story that also
coincidentally magically I was thinking
about
>> copyright community.
>> If that's what it is, at least let's be
honest. That's all I want. And then and
then and if and if people say, "I don't
give a [__] what piece was saying."
Just, you know, you can say that, but
but then don't dispute it, right? Then
don't dispute it and just grant it and
say, "I just don't care because they're
they're good targets and that they ought
to be for what they did to Ethan. punish
him this way.
>> I think he can argue on that.
>> And again, I'm not speaking for Ethan. I
don't have any special insight. I don't
know if that's the thing that motivates
him. Like I I don't I can't I'm just
saying like if that was the case. If he
was motivated, I could understand that
impulse. But then why can I ask you a
question then? Why hasn't he celebrated
this as a massive win community?
>> I I don't I think it's likely that he
was primarily motivated by a desire to
punish those people. I just don't I
don't find that controversial or
>> Right. But if like that's where my mind
goes. I think like well yeah like
obviously he would be compelled to do
stuff like that.
>> If you thought this was a massive win
that just vindicated you and protected
you know we're saved this helps us
against Disney and Sony why isn't he
doing those kinds of things cuz he knows
it's not
>> my guess he was my guess is that he was
more motivated by retribution. That's
what I would guess but I got to go man.
It was a long conversation. Uh tomorrow
we talk Wait Monday. Are we talking to
Learnbox?
>> I think so. Yeah. I got to reach out to
him. But yeah
>> um we'll set up.
>> You know I love you man. I we get learn
but I do want you to know that
>> it's Monday. It's Monday
>> [__] harassing you. I don't want
people to do any of that [__] and I
really do appreciate it or back and
forth. I think that it provides some
life for live and learn and I and I
again don't want anything negative
affecting your way from anybody.
>> I'm directing my own. I'll talk to you
in a couple days. I stand this guy.
>> What was like 9 hours Rob for 5 hours
for 4 hours. Wow.